this is a full-length course from
treehouse we at free code camp are
longtime fans of their learning platform
they were kind enough to let our
non-profit make this course freely
available on our youtube channel if you
like this course treehouse has a lot
more courses like this one the link is
in the description
along with time codes to the different
sections in this course
[Music]
hi my name is passan i'm an instructor
here at treehouse and welcome to
introduction to algorithms
whether you are a high school or college
student a developer in the industry or
someone who is learning to code you have
undoubtedly run into the term algorithm
for many people this word is kind of
scary it represents this body of
knowledge that seems just out of reach
only people with computer science
degrees know about algorithms now to
others this brings up feelings of
imposter syndrome
you might already know how to code but
you're not a real developer because you
don't know anything about algorithms
personally it made me frame certain jobs
as above my skill level because the
interview contained algorithm questions
well whatever your reasons are in this
course our goal is to dispel all those
feelings and get you comfortable with
the basics of algorithms
like any other subject i like to start
my courses with what the course is and
is not
in this course we're going to cover the
very basic set of knowledge that you
need as a foundation for learning about
algorithms
this course is less about specific
algorithms and more about the tools you
will need to evaluate algorithms
understand how they perform
compare them to each other and make a
statement about the utility of an
algorithm in a given context
now don't worry none of this will be
theoretical and we will learn these
concepts by using well-known algorithms
in this course we will also be writing
code so i do expect you to have some
programming experience if you intend to
continue with this topic
you can definitely stick around even if
you don't know how to code but you might
want to learn the basics of programming
in the meantime
in this course we will be using the
python programming language python reads
a lot like regular english and is the
language you will most likely encounter
when learning about algorithms these
days
if you don't know how to code or if you
know how to code in a different language
check out the notes section of this
video for links to other content that
might be useful to you
as long as you understand the
fundamentals of programming you should
be able to follow along pretty well
if you're a javascript developer or a
student who's learning javascript for
example chances are good that you'll
still be able to understand the code we
write later i'll be sure to provide
links along the way if you need anything
to follow up on
let's start with something simple
what is an algorithm
an algorithm is a set of steps or
instructions for completing a task
this might sound like an over
simplification but really that's
precisely what an algorithm is
a recipe is an algorithm your morning
routine when you wake up is an algorithm
and the driving directions you follow to
get to a destination is also an
algorithm
in computer science the term algorithm
more specifically means the set of steps
a program takes to finish a task
if you've written code before any code
really generally speaking you have
written an algorithm
given that much of the code we write can
be considered an algorithm what do
people mean when they say you should
know about algorithms
now consider this
let's say i'm a teacher in a classroom
and i tell everyone i have an assignment
for them on their desks they have a
picture of a maze and their task is to
come up with a way to find the quickest
way out of the maze
everyone does their thing and comes up
with a solution
every single one of these solutions is a
viable solution and is a valid example
of an algorithm the steps one needs to
take to get out of the maze but from
being in classrooms or any group of any
sort you know that some people will have
better ideas than others we all have a
diverse array of skill sets
over time our class picks the best of
these solutions and any time we want to
solve a maze we go with one of these
solutions this is what the field of
algorithms is about
there are many problems in computer
science but some of them are pretty
common regardless of what project you're
working on
different people have come up with
different solutions to these common
problems and over time the field of
computer science has identified several
that do the job well for a given task
when we talk of algorithms we're
referring to two points
we're primarily saying there's an
established body of knowledge on how to
solve particular problems well and it's
important to know what the solutions are
now why is it important
if you're unaware that a solution exists
you might try to come up with one
yourself and there's a likelihood that
your solution won't be as good or
efficient whatever that means compared
to those that have been thoroughly
reviewed
but there's a second component to it as
well
part of understanding algorithms is not
just knowing that an algorithm exists
but understanding when to apply it
understanding when to apply an algorithm
requires properly understanding the
problem at hand and this arguably is the
most important part of learning about
algorithms and data structures
as you progress through this content you
should be able to look at a problem and
break it down into distinct steps
when you have a set of steps you should
then be able to identify which algorithm
or data structure is best for the task
at hand
this concept is called algorithmic
thinking and it's something we're going
to try and cultivate together as we work
through our content
lastly learning about algorithms gives
you a deeper understanding about
complexity and efficiency in programming
having a better sense of how your code
will perform in different situations is
something that you'll always want to
develop in hone
algorithmic thinking is why algorithms
also come up in big tech interviews
interviewers don't care as much that you
are able to write a specific algorithm
in code but more about the fact that you
can break a seemingly insurmountable
problem into distinct components and
identify the right tools to solve each
distinct component
and that is what we plan on doing in
this course though we're going to focus
on some of the tools and concepts you'll
need to be aware of before we can dive
into the topic of algorithms if you're
ready let's get started
hey again in this video we're going to
do something unusual we're going to play
a game and by we i mean me and my two
friends here brittany and john
this game is really simple and you may
have played it before it goes something
like this i'm going to think of a number
between 1 and 10 and they have to guess
what the number is easy right
when they guess a number i'll tell them
if their guess is too high or too low
the winner is the one with the fewest
tries all right john let's start with
you i'm thinking of a number between one
and ten what is it
between you and me the answer is three
uh quick question does the range include
one and ten
that is a really good question so what
john did right there was to establish
the bounds of our problem
no solution works on every problem and
an important part of algorithmic
thinking is to clearly define what the
problem set is and clarify what values
count as inputs
yeah 1 and ten are both included is it
one too low is it two too low is it
three correct
okay so that was an easy one it took
john three tries to get the answer let's
switch over to brittany and play another
round using the same number as the
answer okay brittany i'm thinking of a
number between 1 and 10 inclusive so
both 1 and 10 are in the range what
number am i thinking of
is it 5 too high
2 too low
is it 3 correct all right so what we had
there was two very different ways of
playing the same game
somehow with even such a simple game we
saw different approaches to figuring out
a solution
to go back to algorithmic thinking for a
second this means that with any given
problem there's no one best solution
instead what we should try and figure
out is what solution works better for
the current problem
in this first pass at the game they both
took the same amount of turns to find
the answer so it's not obvious who has
the better approach and that's mostly
because the game was easy
let's try this one more time now this
time the answer is 10.
all right john you first is it one too
low is it two still too low is it three
too low is it four too low is it five
still too low is it six too low is it
seven too low is it eight low is it nine
do low is it ten correct you got it okay
so now same thing but with britney this
time
is it five too low
eight too low is it nine still too low
it's ten
all right so here we start to see a
difference between their strategies when
the answer was three they both took the
same number of turns this is important
when the number was larger but not that
much larger 10 in this case we start to
see that britney strategy did better she
took four tries while john took 10.
we've played two rounds so far and we've
seen a different set of results based on
the number they were looking for
if you look at john's way of doing
things then the answer being 10 the
round we just played is his worst case
scenario he will take the maximum number
of turns 10 to guess it
when we picked a random number like
three it was hard to differentiate which
strategy was better because they both
performed exactly the same
but in john's worst case scenario a
clear winner in terms of strategy
emerges
in terms of algorithmic thinking we're
starting to get a sense that the
specific value they're searching for may
not matter as much as where that value
lies in the range that they've been
given
identifying this helps us understand our
problem better
let's do this again for a range of
numbers from one to one hundred we'll
start by picking five as an answer to
trick them
okay so this time we're going to run
through the exercise again this time
from one to one hundred and both one and
one hundred are included is it one at
this point without even having to run
through it we can guess how many tries
john is going to take since he starts at
one and keeps going he's going to take
five tries as we're about to see is it
five cool correct
okay now for brittany's turn
is it 50 too high is it 25 still too
high
is it 13 too high is it seven
too high
is it four too low
is it six too high is it five correct
let's evaluate john took five tries
brittany on the other hand takes seven
tries so john wins this round but again
in determining whose strategy is
preferred there's no clear winner right
now
what this tells us is that it's not
particularly useful to look at the easy
answers where we arrive at the number
fairly quickly because it's at the start
of the range
instead let's try one where we know john
is going to do poorly let's look at his
worst case scenario where the answer is
100 and see how britney performs in such
a scenario
okay john let's do this one more time
one through 100 again
is it one we can fast forward this scene
because well we know what happens john
takes 100 tries
hi brittany you're up
is it 50 too low is it 75 too low 88 too
low
94 too low is it 97 too low
99 too low
100.
okay so that took brittney seven turns
again and this time she is the clear
winner if you compare their individual
performances for the same number set
you'll see that britney's approach
leaves john's in the dust
when the answer was five so right around
the start of the range john took five
turns but when the answer was 100 right
at the end of the range he took 100
tries it took him 20 times the amount of
tries to get that answer compared to
britney
on the other hand if you compare
britney's efforts when the number was 5
she took seven tries but when the number
was 100 she took the same amount of
tries this is pretty impressive if we
pretend that the number of tries is the
number of seconds it takes britney and
john to run through their attempts this
is a good estimate for how fast their
solutions are
ok we've done this a couple times and
brittany and john are getting tired
let's take a break in the next video
we'll talk about the point of this
exercise
in the last video we ran through an
exercise where i had some of my
co-workers guess what number i was
thinking so was the point of that
exercise you might be thinking hey i
thought i was here to learn about
algorithms
the exercise we just did was an example
of a real life situation you will run
into when building websites apps and
writing code
both approaches taken by john and
brittany to find the number i was
thinking of are examples of searching
for a value
it might be weird to think that there's
more than one way to search but as you
saw in the game the speed at which the
result was obtained differed between
john and brittany think about this
problem from the perspective of a
company like facebook
at the time of this recording facebook
has 2.19 billion active users
let's say you're traveling in a
different country and meet someone you
want to add on facebook
you go into the search bar and type out
this person's name
if we simplify how the facebook app
works it has to search across these 2.19
billion records and find the person you
are looking for
the speed at which you find this person
really matters imagine what kind of
experience it would be if when you
search for a friend facebook put up a
spinning activity indicator and said
come back in a couple hours
i don't think we'd use facebook as much
if that was the case
from the company's perspective working
on making search as fast as possible
using different strategies really
matters
now i said that the two strategies
britney and john used were examples of
search
more specifically these are search
algorithms
the strategy john took where he started
at the beginning of the range and just
counted one number after the other is a
type of search called linear search
it is also called sequential search
which is a better description of how it
works or even simple search since it
really is quite simple
but what makes his approach an algorithm
as opposed to just looking for something
remember we said that an algorithm is a
set of steps or instructions to complete
a task
linear search is a search algorithm and
we can define it like this
we start at the beginning of the list or
the range of values
then we compare the current value to the
target
if the current value is the target value
that we're looking for we're done
if it's not we'll move on sequentially
to the next value in the list and then
repeat step 2.
if we reach the end of the list then the
target value is not in the list
this definition has nothing to do with
programming and in fact you can use it
in the real world for example
i could tell you to walk into a
bookstore and find me a particular book
and one of the ways you could do it is
using the linear search algorithm
you could start at the front of the
bookstore and read the cover or the
spine of every book to check that it
matches the book that you're looking for
if it doesn't you go to the next book
and repeat until you find it or run out
of books
what makes this an algorithm is the
specificity of how it is defined
in contrast to just jumping into a
problem and solving it as we go along an
algorithm follows a certain set of
guidelines and we use the same steps to
solve the problem each time we face it
an important first step to defining the
algorithm isn't the algorithm itself but
the problem we're trying to solve
our first guideline is that an algorithm
must have a clear problem statement
it's pretty hard to define an
instruction set when you don't have a
clear idea of what problem you're trying
to solve
in defining the problem we need to
specify how the input is defined and
what the output looks like when the
algorithm has done its job
for linear search the input can be
generally described as a series of
values and the output is a value
matching the one we're looking for
right now we're trying to stay away from
anything code related so this problem
statement definition is pretty generic
but once we get to code we can actually
tighten this up
once we have a problem an algorithm is a
set of steps that solves this problem
given that the next guideline is that an
algorithm definition must contain a
specific set of instructions in a
particular order
we really need to be clear about the
order in which these instructions are
executed
taking our simple definition of linear
search if i switched up the order and
said move sequentially to the next value
before specifying that first comparison
step if the first value were the target
one our algorithm wouldn't find it
because we moved to the second value
before comparing
now you might think okay that's just an
avoidable mistake and kind of common
sense
the thing is computers don't know any of
that and just do exactly as we tell them
so specific order is really important
the third guideline is that each step in
our algorithm definition must not be a
complex one and needs to be explicitly
clear what i mean by that is that you
shouldn't be able to break down any of
the steps into further into additional
subtasks
each step needs to be a distinct one we
can't define linear search as search
until you find this value because that
can be interpreted in many ways and
further broken down into many more steps
it's not clear
next and this one might seem obvious but
algorithms should produce a result
if it didn't how would we know whether
the algorithm works or not
to be able to verify that our algorithm
works correctly we need a result
now when using a search algorithm the
end result can actually be nothing which
indicates that the value wasn't found
but that's perfectly fine
there are several ways to represent
nothing in code and as long as the
algorithm can produce some results we
can understand its behavior
the last guideline is that the algorithm
should actually complete and cannot take
an infinite amount of time
if we let john loose in the world's
largest library and asked him to find a
novel we have no way of knowing whether
he succeeded or not unless he came back
to us with a result
okay so quick recap what makes an
algorithm an algorithm and not just
something you do
one it needs to have a clearly defined
problem statement input and output
when using linear search the input needs
to be just a series of values but to
actually use brittany's strategy there's
one additional precondition so to speak
if you think about her strategy it
required that the numbers be sorted in
ascending order
this means that where the input for john
is just a series of values to solve the
problem the input to brittany's
algorithm needs to be a sorted series of
values
so clearly defined problem statement
clearly defined input and clearly
defined output
second the steps in the algorithm need
to be in a very specific order
the steps also need to be distinct you
should not be able to break it down into
further subtasks
next the algorithm should produce a
result
and finally the algorithm should
complete in a finite amount of time
these guidelines not only help us define
what an algorithm is but also helps us
verify that the algorithm is correct
executing the steps in an algorithm for
a given input must result in the same
output every time
if in the game i played the answer was
50 every time then every single time
john must take 50 turns to find out that
the answer is 50. if somehow he takes 50
turns in one round then 30 the next and
we technically don't have a correct
algorithm
consistent results for the same set of
values is how we know that the algorithm
is correct
i should stress that we're not going to
be designing any algorithms on our own
and we'll start off and spend most of
our time learning the tried and true
algorithms that are known to efficiently
solve problems
the reason for talking about what makes
for a good algorithm though is that the
same set of guidelines makes for good
algorithmic thinking which is one of the
most important skills we want to
cultivate
when we encounter a problem before
rushing in and thinking about solutions
what we want to do is work through the
guidelines
first we break down the problem into any
possible number of smaller problems
where each problem can be clearly
defined in terms of an input and an
output
now that we know how to generally define
an algorithm let's talk about what it
means to have a good algorithm
an important thing to keep in mind is
that there's no one single way to
measure whether an algorithm is the
right solution because it is all about
context
earlier we touched on two concepts
correctness and efficiency
let's define correctness more clearly
because before we can evaluate an
algorithm on efficiency we need to
ensure its correctness
before we define our algorithms we start
by defining our problem
in the definition of that problem we
have a clearly defined input satisfying
any preconditions and a clearly defined
output
an algorithm is deemed correct if on
every run of the algorithm against all
possible values in the input data we
always get the output we expect
part of correctness means that for any
possible input the algorithm should
always terminate or end
if these two are not true then our
algorithm isn't correct
if you were to pick up an algorithm's
textbook and look up correctness you
will run into a bunch of mathematical
theory this is because traditionally
algorithm correctness is proved by
mathematical induction which is a form
of reasoning used in mathematics to
verify that a statement is correct
this approach involves writing what is
called a specification and a correctness
proof
we won't be going into that in this
course
proof through induction is an important
part of designing algorithms but we're
confident that you can understand
algorithms both in terms of how and when
to use them without getting into the
math so if you pick up a textbook and
feel daunted don't worry i do too but we
can still figure things out without it
all right so once we have a correct
algorithm we can start to talk about how
efficient an algorithm is
remember that this efficiency ultimately
matters because they help us solve
problems faster and deliver a better end
user experience in a variety of fields
for example algorithms are used in the
sequencing of dna and more efficient
sequencing algorithms allow us to
research and understand diseases better
and faster but let's not get ahead of
ourselves we'll start simple by
evaluating john's linear search
algorithm in terms of its efficiency
first what do we mean by efficiency
there are two measures of efficiency
when it comes to algorithms time and
space sounds really cool and very sci-fi
huh
efficiency measured by time something
you'll hear called time complexity is a
measure of how long it takes the
algorithm to run
time complexity can be understood
generally outside the context of code
and computers because how long it takes
to complete a job is a universal measure
of efficiency the less time you take the
more efficient you are
the second measure of efficiency is
called space complexity and this is
pretty computer specific
it deals with the amount of memory taken
up on the computer
good algorithms need to balance between
these two measures to be useful
for example you can have a blazingly
fast algorithm but it might not matter
if the algorithm consumes more memory
than you have available
both of these concepts time and space
complexity are measured using the same
metric but it is a very technical
sounding metric so let's build up to it
slowly and start simple
a few videos ago i played a game with
brittany and john where they tried to
guess the number i was thinking of
effectively they were searching for a
value
so how do we figure out how efficient
each algorithm is and which algorithm
was more suited to our purposes
if we consider the number of tries they
took to guess or search for the value as
an indicator of the time they take to
run through the exercise this is a good
indicator of how long the algorithm runs
for a given set of values
this measurement is called the running
time of an algorithm and we'll use it to
define time complexity
in the game we play it four rounds let's
recap those here focusing on john's
performance
in round one we had 10 values the target
was 3 and john took 3 turns
in round 2 we had 10 values the target
was 10 and john took 10 turns
in round 3 we had 100 values the target
was
john took five tries and finally in
round four when the target was 100 given
100 values john took 100 tries
on paper it's hard to gauge anything
about this performance
when it comes to anything with numbers
though i like to put it up on a graph
and compare visually
on the vertical or y-axis let's measure
the number of tries it took john to
guess the answer or the running time of
the algorithm on the horizontal or
x-axis what do we put
for each turn we have a number of values
as well as a target value
we could plot the target value on the
horizontal axis but that leaves some
context and meaning behind it's far more
impressive that john took five tries
when the range went up to 100 then when
he took three tries for a maximum of 10
values
we could plot the maximum range of
values but then we're leaving out the
other half of the picture
there are data points however that
satisfy both requirements
if we only plot the values where the
target the number john was looking for
was the same as the maximum range of
values we have a data point that
includes both the size of the data set
as well as his effort
there's an additional benefit to this
approach as well
there are three ways we can measure how
well john does or in general how well
any algorithm does
first we can check how well john does in
the best case or good scenarios from the
perspective of his strategy
in the range of 100 values the answer
being a low number like three at the
start of the range is a good scenario he
can guess it fairly quickly one is his
best case scenario
or we could check how well he does on
average we could run this game a bunch
of times and average out the running
time
this would give us a much better picture
of john's performance over time but our
estimates would be too high if the value
he was searching for was at the start of
the range or far too low if it was at
the end of the range
let's imagine a scenario where facebook
naively implements linear search when
finding friends
they looked at the latest u.s census saw
that 50 of names start with the letters
a through j which is the first 40 of the
alphabet and thought okay on average
linear search serves us well
but what about the rest of those whose
names start with the letter after j in
the alphabet
searching for my name would take longer
than the average and much longer for
someone whose name starts with the
letter z
so while measuring the run time of an
algorithm on average might seem like a
good strategy it won't necessarily
provide an accurate picture
by picking the maximum in the range
we're measuring how our algorithm does
in the worst case scenario
analyzing the worst case scenario is
quite useful because it indicates that
the algorithm will never perform worse
than we expect there's no room for
surprises
back to our graph we're going to plot
the number of tries a proxy for running
time of the algorithm against the number
of values in the range which will
shorten to n
n here also represents john's worst case
scenario when n is 10 he takes 10 turns
when n is 100 he takes 100 turns
but these two values alone are
insufficient to really get any sort of
visual understanding moreover it's not
realistic
john may take a long time to work
through 100 numbers but a computer can
do that in no time
to evaluate the performance of linear
search in the context of a computer we
should probably throw some harder and
larger ranges of values at it
the nice thing is by evaluating a worst
case scenario we don't actually have to
do that work
we know what the result will be for a
given value of n using linear search it
will take n tries to find the value in
the worst case scenario so let's add a
few values in here to build out this
graph
okay so we have a good picture of what
this is starting to look like as the
values get really large the running time
of the algorithm gets large as well
we sort of already knew that
before we dig into this runtime any
deeper let's switch tracks and evaluate
brittany's work
by having something to compare against
it should become easier to build a
mental model around time complexity
the algorithm john used linear search
seemed familiar to us and you could
understand it because it's how most of
us search for things in real life anyway
brittany's approach on the other hand
got results quickly but it was a bit
harder to understand so let's break it
down
just like john's approach britney
started with a series of values or a
list of numbers as her input
where john just started at the beginning
of the list and searched sequentially
brittany's strategy is to always start
in the middle of the range
from there she asks a comparison
question
is the number in the middle of the range
equal to the answer she's looking for
and if it's not is it greater than or
less than the answer
if it's greater than she can eliminate
all the values less than the one she's
currently evaluating if it's lesser than
the answer she can eliminate all the
values greater than the one she's
currently evaluating
with the range of values that she's left
over with she repeats this process until
she arrives at the answer
let's visualize how she did this by
looking at round three
in round three the number of values in
the range was 100 the answer was 5.
the bar here represents the range of
values one of the left 100 at the right
and this pointer represents the value
britney chooses to evaluate
so she starts in the middle at 50. she
asks is it equal to the answer i say
it's too high so this tells her that the
value she is evaluating is greater than
our target value which means there's no
point in searching any of the values to
the right of 50 that is values greater
than 50 in this range so she can discard
those values altogether
she only has to consider values from 1
to 50 now
the beauty of this strategy and the
reason why britney was able to find the
answer in such few turns is that with
every value she evaluates she can
discard half of the current range
on her second turn she picks the value
in the middle of the current range which
is 25. she asks the same question i say
that the value is too high again and
this tells her that she can discard
everything greater than 25 and the range
of values drops from 1 to 25.
again she evaluates the number in the
middle roughly so that'd be 13 here i
tell her this is still too high she
discards the values greater moves to
value at 7 which is still too high
then she moves to 4 which is now too low
she can discard everything less than 4
which leaves the numbers 4 through 7.
here she picked 6 which was too high
which only leaves one value 5.
this seems like a lot of work but being
able to get rid of half the values with
each turn is what makes this algorithm
much more efficient
now there's one subtlety to using binary
search and you might have caught on to
this
for this search method to work as we've
mentioned the values need to be sorted
with linear search it doesn't matter if
the values are sorted since a linear
search algorithm just progresses
sequentially checking every element in
the list if the target value exists in
the list it will be fouled but let's say
this range of values 100 was unsorted
britney would start at the middle with
something like 14 and ask if this value
was too low or too high i say it's too
high so she discards everything less
than 14.
now this example starts to fall apart
here because well britney knows what
numbers are less than 14 and greater
than one she doesn't need an actual
range of values to solve this a computer
however does need that
remember search algorithms are run
against lists containing all sorts of
data it's not always just a range of
values containing numbers
in a real use case of binary search
which we're going to implement in a bit
the algorithm wouldn't return the target
value because we already know that it's
a search algorithm so we're providing
something to search for instead what it
returns is the position in the list that
the target occupies without the list
being sorted a binary search algorithm
would discard all the values to the left
of 14 which over here could include the
position where our target value is
eventually we'd get a result back saying
the target value doesn't exist in the
list which is inaccurate
earlier when defining linear simple
search i said that the input was a list
of values and the output was the target
value or more specifically the position
of the target value in the list
so with binary search there's also that
precondition the input list must be
sorted so let's formally define binary
search
first the input a sorted list of values
the output the position in the list of
the target value we're searching for or
some sort of values indicate that the
target does not exist in the list
remember our guidelines for defining an
algorithm let me put those up again
really quick
the steps in the algorithm need to be in
a specific order the steps also need to
be very distinct
the algorithms should produce a result
and finally the algorithm should
complete in a finite amount of time
let's use those to define this algorithm
step one we determine the middle
position of the sorted list
step two we compare the element in the
middle position to the target element
step three if the elements match we
return the middle position and end
if they don't match in step 4 we check
whether the element in the middle
position is smaller than the target
element
if it is then we go back to step 2 with
a new list that goes from the middle
position of the current list to the end
of the current list
in step five if the element in the
middle position is greater than the
target element then again we go back to
step two with a new list that goes from
the start of the current list to the
middle position of the current list
we repeat this process until the target
element is found or until a sub list
contains only one element
if that single element sublist does not
match the target element then we end the
algorithm indicating that the element
does not exist in the list
okay so that is the magic behind how
britney managed to solve the round much
faster
in the next video let's talk about the
efficiency of binary search
[Music]
we have a vague understanding that
britney's approach is better in most
cases but just like with linear search
it helps to visualize this
much like we did with linear search when
determining the efficiency of an
algorithm and remember we're still only
looking at efficiency in terms of time
time complexity as it's called we always
want to evaluate how the algorithm
performs in the worst case scenario now
you might be thinking well that doesn't
seem fair because given a series of data
if the target value we're searching for
is somewhere near the front of the list
then linear search may perform just as
well if not slightly better than binary
search and that is totally true
remember a crucial part of learning
algorithms is understanding what works
better in a given context
when measuring efficiency though we
always use the worst case scenarios as a
benchmark because remember it can never
perform worse than the worst case
let's plot these values on the graph we
started earlier with the number of tris
or the runtime of the algorithm on the y
axis and the maximum number of values in
the series or n on the horizontal axis
to represent the worst case scenario we
have two data points when n equals 10
britney took four tries using binary
search and when n equals 100 it took
seven tries
but even side by side these data points
are sort of meaningless
remember that while there is quite a
difference between the run time of
linear search and binary search at an n
value of 100 for a computer that
shouldn't matter
what we should check out is how the
algorithm performs at levels of n that
might actually slow a computer down
as n grows larger and larger how do
these algorithms compare to one another
let's add that to the graph
okay now a picture starts to emerge
as n gets really large the performance
of these two algorithms differs
significantly
the difference is kind of staggering
actually
even with the simple game we saw that
binary search was better but now we have
a much more complete idea of how much
better
for example when n is 1000 the runtime
of linear search measured by the number
of operations or turns is also 1000.
for binary search it takes just 10
operations
now let's look at what happens when we
increase n by factor of 10
at 10 000 linear search takes 10 000
operations while binary search takes 14
operations
and increased by a factor of 10 in
binary search only needs four more
operations to find a value
if we increase it again by a factor of
10 once more to an n value of 100 000
binary search takes only 17 operations
it is blazing fast
what we've done here is plotted on a
graph how the algorithm performs as the
input set it is working on increases
in other words we've plotted the growth
rate of the algorithm also known as the
order of growth
different algorithms grow at different
rates and by evaluating their growth
rates we get a much better picture of
their performance because we know how
the algorithm will hold up as n grows
larger
this is so important in fact it is the
standard way of evaluating an algorithm
and brings us to a concept called big o
you might have heard this word thrown
about and if you found it confusing
don't worry we've already built up a
definition in the past few videos we
just need to bring it all together
let's start with a common statement
you'll see in studies on algorithms
big o is a theoretical definition of the
complexity of an algorithm as a function
of the size
wow what a mouthful this sounds really
intimidating but it's really not let's
break it down
big o is a notation used to describe
complexity and what i mean by notation
is that it simplifies everything we've
talked about down into a single variable
an example of complexity written in
terms of big o looks like this
as you can see it starts with an
uppercase letter o that's why we call it
big o it's literally a big o
the o comes from order of magnitude of
complexity so that's where we get the
big o from now complexity here refers to
the exercise we've been carrying out in
measuring efficiency
if it takes brittany 4 tries when n is
10
how long does the algorithm take when n
is 10 million
when we use big o for this the variable
used which we'll get to distills that
information down so that by reading the
variable you get a big picture view
without having to run through data
points and graphs just like we did
it's important to remember that
complexity is relative
when we evaluate the complexity of the
binary search algorithm we're doing it
relative to other search algorithms not
all algorithms
bigo is a useful notation for
understanding both time and space
complexity but only when comparing
amongst algorithms that solve the same
problem
the last bit in that definition of big o
is a function of the size and all this
means is that big o measures complexity
as the input size grows because it's not
important to understand how an algorithm
performs in a single data set but in all
possible data sets
you will also see big o referred to as
the upper bound of the algorithm and
what that means is that big o measures
how the algorithm performs in the worst
case scenario
so that's all big o is
nothing special it's just a notation
that condenses the data points and
graphs that we've built up down to one
variable okay so what do these variables
look like
for john's strategy linear search we say
that it has a time complexity of big o
and then n so that's again big o with an
n inside parentheses
for britney strategy binary search we
say that it has a time complexity of big
o of log n that's big o with something
called a log and an n inside parentheses
now don't worry if you don't understand
that we'll go into that in more detail
later on in the course
each of these has a special meaning but
it helps to work through all of them to
get a big picture view so over the next
few videos let's examine what are called
common complexities or common values of
big o that you will run into and should
internalize
in our discussions of complexity we made
one assumption that the algorithm as a
whole had a single measure of complexity
that isn't true and we'll get at how we
arrive at these measures for the entire
algorithm at the end of this exercise
but each step in the algorithm has its
own space and time complexity
in linear search for example there are
multiple steps and the algorithm goes
like this
start at the beginning of the list or
range of values compare the current
value to the target if the current value
is the target value that we're looking
for we're done
if it's not we'll move on sequentially
to the next value in the list and repeat
step two
if we reach the end of the list then the
target value is not in the list
let's go back to step two for a second
comparing the current value to the
target
does the size of the data set matter for
this step
when we're at step two we're already at
that position in the list and all we're
doing is reading the value to make a
comparison reading the value is a single
operation and if we were to plot it on a
graph of runtime per operations against
n it looks like this a straight line
that takes constant time regardless of
the size of n since this takes the same
amount of time in any given case we say
that the run time is constant time it
doesn't change
in big o notation we represent this as
big o with a 1 inside parentheses now
when i first started learning all this i
was really confused as to how to read
this even if it was in my own head
should i say big o of one
when you see this written you're going
to read this as constant time so reading
a value in a list is a constant time
operation
this is the most ideal case when it
comes to run times because input size
does not matter and we know that
regardless of the size of n the
algorithm runtime will remain the same
the next step up in complexity so to
speak is the situation we encountered
with the binary search algorithm
traditionally explaining the time
complexity of binary search involves
math i'm going to try to do it both with
and without
when we played the game using binary
search we notice that with every turn we
were able to discard half of the data
but there's another pattern that emerges
that we didn't explore
let's say n equals 10. how long does it
take to find an item at the 10th
position of the list we can write this
out so we go from 10 to 5 to 8 to 9 and
then down to 10.
here it takes us four tries to cut down
the list to just one element and find
the value we're looking for
let's double the value of n to 20 and
see how long it takes for us to find an
item at the 20th position so we start at
20 and then we pick 10 from there we go
to 15 17 19 and finally 20.
so here it takes us five tries
okay let's double it again so that n is
40 and we try to find the item in the
40th position
so when we start at 40 the first
midpoint we're going to pick is 20 from
there we go to 30 then 35 37 39 and then
40.
notice that every time we double the
value of n the number of operations it
takes to reduce the list down to a
single element only increases by 1.
there's a mathematical relationship to
this pattern and it's called a logarithm
of n
you don't really have to know what
logarithms truly are but i know that
some of you like underlying explainers
so i'll give you a quick one
if you've taken algebra classes you may
have learned about exponents here's a
quick refresher
2 times 1 equals 2. now this can be
written as 2 raised to the first power
because it is our base case two times
one is two
now two times two is four this can be
written as two raised to the second
power because we're multiplying two
twice first we multiply two times one
then the result of that times 2.
2 times 2 times 2 is 8 and we can write
this as 2 raised to the 3rd power
because we're multiplying 2 3 times
in 2 raised to 2 and 2 raised to 3 the 2
and 3 there are called exponents and
they define how the number grows
with 2 raised to 3 we start with the
base value and multiply itself 3 times
the inverse of an exponent is called a
logarithm so if i say log to the base 2
of 8 equals 3 i'm basically saying the
opposite of an exponent
instead of saying how many times do i
have to multiply this value i'm asking
how many times do i have to divide 8 by
two to get the value one
this takes three operations
what about the result of log to the base
two of sixteen that evaluates to four
so why does any of this matter
notice that this is sort of how binary
search works
log to the base 2 of 16 is 4.
if n was 16 how many triads does it take
to get to that last element
well we start in the middle at 8 that's
too low so we move to 12 then we move to
14 then to 15 and then to 16 which is 5
tries or log to the base 2 of 16 plus 1.
in general for a given value of n the
number of tries it takes to find the
worst case scenario
is log of n plus one
and because this pattern is overall a
logarithmic pattern we say that the
runtime of such algorithms is
logarithmic
if we plot these data points on our
graph a logarithmic runtime looks like
this
in big o notation we represent a
logarithmic runtime as big o of log n
which is written as big o with log n
inside parentheses or even sometimes as
l n n inside parentheses
when you see this read it as logarithmic
time
as you can see on the graph as n grows
really large the number of operations
grows very slowly and eventually
flattens out
since this line is below the line for a
linear runtime which we'll look at in a
second you might often hear algorithms
with logarithmic runtimes being called
sublinear
logarithmic or sub-linear runtimes are
preferred to linear because they're more
efficient but in practice linear search
has its own set of advantages which
we'll take a look at in the next video
next up let's look at the situation we
encountered with the linear search
algorithm
we saw that in the worst case scenario
whatever the value of n was john took
exactly that many tries to find the
answer
as in linear search when the number of
operations to determine the result in
the worst case scenario is at most the
same as n
we say that the algorithm runs in linear
time
we represent this as big o of n now you
can read that as big o of n like i just
said or you can say linear time which is
more common
when we put that up on a graph against
constant time and logarithmic time we
get a line that looks like this
any algorithm that sequentially reads
the input will have linear time
so remember anytime you know a problem
involves reading every item in a list
that means a linear run time as you saw
from the game we played brittany's
strategy using binary search was clearly
better and we can see that on the graph
so if we had the option why would we use
linear search which runs in linear time
remember that binary search had a
precondition the input set had to be
sorted
while we won't be looking at sorting
algorithms in this course as you learn
more about algorithms you'll find that
sorting algorithms have varying
complexities themselves just like search
does so we have to do additional work
prior to using binary search
for this reason in practice linear
search ends up being more performant up
to a certain value of n because the
combination of sorting first and then
searching using binary search adds up
the next common complexity you will hear
about is when an algorithm runs in
quadratic time if the word quadratic
sounds familiar to you it's because you
might have heard about it in math class
quadratic is a word that means an
operation raised to the second power or
when something is squared
let's say you and your friends are
playing a tower defense game and to
start it off you're going to draw a map
of the terrain
this map is going to be a grid and you
pick a random number to determine how
large this grid is let's set n the size
of the grid to four
next you need to come up with a list of
coordinates so you can place towers and
enemies and stuff on this map so how
would we do this
if we start out horizontally we'd have
coordinate points that go 1 1 1 2 1 3
and 1 4.
then you go up one level vertically and
we have points 2 1 2 2 2 3 and 2 4.
go up one more and you have the points 3
1 3 2 3 3 and 3 4 and on that last row
you have the points 4 1 4 2 4 3 and 4 4.
notice that we have a pattern here
for each row we take the value and then
create a point by adding to that every
column value
the range of values go from 1 to the
value of n
so we can generally think of it this way
for the range of values from 1 to n for
each value in that range we create a
point by combining that value with the
range of values from 1 to n again
doing it this way for each value in the
range of 1 to n we create an n number of
values and we end up with 16 points
which is also n times n or n squared
this is an algorithm with a quadratic
runtime because for any given value of n
we carry out n squared number of
operations
now i picked a relatively easy so to
speak example here because in english at
least we often denote map sizes by
height times width so we would call this
a 4 by 4 grid which is just another way
of saying 4 squared or n squared
in big o notation we would write this as
big o of n squared or say that this is
an algorithm with a quadratic runtime
many search algorithms have a worst case
quadratic runtime which you'll learn
about soon
now in addition to quadratic runtimes
you may also run into cubic runtimes as
you encounter different algorithms in
such an algorithm for a given value of n
the algorithm executes n raised to the
third power number of operations
these aren't as common as quadratic
algorithms though so we won't look at
any examples but i think it's worth
mentioning
thrown up on our graph quadratic and
cubic runtimes look like this
so this is starting to look pretty
expensive computationally as they say we
can see here that for small changes in n
there's a pretty significant change in
the number of operations that we need to
carry out
the next worst case runtime we're going
to look at is one that's called
quasi-linear and a sort of easier to
understand for lack of better word by
starting with the big o notation
quasi-linear runtimes are written out as
big o of n times log n
we learned what log n was right a
logarithmic runtime whereas n grew the
number of operations only increased by a
small factor with a quasi-linear runtime
what we're saying is that for every
value of n we're going to execute a log
n number of operations hence the run
time of n times log n
so you saw earlier with the quadratic
runtime that for each value of n we
conducted n operations it's sort of the
same in that as we go through the range
of values in n we're executing login
operations
in comparison to other runtimes a
quasi-linear algorithm has a runtime
that lies somewhere between a linear
runtime and a quadratic runtime
so where would we expect to see this
kind of runtime in practical use
well sorting algorithms is one place you
will definitely see it
merge sort for example is a sorting
algorithm that has a worst case runtime
of big o of n log n
let's take a look at a quick example
let's say we start off with a list of
numbers that looks like this and we need
to sort it
merge sort starts by splitting this list
into two lists down the middle
it then takes each sub list and splits
that in half down the middle again
it keeps doing this until we end up with
a list of just a single number
when we're down to single numbers we can
do one sort operation and merge these
sub-lists back in the opposite direction
the first part of merge sort cuts those
lists into sub-lists with half the
numbers
this is similar to binary search where
each comparison operation cuts down the
range to half the values
you know the worst case runtime in
binary search is log n so these
splitting operations have the same
runtime big o of log n or logarithmic
but splitting into half isn't the only
thing we need to do with merge sort we
also need to carry out comparison
operations so we can sort those values
and if you look at each step of this
algorithm we carry out an n number of
comparison operations and that brings
the worst case runtime of this algorithm
to n times log n also known as quasi
linear don't worry if you didn't
understand how merge sort works that
wasn't the point of this demonstration
we will be covering merge sorts soon in
a future course
the run times we've looked at so far are
all called polynomial runtimes an
algorithm is considered to have a
polynomial runtime if for a given value
of n its worst case runtime is in the
form of n raised to the k power where k
just means some value so it could be n
squared where k equals 2 for a quadratic
runtime n cubed for a cubic runtime and
so on
all of those are in the form of n raised
to some power
anything that is bounded by this and
what i mean by that is if we had a
hypothetical line on our graph of n
raised to the k power anything that
falls under this graph is considered to
have a polynomial runtime
algorithms with an upper bound or a
runtime with a big o value that is
polynomial are considered efficient
algorithms and are likely to be used in
practice
now the next class of runtimes that
we're going to look at are a runtimes
that we don't consider efficient and
these are called exponential runtimes
with these runtimes as n increases
slightly the number of operations
increases exponentially and as we'll see
in a second these algorithms are far too
expensive to be used
an exponential runtime is an algorithm
with a big o value of some number raised
to the nth power
imagine that you wanted to break into a
locker that had a padlock on it let's
assume you forgot your code
this lock takes a two digit code and the
digit for the code ranges from zero to
nine
you start by setting the dials to zero
and then with the first dial remaining
on zero you change the second dial to
one and try and open it if it doesn't
work you set it to two then try again
you would keep doing this and if you
still haven't succeeded with the second
dial set to 9 then you go back to that
first dial set it to 1 and start the
second dial over
the range of values you'd have to go
through is 0 0 to 9 9 which is 100
values
this can be generalized as 10 to the
second power since there are 10 values
on each dial raised to two dials
searching through each individual value
until you stumble on the right one is a
strategy called brute force and brute
force algorithms have exponential run
times
here there are two dials so n is 2 and
each dial has 10 values so again we can
generalize this algorithm as 10 raised
to n where n represents the number of
dials
the reason that this algorithm is so
inefficient is because with just one
more dial on the lock the number of
operations increases significantly
with three dials the number of
combinations in the worst case scenario
where the correct code is the last digit
in the range is 10 raised to 3 or 1 000
values
with an additional wheel it becomes 10
raised to 4 or 10 000 values
as n increases the number of operations
increases exponentially to a point where
it's unsolvable in a realistic amount of
time
now you might think well any computer
can crack a four digit numerical lock
and that's true because n here is
sufficiently small but this is the same
principle that we use for passwords
in a typical password field implemented
well users are allowed to use letters of
the english alphabet so up to 26
characters numbers from 0 to 9 and a set
of special characters of which there can
be around 33
so typically that means each character
in a password can be one out of 69
values
this means that for a one character
password it takes 69 to the nth power so
1 which equals 69 operations in the
worst case scenario to figure out the
password
just increasing n to 2 increases the
number of operations needed to guess the
password to 69 squared or
4761 operations
now usually on a secure website there
isn't really a limit but in general
passwords are limited to around 20
characters in length
with each character being a possible 69
values and there being 20 characters the
number of operations needed to guess the
password in the worst case scenario is
69 raised to the 20th power or
approximately 6 followed by 36 zeros
number of operations
an intel cpu with five cores can carry
out roughly about 65 000 million
instructions per second that's a funny
number i know to crack our 20-digit
passcode in this very simplistic model
it would take this intel cpu
to race to 20th power years to brute
force the password
so while this algorithm would eventually
produce a result it is so inefficient
that it's pointless
this is one of the reasons why people
recommend you have longer passwords
since brute forcing is exponential in
the worst case each character you add
increases the number of combinations by
an exponent
the next class of exponential algorithms
is best highlighted by a popular problem
known as the traveling salesman
the problem statement goes like this
given a list of cities and the distance
between each pair of cities what is the
shortest possible route that visits each
city and then returns to the origin city
this seems like a simple question but
let's start with a simple case three
cities a b and c
to figure out what the shortest route is
we need to come up with all the possible
routes
with three cities we have six routes in
theory at least some of these routes can
be discarded because abc is the same as
c b a but in the opposite direction
but as we do know sometimes going from a
to c through b may go through a
different route than c to a through b so
we'll stick to the six routes and from
there we could determine the shortest no
big deal
now if we increase this to four cities
we jump to 24 combinations
the mathematical relationship that
defines this is called a factorial and
is written out as n followed by an
exclamation point
factorials are basically n times n minus
one repeated until you reach the number
one so for example the factorial of
three is three times two times one which
is six which is the number of
combinations we came up with for three
cities
the factorial of four is four times
three times two times one or 24 which is
the number of combinations we arrived at
with four cities
in solving the traveling salesman
problem the most efficient algorithm
will have a factorial runtime or a
combinatorial runtime as it's also
called
at low values of n algorithms with a
factorial runtime may be used but with
an n value of say 200 it would take
longer than humans have been alive to
solve the problem
for sake of completeness let's plot a
combinatorial runtime on our graph so
that we can compare
an algorithm such as one that solves the
traveling salesman problem as a worst
case run time of big o of n factorial
studying exponential runtimes like this
are useful for two reasons
first in studying how to make such
algorithms efficient we develop
strategies that are useful across the
board and can potentially be used to
make existing algorithms even more
efficient
second it's important to be aware of
problems that take a long time to solve
knowing right off the bat that a problem
is somewhat unsolvable in a realistic
time means you can focus your efforts on
other aspects of the problem
as beginners though we're going to steer
clear of all this and focus our efforts
on algorithms with polynomial runtimes
since we're much more likely to work
with and learn about such algorithms
now that we know some of the common
complexities in the next video let's
talk about how we determine the
complexity of an algorithm because there
are some nuances
over the last few videos we took a look
at common complexities that we would
encounter in studying algorithms but the
question remains how do we determine
what the worst case complexity of an
algorithm is
earlier i mentioned that even though we
say that an algorithm has a particular
upper bound or worst case runtime each
step in a given algorithm can have
different run times
let's bring up the steps for binary
search again
assuming the list is sorted the first
step is to determine the middle position
of the list
in general this is going to be a
constant time operation
many programming languages hold on to
information about the size of the list
so we don't actually need to walk
through the list to determine the size
now if we didn't have information about
the size of the list we would need to
walk through counting each item one by
one until we reached the end of the list
and this is a linear time operation but
realistically this is a big o of 1 or
constant time
step 2 is to compare the element in the
middle position to the target element
we can assume that in most modern
programming languages this is also a
constant time operation because the
documentation for the language tells us
it is
step 3 is our success case and the
algorithm ends
this is our best case and so far we have
only incurred two constant time
operations
so we would say that the best case run
time of binary search is constant time
which is actually true
but remember that best case is not a
useful metric
step 4 if we don't match is splitting
the list into sub-lists
assuming the worst case scenario the
algorithm would keep splitting into
sub-lists until a single element list is
reached with the value that we're
searching for
the run time for this step is
logarithmic since we discard half the
values each time
so in our algorithm we have a couple
steps that are constant time and one
step that is logarithmic overall
when evaluating the run time for an
algorithm we say that the algorithm has
as its upper bound the same runtime as
the least efficient step in the
algorithm
think of it this way let's say you're
participating in a triathlon which is a
race that has a swimming running and a
cycling component
you could be a phenomenal swimmer and a
really good cyclist but you're a pretty
terrible runner
no matter how fast you are at swimming
or cycling your overall race time is
going to be impacted the most by your
running race time because that's the
part that takes you the longest
if you take an hour 30 to finish the
running component 55 minutes to swim and
38 minutes to bike it won't matter if
you can fine tune your swimming
technique down to finish in 48 minutes
and your cycle time to 35 because you're
still bounded at the top by your running
time which is close to almost double
your bike time
similarly with the binary search
algorithm it doesn't matter how fast we
make the other steps they're already as
fast as they can be
in the worst case scenario the splitting
of the list down to a single element
list is what will impact the overall
running time of your algorithm
this is why we say that the time
complexity or run time of the algorithm
in the worst case is big o of log n or
logarithmic
as i alluded to though your algorithm
may hit a best case runtime and in
between the two best and worst case have
an average run time as well
this is important to understand because
algorithms don't always hit their worst
case but this is getting a bit too
complex for us for now we can safely
ignore average case performances and
focus only on the worst case in the
future if you decide to stick around
we'll circle back and talk about this
more
now that you know about algorithms
complexities and big o let's take a
break from all of that and write code in
the next video
[Music]
so far we've spent a lot of time in
theory and while these things are all
important things to know you get a much
better understanding of how algorithms
work when you start writing some code as
i mentioned earlier we're going to be
writing python code in this and all
subsequent algorithm courses
if you do have programming experience
but in another language check the notes
section of this video for an
implementation in your language
if you don't have any experience i'll
try my best explain as we go along
on the video you're watching right now
you should see a launch workspaces
button
we're going to use a treehouse coding
environment call workspaces to write all
of our code
if you're familiar with using python in
a local environment then feel free to
keep doing so workspaces is an
in-browser coding environment and will
take care of all the setup and
installation so you can focus on just
writing and evaluating code workspaces
is quite straightforward to use on the
left here we have a file navigator pane
which is currently empty since we
haven't created a new file
on the top we have an editor where we
write all our code and then below that
we have a terminal or a command line
prompt where we can execute the scripts
that we write let's add a new file here
so at the top in the editor area we're
going to go to file new file and we'll
name this linear
underscore search
dot pi
in here we're going to define our linear
search algorithm as a standalone
function
we start with the keyword def which
defines a function or a block of code
and then we give it the name linear
underscore search
this function will accept two arguments
first the list we're searching through
and then the target value we're looking
for both of these arguments are enclosed
in a set of parentheses and there's no
space between the name of the function
and the arguments
after that we have a colon
now there might be a bit of confusion
here since we already have this target
value what are we searching for unlike
the game we played at the beginning
where john's job was to find the value
in a true implementation of linear
search we're looking for the position in
the list where the value exists
if the target is in the list then we
return its position
and since this is a list that position
is going to be denoted by an index value
now if the target is not found we're
going to return none the choice of what
to return in the failure case may be
different in other implementations of
linear search
you can return -1 since that isn't
typically an index value
you can also raise an exception which is
python speak for indicating an error
occurred
now i think for us the most
straightforward value we can return here
is none now let's add a comment to
clarify this so hit enter to go to the
next line
and then we're going to add
three
single quotes
and then below that on the next line
we'll say returns
the position or the index
position
of the target
if found
else returns none
and then on the next line we'll close
off those three quotes
this is called a doc string and is a
python convention for documenting your
code the linear search algorithm is a
sequential algorithm that compares each
item in the list until the target is
found
to iterate or loop or walk through our
list sequentially we're going to use a
for loop
now typically when iterating over a list
in python we would use a loop like this
we'd say for item in list
this assigns the value at each index
position to that local variable item
we don't want this though since we
primarily care about the index position
instead we're going to use the range
function in python to create a range of
values that start at 0 and end at the
number of items in the list
so we'll say 4 i i stands for index here
in range
starting at 0 and going all the way up
to the length of the list
we can get the number of items in the
list using the len function
now going back to our talk on complexity
and how individual steps in an algorithm
can have its own run times this is a
line of code that we would have to be
careful about
python keeps track of the length of a
list so this function call here len list
is a constant time operation now if this
were a naive implementation let's say we
wrote the implementation of the list
and we iterate over the list every time
we call this length function then we've
already incurred a linear cost
okay so once we have a range of values
that represent index positions in this
list we're going to iterate over that
using the for loop and assign each index
value to this local variable i using
this index value we can obtain the item
at that position using subscript
notation on the list
now this is also a constant time
operation because the language says so
so we'll do if list so once we have this
value which we'll get by using subscript
notation so we'll say list i
once we have this value we'll check if
it matches the target so if the value at
i
equals target
well if it does then we'll return that
index value because we want the position
and once we hit this return statement
we're going to terminate our function if
the entire for loop is executed and we
don't hit this return statement then the
target does not exist in the list so at
the bottom here we'll say return none
even though all the individual
operations in our algorithm run in
constant time
in the worst case scenario this for loop
here will have to go through the entire
range of values and read every single
element in the list
therefore giving the algorithm a big o
value of n or running in linear time now
if you've written code before you've
definitely written code like this a
number of times and i bet you didn't
know but all along you are implementing
what is essentially a well-known
algorithm
so i hope this goes to show you that
algorithms are pretty approachable topic
like everything else this does get
advanced but as long as you take things
slow there's no reason for it to be
impossible remember that not any block
of code counts as an algorithm to be a
proper implementation of linear search
this block of code must return a value
must complete execution in a finite
amount of time and must output the same
result every time for a given input set
so let's verify this with a small test
let's write a function called verify
that accepts an index value
if the value is not none it prints the
index position if it is none it informs
us that the target was not found in the
list so def verify
and this is going to take an index value
and we'll say if index is not none
then we'll print
target
found at index
oops that's a colon here
index else
that needs to go back
there we go
else we'll say target
not found in list
okay using this function let's define a
range of numbers now so this will be a
list numbers
and we'll just go from 1 to
let's say 10.
now if you've written python code before
you know that i can use a list
comprehension to make this easier but
we'll keep things simple
we can now use our linear search
function to search for the position of a
target value in this list so we can say
result
equal
linear underscore search
and we're going to pass in the numbers
list that's the one we're searching
through and we want to look for the
position where the value 12 exists
and then we'll verify
this result
if our algorithm works correctly the
verify function should inform us that
the target did not exist so make sure
you save the file which you can do by
going up to file and save or hitting
command s
and then below in the terminal
you're going to type out python
linear search or you can hit tab and it
should auto complete linear search dot
pi
as you can see correct the target was
not found in the list so the output of
our script is what we expect
for our second test let's search for the
value 6 in the list so you can copy this
command c to copy and then paste it
again and we'll just change 12 here to 6
and then come back down to the terminal
hit the up arrow to execute the same
command again and hit enter you'll
notice that i forgot to hit save so it
did not account for that new change
we'll try that again
and there you'll see that if it works
correctly which it did the index should
be number five run the program on your
end and make sure everything works as
expected
our algorithm returned a result in each
case it executed in a finite time and
the results were the ones we expect in
the next video let's tackle binary
search
in the last video we left off with an
implementation of linear search
let's do the same for binary search so
that we get an understanding of how this
is represented in code
so we'll do this in a new file back to
file new file
and we'll name this one binary
search
dot
py
like before we're going to start with a
function named binary search so we'll
say def
binary underscore search
that takes a list and a target
if you remember binary search works by
breaking the array or list down into
smaller sets until we find the value
we're looking for
we need a way to keep track of the
position of the list that we're working
with so let's create two variables first
and last to point to the beginning and
end of the array so first equal
zero now if you're new to programming
list positions are represented by index
values that start at zero instead of one
so here we're setting first to zero to
point to the first element in the list
last is going to point to the last
element in the list so we'll say last
equal
len list
minus one now this may be confusing to
you so a quick sidebar to explain what's
going on
let's say we have a list containing 5
elements if we called len on that list
we should get 5 back because there are 5
elements
but remember that because the position
numbers start at 0 the last value is not
at position 5 but at 4. in nearly all
programming languages getting the
position of the last element in the list
is obtained by determining the length of
the list and deducting 1 which is what
we're doing
okay so we know what the first and last
positions are when we start the
algorithm
for our next line of code we're going to
create a while loop
a while loop takes a condition and keeps
executing the code inside the loop until
the condition evaluates to false
for our condition we're going to say to
keep executing this loop until the value
of first is less than or equal to the
value of last
so while first less than or equal to
last
well why you ask why is this our
condition well let's work through this
implementation and then a visualization
should help
inside the while loop we're going to
calculate the midpoint of our list since
that's the first step of binary search
midpoint equal
so we'll say first
plus last
and then we'll use the floor division
double slash here
divided by two
now the two forward slashes here are
what python calls a floor division
operator what it does is it rounds down
to the nearest whole number so if we
have an eight element array first is
zero last is 7 if we divided 0 plus 7
which is 7 by 2 we would get 3.5 now 3.5
is not a valid index position so we
round that down to 3 using the floor
division operator okay so now we have a
midpoint the next step of binary search
is to evaluate whether the value at this
midpoint is the same as the target we're
looking for so say if list
value at midpoint
equals the target
well if it is then we'll go ahead and
return the midpoint
so we'll say return
midpoint
the return statement terminates our
algorithm and over here we're done this
is our best case scenario
next we'll say else if
list at midpoint
or value at midpoint is less than the
target now here if the value is less the
value at midpoint is less than the
target then we don't care about any of
the values lower than the midpoint so we
redefine first
to point to the value after the midpoint
so we'll say midpoint plus 1.
now if the value at the midpoint is
greater than the target then we can
discard the values after the midpoint
and redefine last to point to the value
prior to the midpoint so we'll say else
last equal midpoint
minus 1.
let's visualize this we're going to
start with a list of nine integers
to make this easier to understand let's
specify these integers to be of the same
value as its index position so we have a
range of values from 0 to 8.
our target is the worst case scenario
we're looking for the position of the
value 8. at the start our algorithm sets
first to point to the index 0 and last
to point to the length of the list minus
1 which is 8.
next we hit our while loop the logic of
this loop is going to be executed as
long as the value of first is not
greater than the value of last or as
we've defined it we're going to keep
executing the contents of the loop as
long as first is less than or equal to
last
on the first pass this is true so we
enter the body of the loop
the midpoint is first plus last divided
by two and rounded down so we get a nice
even four the value at this position is
four now this is not equal to the target
so we move to the first else if
four is less than eight so now we
redefine first to point to midpoint plus
one which is five
first is still less than last so we run
through the body of the loop again the
midpoint is now six
six is less than eight so we move first
to point to seven
seven is still less than or equal to
eight so we go for another iteration of
the loop
the midpoint is seven oddly enough and
seven is still less than the target so
we move first to point to eight first is
equal to last now but our condition says
keep the loop going as long as first is
less than or equal to last so this is
our final time through the loop
the midpoint is now 8 which makes the
value at the midpoint equal to the
target and we finally exit our algorithm
and return the position of the target
now what if we had executed all this
code and never hit a case where midpoint
equal the target well that would mean
the list did not contain the target
value so after the while loop at the
bottom
will return
none
we have several operations that make up
our binary search algorithm so let's
look at the runtime of each step we
start by assigning values to first and
last
the value assigned to last involves a
call to the len function to get the size
of the list but we already know this is
a constant time operation in python so
both of these operations run in constant
time
inside the loop we have another value
assignment and this is a simple division
operation so again the runtime is
constant
in the next line of code we're reading a
value from the list and comparing the
midpoint to the target both of these
again are constant time operations the
remainder of the code is just a series
of comparisons and value assignments and
we know that these are all constant time
operations as well
so if all we have are a series of
constant time operations why does this
algorithm have in the worst case a
logarithmic runtime
it's hard to evaluate by just looking at
the code but the while loop is what
causes the run time to grow
even though all we're doing is a
comparison operation by redefining first
and last
over here or rather in the last two
steps over here we're asking the
algorithm to run as many times as it
needs until first is equal or greater
than last
now each time the loop does this the
size of the data set the size of the
list grows smaller by a certain factor
until it approaches a single element
which is what results in the logarithmic
runtime
okay just like with linear search let's
test that our algorithm works so we'll
go back to linear search.hi
and we're going to copy paste
so command c to copy if you're on a mac
then go back to binary search and at the
bottom
oops
we're going to paste in that verify
function
okay we'll also go back and grab this
numbers
you know what let's go ahead and copy
all all of these things so numbers and
the two verify cases we'll paste that in
as well
and the only thing we need to change
here is instead of calling linear search
this is going to call binary search
okay we'll hit command s to save the
file and then i'm going to drag up my
console and we'll run python binary
search dot
and hit enter and you'll see like just
like before we get the same results back
now note that an extremely important
distinction needs to be made here
the numbers list that we've defined
for our test cases
right here
has to be sorted the basic logic of
binary search relies on the fact that if
the target is greater than the midpoint
then our potential values lie to the
left or vice versa since the values are
sorted in ascending order if the values
are unsorted our implementation of
binary search may return none even if
the value exists in the list
and just like that you've written code
to implement two search algorithms how
fun was that
hopefully this course has shown you that
it isn't a topic to be afraid of and
that algorithms like any other topic
with code can be broken down and
understood piece by piece
now we have a working implementation of
binary search but there's actually more
than one way to write it so in the next
video let's write a second version
i'm going to create a new file
as always file new file
and we'll name this recursive
underscore binary underscore search dot
p
y
okay so we're going to add our new
implementation here so that we don't get
rid of that first implementation we
wrote let's call this new function
recursive binary search
unlike our previous implementation this
version is going to behave slightly
differently in that it won't return the
index value of the target element if it
exists
instead it will just return a true value
if it exists and a false if it doesn't
so recursive
underscore binary underscore search
and like before this is going to take a
list it accepts a list and a target to
look for in that list
we'll start the body of the function by
considering what happens if an empty
list is passed in in that case we would
return false so i would say if the
length of the list which is one way to
figure out if it's empty if it's equal
to zero
then we'll return false
now you might be thinking that in the
previous version of binary search we
didn't care if the list was empty well
we actually did but in a roundabout sort
of way so in the previous version of
binary search our function had a loop
and that loop condition was true when
first was less than or equal to last so
as long as it's less than or equal to
last we continue the loop
now if we have an empty list then first
is greater than last and the loop would
never execute and we return none at the
bottom
so this is the same logic we're
implementing here we're just doing it in
a slightly different way if the list is
not empty we'll implement an else clause
now here we'll calculate the midpoint
by dividing the length of the list by 2
and rounding down
again there's no use of first and last
here so we'll say length of list
and then using the floor division
operator we'll divide that by 2.
if the value at the midpoint which we'll
check by saying if list
using
subscript notation we'll say midpoint as
the index now if this value at the
midpoint is the same as the target
then we'll go ahead and return true
so far this is more or less the same
except for the value that we're
returning
let me actually get rid of all that
okay
all right so if this isn't the case
let's implement an else clause now here
we have two situations so first if the
value at the midpoint is less than the
target so if
value at midpoint
is less than the target
then we're going to do something new
we're going to call this function again
this recursive binary search function
that we're in the process of defining
we're going to call that again and we're
going to give it the portion of the list
that we want to focus on in the previous
version of binary search we moved the
first value to point to the value after
the midpoint
now here we're going to create a new
list using what is called a slice
operation and create a sub list that
starts at midpoint plus 1 and goes all
the way to the end
we're going to specify the same target
as a search target and when this
function call is done we'll return the
value so we'll say return the return is
important
then we'll call this function again
recursive
binary search
and this function takes a list and here
we're going to use that subscript
notation to perform a slice operation by
using two indexes a start and an end so
we'll say our new list that we're
passing in needs to start at midpoint
plus one
and then we'll go all the way to the end
and this is a
python syntactic sugar so to speak if i
don't specify an end index python knows
to just go all the way to the end all
right so this is our new list that we're
working with
and we need a target we'll just pass it
through if you're confused bear with me
just like before we'll visualize this at
the end
okay we have another else case here
and this is a scenario where the value
at the midpoint is greater than the
target
which means we only care about the
values in the list from the start going
up to the midpoint now in this case as
well we're going to call the binary
search function again and specify a new
list to work with this time the list is
going to start at the beginning and then
go all the way up to the midpoint so it
looks the same we'll say return
recursive
binary search
we're going to pass in a list here so if
we just put a colon here
without a start index python knows to
start at the beginning and we're going
to go all the way up to the midpoint
the target here is the same
and this is our new binary search
function so let's see if this works
actually
yes
down here we'll make some space
and we'll define a verify function
we're not going to copy paste the
previous one
because we're not returning none or an
integer here so we'll verify the result
that we pass in and we'll say print
target found
and this is just going to say true or
false whether we found it
okay so like before we need a numbers
list
and we'll do something one two three
four all the way up to eight
okay and now let's test this out so
we'll call
our recursive
binary search function
and we'll pass in the numbers list
and the target here is 12.
we're going to verify this
verify the result make sure it works and
then we'll call it again this time
making sure that we give it a target
that is actually in the list so here
we'll say 6
and we'll verify this again
make sure you hit command s to save
and then in the console below we're
going to type out
python recursive binarysearch.pi
run it and you'll see that we've
verified that search works
while we can't verify the index position
of the target value which is a
modification to how our algorithm works
we can guarantee by running across all
valid inputs that search works as
intended
so why write a different search
algorithm here a different binary search
algorithm and what's the difference
between these two implementations anyway
the difference lies in these last four
lines of code that you see here
we did something unusual here now before
we get into this a small word of advice
this is a confusing topic and people get
confused by it all the time
don't worry that doesn't make you any
less of a programmer in fact i have
trouble with it often and always look it
up including when i made this video
this version of binary search is a
recursive binary search
a recursive function is one that calls
itself
this is hard for people to grasp
sometimes because there's few easy
analogies that make sense but you can
think of it and sort this way so let's
say you have this book that contains
answers to multiplication problems
you're working on a problem and you look
up an answer
in the book the answer for your problem
says add 10 to the answer for problem 52
okay so you look up problem 52 and there
it says add 12 to the answer for problem
85
well then you go and look up the answer
to problem 85 and finally instead of
redirecting you somewhere else that
answer says 10. so you take that 10 and
then you go back to problem 52 because
remember the answer for problem 52 was
to add 12 to the answer for problem 85
so you take that 10 and then you now
have the answer to problem 85 so you add
10 to 12 to get 22.
then you go back to your original
problem where it said to add 10 to the
answer for problem 52 so you add 10 to
22 and you get 32 to end up with your
final answer so that's a weird way of
doing it but this is an example of
recursion
the solution to your first lookup in the
book was the value obtained by another
lookup in the same book which was
followed by yet another lookup in the
same book the book told you to check the
book until you arrived at some base
value
our function works in a similar manner
so let's visualize this with an example
of list
like before we have a nine element list
here with values zero through eight
the target we're searching for is the
value eight
we'll check if the list is empty by
calling len on it this list is not empty
so we go to the else clause next we
calculate the midpoint 9 divided by 2 is
4.5 rounded down is 4 so our first
midpoint value is 4.
we'll perform our first check is the
value at the midpoint equal to the
target
not true so we go to our else clause
we'll perform another check here is the
value at the midpoint less than the
target now in our case this is true
earlier when we evaluated this condition
we simply change the value of first
here we're going to call the recursive
binary search function again and give it
a new list to work with
the list starts at midpoint plus 1 so at
index position 5 all the way to the end
notice that this call to recursive
binary search inside of recursive binary
search includes a return statement
this is important and we'll come back to
that in a second
so now we're back at the top
of a new call to recursive binary search
with effectively a new list although
technically just a sub list of the first
one
the list here contains the numbers 6 7
and 8.
starting with the first check the list
is not empty so we move to the else
the midpoint in this case length of the
list 3 divided by 2 rounded down is 1.
is the value of the midpoint equal to
the target well the value at that
position is 7 so no in the else we
perform the first check is the value at
the midpoint less than the target indeed
it is so we call recursive binary search
again and provided a new list
this list starts at midpoint plus 1 and
goes to the end so in this case that's a
single element list
since this is a new call to recursive
binary search we start back up at the
top
is the list empty no the midpoint is
zero
is the value at the midpoint the same as
the target it is so now we can return
true
remember a minute ago i pointed out that
when we call recursive binary search
from inside the function itself it's
preceded by a return statement
that plays a pretty important role here
so back to our visualization
we start at the top and recall binary
search with a new list but because
that's got a return statement before it
what we're saying is hey when you run
binary search on this whatever value you
get back return it to the function that
called you
then at the second level we call binary
search again along with another return
statement like with the first call we're
instructing the function to return a
value back to the code that called it
at this level we find the target so the
function returns true back to the caller
but since this inner function was also
called by a function with instructions
to return it keeps returning that true
value back up until we reach the very
first function that called it going back
to our book of answers recursive binary
search instructs itself to keep working
on the problem until it has a concrete
answer
once it does it works its way backwards
giving the answer to every function that
called it until the original caller has
an answer
now like i said at the beginning this is
pretty complicated so you should not be
concerned if this doesn't click honestly
this is not one thing that you're going
to walk away with knowing fully how to
understand recursion after your first
try i'm really not lying when i say i
have a pretty hard time with recursion
now before we move on i do want to point
out one thing
even though the implementation of
recursion is harder to understand
it is easier in this case to understand
how we arrive at the logarithmic run
time since we keep calling the function
with smaller lists let's take a break
here in the next video let's talk a bit
more about recursion and why it matters
[Music]
in the last video we wrote a version of
binary search that uses a concept called
recursion
recursion might be a new concept for you
so let's formalize how we use it
a recursive function is one that calls
itself
in our example the recursive binary
search function called itself inside the
body of the function
when writing a recursive function you
always need a stopping condition
and typically we start the body of the
recursive function with this stopping
condition it's common to call this
stopping condition the base case
in our recursive binary search function
we had two stopping conditions
the first was what the function should
return if an empty list is passed in
it seems weird to evaluate an empty list
because you wouldn't expect to run
search on an empty list but if you look
at how our function works recursive
binary search keeps calling itself and
with each call to itself the size of the
list is cut in half
if we searched for a target that didn't
exist in the list then the function
would keep halving itself until it got
to an empty list
consider a three element list with
numbers one two three where we're
searching for a target of four
on the first pass the midpoint is 2 so
the function would call itself with the
list 3.
on the next pass the midpoint is 0 and
the target is still greater so the
function would call itself this time
passing in an empty list because an
index of 0 plus 1 in a single element
list doesn't exist
when we have an empty list this means
that after searching through the list
the value wasn't found
this is why we define an empty list as a
stopping condition or a base case that
returns false if it's not an empty list
then we have an entirely different set
of instructions we want to execute
first we obtain the midpoint of the list
once we have the midpoint we can
introduce our next base case or stopping
condition
if the value at the midpoint is the same
as the target then we return true
with these two stopping conditions we've
covered all possible paths of logic
through the search algorithm you can
either find the value or you don't
once you have the base cases the rest of
the implementation of the recursive
function is to call the function on
smaller sub-lists until we hit one of
these base cases going back to our
visualization for a second we see that
recursive binary search calls itself a
first time which then calls itself again
for the initial list we started with the
function only calls itself a few times
before a stopping condition is reached
the number of times a recursive function
calls itself is called recursive depth
now the reason i bring all of this up is
because if after you start learning
about algorithms you decide you want to
go off and do your own research you may
start to see a lot of algorithms
implemented using recursion
the way we implemented binary search the
first time is called an iterative
solution
now when you see the word iterative it
generally means the solution was
implemented using a loop structure of
some kind
a recursive solution on the other hand
is one that involves a set of stopping
conditions and a function that calls
itself computer scientists and computer
science textbooks particularly from back
in the day
favor and are written in what are called
functional languages
in functional languages we try to avoid
changing data that is given to a
function
in our first version of binary search we
created first and last variables using
the list and then modified first and
last as we needed to arrive at a
solution
functional languages don't like to do
this all this modification of variables
and prefer a solution using recursion
a language like python which is what
we're using is the opposite and doesn't
like recursion in fact python has a
maximum recursion depth after which our
function will halt execution python
prefers an iterative solution now i
mentioned all of this for two reasons
if you decide that you want to learn how
to implement the algorithm in a language
of your choice that's not python then
you might see a recursive solution as
the best implementation in that
particular language
i'm an ios developer for example and i
work with a language called swift
swift is different from python in that
it doesn't care about recursion depth
and does some neat tricks where it
doesn't even matter how many times your
function calls itself
so if you want to see this in swift code
then you need to know how recursion
works
well and now you have some idea now the
second reason i bring it up is actually
way more important and to find out on to
the next video
at the beginning of this series i
mentioned that there were two ways of
measuring the efficiency of an algorithm
the first was time complexity or how the
run time of an algorithm grows as n
grows larger
the second is space complexity
we took a pretty long route to build up
this example but now we're in a good
place to discuss space complexity
space complexity is a measure of how
much working storage or extra storage is
needed as a particular algorithm grows
we don't think about it much these days
but every single thing we do on a
computer takes up space in memory in the
early days of computing considering
memory usage was of paramount importance
because memory was limited and really
expensive
these days were spoiled our devices are
rich with memory this is okay when we
write everyday code because most of us
aren't dealing with enormously large
data sets
when we write algorithms however we need
to think about this because we want to
design our algorithms to perform as
efficiently as it can as the size of the
data set n grows really large
like time complexity space complexity is
measured in the worst case scenario
using big-o notation
since you are familiar with the
different kinds of complexities let's
dive right into an example
in our iterative implementation of
binary search the first one we wrote
that uses a while loop let's look at
what happens to our memory usage as n
gets large
let's bring up that function
let's say we start off with a list of 10
elements now inspecting the code we see
that our solution relies heavily on
these two variables first and last
first points to the start of the list
and last to the end
when we eliminate a set of values we
don't actually create a sub list instead
we just redefine first
and last as you see here
to point to a different section of the
list
since the algorithm only considers the
values between first and last when
determining the midpoint
by redefining first and last as the
algorithm proceeds we can find a
solution using just the original list
this means that for any value of n
the space complexity of the iterative
version of binary search is constant or
that the iterative version of binary
search takes constant space
remember that we would write this as big
o of one
this might seem confusing because as n
grows we need more storage to account
for that larger list size
now this is true but that storage is not
what space complexity cares about
measuring
we care about what additional storage is
needed as the algorithm runs and tries
to find a solution
if we assume something simple say that
for a given size of a list represented
by a value n it takes n amount of space
to store it whatever that means
then for the iterative version of binary
search regardless of how large the list
is at the start middle and end of the
algorithm process the amount of storage
required does not get larger than n
and this is why we consider it to run in
constant space
now this is an entirely different story
with the recursive version however in
the recursive version of binary search
we don't make use of variables to keep
track of which portion of the list we're
working with
instead we create new lists every time
with a subset of values or sub-lists
with every recursive function call
let's assume we have a list of size n
and in the worst case scenario the
target element is the last in the list
calling the recursive implementation of
binary search on this list and target
would lead to a scenario like this
the function would call itself and
create a new list that goes from the
midpoint to the end of the list
since we're discarding half the values
the size of the sub list is n by 2.
this function will keep calling itself
creating a new sub list that's half the
size of the current one until it arrives
at a single element list and a stopping
condition
this pattern that you see here where the
size of the sublist is reduced by a
factor on each execution of the
algorithmic logic well we've seen that
pattern before do you remember where
this is exactly how binary search works
it discards half the values every time
until it finds a solution now we know
that because of this pattern the running
time of binary search is logarithmic
in fact the space complexity of the
recursive version of binary search is
the same
if we start out with a memory allocation
of size n that matches the list
on each function call of recursive
binary search we need to allocate
additional memory of size n by 2 n by 4
and so on until we have a sub list that
is either empty or contains a single
value because of this we say that the
recursive version of the binary search
algorithm runs in logarithmic time with
a big o of log n
now there's an important caveat here
this totally depends on the language
remember how i said that a programming
language like swift can do some tricks
to where recursion depth doesn't matter
the same concept applies here if you
care to read more about this concept
it's called tail
optimization it's called tail
optimization because if you think of a
function as having a head and a tail
if the recursive function call is the
last line of code in the function as it
is in our case
we call this tail recursion since it's
the last part of the function that calls
itself
now the trick that swift does to reduce
the amount of space and therefore
computing overhead to keep track of this
recursive calls is called tail call
optimization or tail call elimination
it's one of those things that you'll see
thrown around a loss in algorithm
discussions but may not always be
relevant to you
now what if any of this is relevant to
us well python does not implement tail
call optimization so the recursive
version of binary search takes
logarithmic space
if we had to choose between the two
implementations given that time
complexity or run time of both versions
the iterative and the recursive version
are the same we should definitely go
with the iterative implementation in
python since it runs in constant space
okay that was a lot but all of this with
all of this we've now established two
important ways to distinguish between
algorithms that handle the same task and
determine which one we should use
we've arrived at what i think is a good
spot to take a long break and let all of
these new concepts sink in but before
you go off to the next course let's take
a few minutes to recap everything we've
learned so far
while we did implement two algorithms in
this course in actual code much of what
we learned here was conceptual and will
serve as building blocks for everything
we're going to learn in the future so
let's list all of it out
the first thing we learned about and
arguably the most important was
algorithmic thinking
algorithmic thinking is an approach to
problem solving that involves breaking a
problem down into a clearly defined
input and output along with a distinct
set of steps that solves the problem by
going from input to output
algorithmic thinking is not something
you develop overnight by taking one
course so don't worry if you're thinking
i still don't truly know how to apply
what i learned here
algorithmic thinking sinks in after you
go through several examples in a similar
fashion to what we did today
it also helps to apply these concepts in
the context of a real example which is
another thing we will strive to do
moving forward
regardless it is important to keep in
mind that the main goal here is not to
learn how to implement a specific data
structure or algorithm off the top of
your head i'll be honest i had to look
up a couple code snippets for a few of
the algorithms myself in writing this
course
but in going through this you now know
that binary search exists and can apply
to a problem where you need a faster
search algorithm
unlike most courses where you can
immediately apply what you have learned
to build something cool learning about
algorithms and data structures will pay
off more in the long run
the second thing we learned about is how
to define and implement algorithms we've
gone over these guidelines several times
i won't bore you here again at the end
but i will remind you that if you're
often confused about how to effectively
break down a problem in code to
something more manageable following
those algorithm guidelines is a good
place to start
next we learned about big o and
measuring the time complexity of
algorithms this is a mildly complicated
topic but once you've abstracted the
math away it isn't as hazy a topic as it
seems
now don't get me wrong the math is
pretty important but only for those
designing and analyzing algorithms
our goal is more about how to understand
and evaluate algorithms
we learned about common run times like
constant linear logarithmic and
quadratic runtimes these are all fairly
new concepts but in time you will
immediately be able to distinguish the
runtime of an algorithm based on the
code you write and have an understanding
of where it sits on an efficiency scale
you will also in due time internalize
runtimes of popular algorithms like the
fact that binary search runs in
logarithmic time and constant space
and be able to recommend alternative
algorithms for a given problem
all in all over time the number of tools
in your tool belt will increase
next we learned about two important
search algorithms and the situations in
which we select one over the other
we also implemented these algorithms in
code so that you got a chance to see
them work
we did this in python but if you are
more familiar with a different language
and haven't gotten the chance to check
out the code snippets we've provided you
should try your hand at implementing it
yourself it's a really good exercise to
go through
finally we learned about an important
concept and a way of writing algorithmic
code through recursion recursion is a
tricky thing and depending on the
language you write code with you may run
into it more than others
it is also good to be aware of because
as we saw in our implementation of
binary search
whether recursion was used or not
affected the amount of space we used
don't worry if you don't fully
understand how to write recursive
functions i don't truly know either the
good part is you can always look these
things up and understand how other
people do it
anytime you encounter recursion in our
courses moving forward you'll get a full
explanation of how and why the function
is doing what it's doing
and that brings us to the end of this
course i'll stress again that the goal
of this course was to get you prepared
for learning about more specific
algorithms by introducing you to some of
the tools and concepts you will need
moving forward
so if you're sitting there thinking i
still don't know how to write many
algorithms or how to use algorithmic
thinking that's okay we'll get there
just stick with it
as always have fun and happy coding
[Music]
hi my name is passant i'm an instructor
at treehouse and welcome to the
introduction to data structures course
in this course we're going to answer one
fundamental question why do we need more
data structures than a programming
language provides
before we answer that question some
housekeeping if you will
in this course we're going to rely on
concepts we learned in the introduction
to algorithms course
namely big-o notation space and time
complexity and recursion
if you're unfamiliar with those concepts
or just need a refresher check out the
prerequisites courses listed
in addition this course does assume that
you have some programming experience
we're going to use data structures that
come built into nearly all programming
languages as our point of reference
while we will explain the basics of how
these structures work we won't be going
over how to use them in practice
if you're looking to learn how to
program before digging into this content
check the notes section of this video
for helpful links
if you're good to go then awesome let's
start with an overview of this course
the first thing we're going to do is to
explore a data structure we are somewhat
already familiar with arrays
if you've written code before there's a
high chance you have used an array
in this course we're going to spend some
time understanding how arrays work what
are the common operations on an array
and what are the run times associated
with those operations
once we've done that we're going to
build a data type of our own called a
linked list
in doing so we're going to learn that
there's more than one way to store data
in fact there's way more than just one
way
we're also going to explore what
motivates us to build specific kinds of
structures and look at the pros and cons
of these structures
we'll do that by exploring four common
operations accessing a value searching
for a value inserting a value and
deleting a value
after that we're actually going to
circle back to algorithms and implement
a new one a sorting algorithm
in the introductions to algorithms
course we implemented a binary search
algorithm a precondition to binary
search was that the list needed to be
sorted
we're going to try our hand at sorting a
list and open the door to an entirely
new category of algorithms
we're going to implement our sorting
algorithm on two different data
structures and explore how the
implementation of one algorithm can
differ based on the data structure being
used
we'll also look at how the choice of
data structure potentially influences
the run time of the algorithm
in learning about sorting we're also
going to encounter another general
concept of algorithmic thinking called
divide and conquer
along with recursion dividing conquer
will be a fundamental tool that we will
use to solve complex problems all in due
time in the next video let's talk about
arrays
a common data structure built into
nearly every programming language is the
array
arrays are a fundamental data structure
and can be used to represent a
collection of values but it is much more
than that arrays are also used as
building blocks to create even more
custom data types and structures
in fact in most programming languages
text is represented using the string
type and under the hood strings are just
a bunch of characters stored in a
particular order in an array
before we go further and dig into arrays
what exactly is a data structure
a data structure is a way of storing
data when programming it's not just a
collection of values and the format
they're stored in but the relationship
between the values in the collection as
well as the operations applied on the
data stored in the structure
an array is one of very many data
structures in general an array is a data
structure that stores a collection of
values where each value is referenced
using an index or a key
a common analogy for thinking about
arrays is as a set of train cars
each car has a number and these cars are
ordered sequentially
inside each car the array or the train
in this analogy stores some data
while this is the general representation
of an array it can differ slightly from
one language to another but for the most
part all these fundamentals remain the
same in a language like swift or java
arrays are homogeneous containers which
means they can only contain values of
the same type
if you use an array to store integers in
java it can only store integers
in other languages arrays are
heterogeneous structures that can store
any kind of value in python for example
you can mix numbers and text with no
issues
now regardless of this nuance the
fundamental concept of an array is the
index
this index value is used for every
operation on the array from accessing
values to inserting updating and
deleting
in python the language we're going to be
using for this course it's a tiny bit
confusing
the type that we generally refer to as
an array in most languages is best
represented by the list type in python
python does have a type called array as
well but it's something different so
we're not going to use it
while python calls it a list when we use
a list in this course we'll be talking
about concepts that apply to arrays as
well in other languages so definitely
don't skip any of this there's one more
thing
in computer science a list is actually a
different data structure than an array
and in fact we're going to build a list
later on in this course
generally though this structure is
called a linked list as opposed to just
list so hopefully the terminology isn't
too confusing
to properly understand how arrays work
let's take a peek at how arrays are
stored under the hood
an array is a contiguous data structure
this means that the array is stored in
blocks of memory that are right beside
each other with no gaps
the advantage of doing this is that
retrieving values is very easy
in a non-contiguous data structure we're
going to build one soon the structure
stores a value as well as a reference to
where the next value is
to retrieve that next value the language
has to follow that reference also called
a pointer to the next block of memory
this adds some overhead which as you
will see increases the runtime of common
operations a second ago i mentioned that
depending on the language arrays can
either be homogeneous containing the
same type of value or heterogeneous
where any kind of value can be mixed
this choice also affects the memory
layout of the array
for example in a language like c swift
or java where arrays are homogeneous
when an array is created since the kind
of value is known to the language
compiler and you can think of the
compiler as the brains behind the
language
it can choose a contiguous block of
memory that fits the array size and
values created
if the values were integers assuming an
integer took up space represented by one
of these blocks then for a five item
array the compiler can allocate five
blocks of equally sized memory
in python however this is not the case
we can put any value in a python list
there's no restriction
the way this works is a combination of
contiguous memory and the pointers or
references i mentioned earlier
when we create a list in python there is
no information about what will go into
that array which makes it hard to
allocate contiguous memory of the same
size
there are several advantages to having
contiguous memory
since the values are stored beside each
other accessing the values happens in
almost constant time so this is a
characteristic we want to preserve
the way python gets around this is by
allocating contiguous memory and storing
init not the value we want to store but
a reference or a pointer to the value
that's stored somewhere else in memory
by doing this it can allocate equally
sized contiguous memory since regardless
of the value size the size of the
pointer to that value is always going to
be equal this incurs an additional cost
in that when a value is accessed we need
to follow the pointer to the block of
memory where the value is actually
stored but python has ways of dealing
with these costs that are outside the
scope of this course
now that we know how an array stores its
values let's look at common operations
that we execute on an array
regardless of the kind of data structure
you work with all data structures are
expected to carry out four kinds of
operations at minimum
we need to be able to access and read
values stored in the structure we need
to be able to search for an arbitrary
value
we also need to be able to insert a
value at any point into the structure
and finally we need to be able to delete
structures
let's look at how these operations are
implemented on the array structure in
some detail starting with access
elements in an array are identified
using a value known as an index and we
use this index to access and read the
value
most programming languages follow a
zero-based numbering system when it
comes to arrays and all this means is
that the first index value is equal to
zero not one
generally speaking when an array is
declared a base amount of contiguous
memory is allocated as the array storage
computers refer to memory through the
use of an address but instead of keeping
a reference to all the memory allocated
for an array the array only has to store
the address of the first location
because the memory is contiguous using
the base address the array can calculate
the address of any value by using the
index position of that value as an
offset
if you want to be more specific think of
it this way
let's say we want to create an array of
integers and then each integer takes up
a certain amount of space in memory that
we'll call m
let's also assume that we know how many
elements we're going to create so the
size of the array is some number of
elements we'll call n
the total amount of space that we need
to allocate is n times the space per
item m
if the array keeps track of the location
in memory where the first value is held
so let's label that m0 then it has all
the information it needs to find any
other element in the list
when accessing a value in an array we
use the index
to get the first element in the list we
use the zeroth index to get the second
we use the index value 1 and so on
given that the array knows how much
storage is needed for each element it
can get the address of any element by
starting off with the address for the
first element and adding to that the
index value times the amount of storage
per element
for example to access the second value
we can start with m0 and to that add m
times the index value 1 giving us m1 as
the location in memory for the second
address
this is a very simplified model but
that's more or less how it works
this is only possible because we know
that array memory is contiguous with no
gaps
let's switch over to some code
as i mentioned earlier we're going to be
using python in this course
if you don't know how to code or you're
interested in this content but know a
language other than python check the
notes section of this video for more
information while the code will be in
python the concepts are universal and
more importantly simple enough that you
should have no issue following along in
your favorite programming language
and to get started click on the launch
workspaces button on the video page that
you're watching right now
this should spin up an instance of a
treehouse workspace an in-browser coding
environment right now your workspace
should be empty and that's expected so
let's add a new file in here i'm going
to go to file new file
and we'll call this arrays
dot py pi
creating a list in python is quite
simple so we'll call this new underscore
list
we use a set of square brackets around a
set of values to create a list so one
and we comma separate them so space two
and space three this allocates a base
amount of memory for the array to use or
when i say array know that in python i
mean a list
since this is python the values aren't
stored in memory
instead the values 1 2 and 3 are stored
elsewhere in memory and the array stores
references to each of those objects
to access a value we use a subscript
along with an index value so to get the
first value we use the index 0 and if we
were to assign this to another variable
we would say result
equal new list
we write out new lists since this is the
array that we're accessing the value
from and then a subscript notation which
is a square bracket
and then the index value
as we saw since the array has a
reference to the base location in memory
the position of any element can be
determined pretty easily
we don't have to iterate over the entire
list
all we need to do is a simple
calculation of an offset from the base
memory since we're guaranteed that the
memory is contiguous
for this reason access is a constant
time operation on an array or a python
list
this is also why an array crashes if you
try to access a value using an index
that is out of bounds of what the array
stores
if you've used an array before you've
undoubtedly run into an error or a crash
where you try to access a value using an
index that was larger than the number of
elements in the array since the array
calculates the memory address on the fly
when you access a value with an out of
bounds index as it's called the memory
address returned is not one that's part
of the array structure and therefore
cannot be read by the array now in
python this is represented by an index
error and we can make this happen by
using an index we know our array won't
contain
now i'm writing out my code here inside
of a text editor which obviously doesn't
run the code so let's drag up this
console area here
and i'm going to write python
to bring up the python interpreter
and in here we can do the same thing so
i can say new
list equal one
comma two comma three and now this is an
interpreter so it's actually going to
evaluate our code
all right so now we have a new list if i
type out new list it gets printed out
into the console
okay i can also do new list square
bracket 0 and you'll see that i get the
value 1 which is the value stored at the
zeroth index
now to highlight that index error we can
do new list
and inside the square brackets we can
provide an index that we know our array
doesn't contain so here i'll say index
10
and if i hit enter you'll see it say
index error list index out of range
and those are the basics of how we
create and read values from an array in
the next video let's take a look at
searching
in the last video we learned what
happens under the hood when we create an
array and read a value using an index
in this video we're going to look at how
the remaining data structure operations
work on arrays
if you took the introduction to
algorithms course we spent time learning
about two search algorithms linear
search and binary search
while arrays are really fast at
accessing values they're pretty bad at
searching
taking an array as is the best we can do
is use linear search for a worst case
linear runtime linear search works by
accessing and reading each value in the
list until the element in concern is
found
if the element we're looking for is at
the end of the list then every single
element in the list will have been
accessed and compared
even though accessing and comparing our
constant time operations having to do
this for every element results in an
overall linear time
let's look at how search works in code
in python we can search for an item in
an array in one of two ways
we can use the in operator to check
whether a list contains an item so i can
say if
one in new underscore
list
then print
true
the in operator actually calls a
contains method that is defined on the
list type which runs a linear search
operation
in addition to this we can also use a
for loop to iterate over the list
manually and perform a comparison
operation
so i can say
for
n in new list
if n equals one then print
true
and then after that break out of the
loop
this is more or less the implementation
of linear search
if the array were sorted however we
could use binary search but because sort
operations incur a cost of their own
languages usually stay away from sorting
the list and running binary search since
for smaller arrays linear search on its
own may be faster
now again remember that
since this is an editor this is just a
text file none of these lines of code
are evaluated so you can try that out in
here so we'll copy that we can come down
here and say python and hit enter and
then when it starts up we can paste in
our list
and now we can try what we just did so
if one in new list
print
true
and there you go it prints true now
because we've already learned about
linear and binary search in a previous
course there's nothing new going on here
what's more interesting to look at in my
opinion is inserting and deleting values
in an array let's start with inserting
in general most array implementations
support three types of insert operations
the first is a true insert using an
index value where we can insert an
element anywhere in the list this
operation has a linear runtime imagine
you wanted to insert an item at the
start of the list when we insert into
the first position what happens to the
item that is currently in that spot
well it has to move to the next spot at
index value one what happens to the
second item at index position one
that one moves to the next spot at index
position two
this keeps happening until all elements
have been shifted forward one index
position
so in the worst case scenario inserting
at the zeroth position of an array every
single item in the array has to be
shifted forward and we know that any
operation that involves iterating
through every single value means a
linear runtime
now the second way we can insert an item
into an array is by appending appending
although technically an insert operation
in that it inserts an item into an
existing array doesn't incur the same
runtime cost because appends simply add
the item to the end of the list
we can simplify and say that this is
constant time this is a constant time
operation but it depends on the language
implementation of array
to highlight why that matters let's
consider how lists in python work in
python when we create a list the list
doesn't know anything about the size of
the list and how many elements we're
going to store
creating a new empty list like so so
numbers equal and two empty brackets
so this creates a list and allocates a
space of size n plus one
since n here is zero there are no
elements in this array in this list
space is allocated for a one element
list to start off
because the space allocated for the list
and the space used by the list are not
the same
what do you think happens when we ask
python for the length of this list so i
can say len numbers
we correctly get 0 back
this means that the list doesn't use the
memory allocation as an indicator of its
size because as i mentioned it has
allocated space for a one element list
but it returns zero so it determines it
in other ways
okay so numbers this list currently has
space for one element
let's use the append method defined on
the type to insert a number at the end
of the list so you can say numbers dot
append and i'll pass in 2.
now the memory allocation and the size
of the list are the same since the list
contains one element
now what if i were to do something like
this numbers.append
there needs to be a dot
and i'll add another value 200.
now since the list only has an
allocation for one item at this point
before it can add the new element to the
list it needs to increase the memory
allocation and thereby the size of the
list it does this by calling a list
resize operation list resizing is quite
interesting because it shows the
ingenuity in solving problems like this
python doesn't resize the list to
accommodate just the element we want to
add
instead in this case it would allocate
four blocks of memory to increase the
size to a total of four contiguous
blocks of memory
it does this so that it doesn't have to
resize the list every single time we add
an element but at very specific points
the growth pattern of the list type in
python is 0 4 8 16 25 35 46 and so on
this means that as the list size
approaches these specific values
resize is called again if you look at
when the size of the list is four
this means that when appending four more
values until the size of eight
each of those append operations do not
increase the amount of space taken
at specific points however when resizing
is triggered space required increases as
memory allocation increases
this might signify that the append
method has a non-constant space
complexity but it turns out that because
some operations don't increase space and
others do
when you average all of them out append
operations take constant space
we say that it has an amortized constant
space complexity this also happens with
insert operations
if we had a four element array we would
have four elements and a memory
allocation of four
an insert operation at that point
doesn't matter where it happens on the
list but at that point it would trigger
a resize
inserting is still more expensive though
because after the resize every element
needs to be shifted over one
the last insert operation that is
supported in most languages is the
ability to add one list to another
in python this is called an extend and
looks like this
so i'll say numbers now if you let me
actually clear out the console
oh actually you will let's exit python
we'll clear this out so we're back at
the top and we'll start again
so i'll say numbers
and we'll set it to an empty list and
now we can say numbers dot extend
and as an argument we're going to pass
in a new list entirely so here we'll say
4 comma 5 comma 6
and then once i hit enter if i were to
print out numbers you'll see that it now
contains the values 4 5 and 6.
so extend takes another list to add
extend effectively makes a series of
append calls on each of the elements in
the new list until all of them have been
appended to the original list this
operation has a run time of big o of k
where k represents the number of
elements in the list that we're adding
to our existing list
the last type of operation we need to
consider are delete operations deletes
are similar to inserts in that when a
delete operation occurs the list needs
to maintain correct index values so
where an insert shifts every element to
the right a delete operation shifts
every element to the left
just like an insert as well if we delete
the first element in the list every
single element in the list needs to be
shifted to the left
delete operations have an upper bound of
big o of n also known as a linear
runtime now that we've seen how common
operations work on a data structure that
we're quite familiar with let's switch
tracks and build our own data structure
[Music]
over the next few videos we're going to
build a data structure that you may have
worked with before a linked list
before we get into what a linked list is
let's talk about why we build data
structures instead of just using the
ones that come built into our languages
each data structure solves a particular
problem
we just went over the basics of the
array data structure and looked at the
cost of common operations that we carry
out on arrays
we found that arrays were particularly
good at accessing reading values happens
in constant time but arrays are pretty
bad at inserting and deleting both of
which run in linear time
linked lists on the other hand are
somewhat better at this although there
are some caveats and if we're trying to
solve a problem that involves far more
inserts and deletes than accessing a
linked list can be a better tool than an
array
so what is a linked list
a linked list is a linear data structure
where each element in the list is
contained in a separate object called a
node a node models two pieces of
information an individual item of the
data we want to store and a reference to
the next node in the list
the first node in the linked list is
called the head of the list while the
last node is called the tail
the head and the tail nodes are special
the list only maintains a reference to
the head although in some
implementations it keeps a reference to
the tail as well
this aspect of linked lists is very
important and as you'll see most of the
operations on the list need to be
implemented quite differently compared
to an array
the opposite of the head the tail
denotes the end of the list
every node other than the tail points to
the next node in the list but tail
doesn't point to anything this is
basically how we know it's the end of
the list nodes are what are called
self-referential objects the definition
of a node includes a link to another
node and self-referential here means the
definition of node includes the node
itself linked lists often come in two
forms a singly linked list where each
node stores a reference to the next node
in the list or a doubly linked list
where each node stores a reference to
both the node before and after if an
array is a train with a bunch of cars in
order then a linked list is like a
treasure hunt
when you start the hunt you have a piece
of paper with the location of the first
treasure you go to that location and you
find an item along with a location to
the next item of treasure
when you finally find an item that
doesn't also include a location you know
that the hunt has ended
now that we have a high level view of
what a linked list is let's jump into
code and build one together we'll focus
on building a singly linked list for
this course there are advantages to
having a doubly linked list but we don't
want to get ahead of ourselves
let's start here by creating a new file
we're going to put all our code for our
linked list so we'll call this linked
underscore list
dot pi and first we're going to create a
class to represent a node
say class
node
now node is a simple object in that it
won't model much so first we'll add a
data variable
it's an instance variable here called
data and we'll assign the value none
initially
and then we'll add one more we'll call
this next node and to this we'll assign
none as well so we've created two
instance variables data to hold on to
the data that we're storing and next
node to point to the next node in the
list
now we need to add a constructor to make
this class easy to create so we'll add
an init
method here that takes self and some
data to start off
and all we're going to do is assign
data to that instance variable we
created so that's all we need to model
node
before we do anything else though let's
document this so right after the class
definition let's create a docs string so
three quotes
next line and we'll say an object
for storing
a single
node of a linked list
and then on the next line we'll say
models two attributes
data
and
the link to the next
node in the list
and then we'll close this doc string off
with three more quotation marks okay
using the node class is fairly
straightforward so we can create a new
instance of node with some data to store
now the way we're going to do this is
we're going to bring up the console
and we're going to type out like we've
been typing out before python followed
by the name of the script that we wrote
which is linked list linked underscore
list.pi but before we do that we're
going to pass an argument to the python
command we're going to say dash or
python i and then the name of the script
linked underscore list dot pi so what
this does is this is going to run the
python repl
the read evaluate print loop in the
console but it's going to load the
contents of our file into that so that
we can use it
so i'll hit enter and we have a new
instance going and now we can use the
node in here so we can say n1
equal node
and since we defined that constructor we
can pass it some data so we'll say 10
here
now if we try to inspect this object the
representation returned isn't very
useful
which will make things really hard to
debug as our code grows so for example
if i type out n1 you'll see that
we have a valid instance here but it's
not very helpful the way it's printed
out
so we can customize this by adding a
representation of the object using the
wrapper function now in the terminal
still we'll type out exit
like that hit enter to exit the console
and then down here
let's add in some room
okay and here we'll say def
double underscore
wrapper another set of double
underscores
and then this function takes the
argument self
and in here we can provide a string
representation of what we want printed
to the console when we inspect that
object inside of it inside of a console
so here we'll say return
again
this is a string representation so
inside quotes we'll say
node so this represents a node instance
and the data it contains here we'll say
percent s
which is a python way of substituting
something into a string string
interpolation and outside of the string
we can say percent again
and here we're saying we want to replace
this percent s with
self.data okay
let's hit save and before we move on
let's verify that this works so i'm
going to come in here
type clear to get rid of everything
and then we'll do what we did again and
you can just hit the up arrow a couple
times to get that command
all right so hit enter and now just so
you know every time you run this you
start off you know from scratch so n1
that we created earlier not there
anymore so let's go ahead and create it
n1 equal node
10
and we can type n1 again and hit enter
and you have a much better
representation now so we can see that we
have a node and it contains the data 10.
we can also create another one n2 equal
node that contains the data 20 and now
we can say n1.next n1.nextnode
equal n2 so n1 now points to n2 and if
we say n1.nextnode
you'll see that it points to that node
the node containing 20.
nodes are the building blocks for a list
and now that we have a node object we
can use it to create a singly linked
list so again i'm going to exit out of
this
and then go back to the text editor
and here we'll create a new class so
class
linked
list
the linked list class is going to define
a head and this attribute models the
only node that the list is going to have
a reference to so here we'll say head
and we'll assign none initially and then
like we did earlier let's create a
constructor
so double underscore init double
underscore this takes self
and then inside like before we'll say
self dot head
equal none this is the same
as doing this so we can actually get rid
of that and just use the constructor
okay so again this head attribute models
the only node that the list will have a
reference to since every node points to
the next node to find a particular node
we can go from one node to the next in a
process called list traversal
so in the class constructor here we've
set the default value of head to none so
that new lists created are always empty
again you'll notice here that i didn't
explicitly declare the head attribute at
the top of the class definition
and don't worry that's not an oversight
the self.head in the initializer means
that it's still created okay so that's
all there is to modeling a linked list
now we can add methods that make it
easier to use this data structure
first a really simple docstring to
provide some information
so here we'll to create a docstring
three quotation marks
and then we'll say singly linked list
and then close it off
a common operation carried out on data
structures is checking whether it
contains any data or whether it's empty
at the moment to check if a list is
empty we would need to query these
instance variables head and so on every
time
ideally we would like to not expose the
inner workings of our data structure to
code that uses it
instead let's make this operation more
explicit by defining a method so we'll
say def is empty
and this method takes self as an
argument and here we'll say return
self.head double equal none
all we're doing here is checking to see
if head is none
if it is this condition evaluates to
true which indicates the list is empty
now before we end this video let's add
one more convenience method to calculate
the size of our list the name
convenience method indicates that what
this method is doing is not providing
any additional functionality that our
data structure can't handle right now
but instead making existing
functionality easier to use
we could calculate the size of our
linked list by traversing it every time
using a loop until we hit a tail node
but doing that every time is a hassle
okay so we'll call this method
size and as always it takes self
unlike calling len on a python list not
to be confused with a linked list which
is a constant time operation our size
operation is going to run in linear time
the only way we can count how many items
we have is to visit each node and call
next until we hit the tail node
so we'll start by getting a reference to
the head we'll say current
equal self.head let's also define a
local variable named count with an
initial value of 0 that will increment
every time we visit a node once we hit
the tail count will reflect the size of
that list
next we'll define a while loop that will
keep going until there are no more nodes
so say while current
while current is the same as writing out
while current does not equal none but
it's more succinct so we'll go with this
former
if the ladder is more precise for you
you can go with that
now inside this loop we'll increment the
count value so count plus equal one
plus equal if you haven't encountered it
before is the same as writing count
equal count plus one so if count is zero
initially so it's zero plus one is one
and then we'll assign that back to count
okay so count plus equal one
next we're going to assign the next node
in the list to current so current equal
current dot next
node
this way once we get to the tail and
call next node current will equal none
and the while loop terminates so the end
we can return
count
as you can see we need to visit every
node to determine the size meaning our
algorithm runs in linear time so let's
document this
up in our docs string which we'll add
now to size
we'll say
returns
the number of nodes in the list
takes
linear time
let's take a break here we can now
create lists check if they're empty and
check the size
in the next video let's start
implementing some common operations
at the moment we can create an empty
list but nothing else let's define a
method to add data to our list
technically speaking there are three
ways we can add data to a list
we can add nodes at the head of the list
which means that the most recent node we
created will be the head and the first
node we created will be the tail
or we could flip that around most recent
nodes are the tail of the list and the
first node to be added is the head i
mentioned that one of the advantages of
linked lists over arrays is that
inserting data into the list is much
more efficient than to the array
this is only true if we're inserting at
the head or the tail
technically speaking this isn't an
insert and you'll often see this method
called add prepend if the data is added
to the head or append if it's added to
the tail
a true insert is where you can insert
the data at any point in the list which
is our third way of adding data we're
going to circle back on that if we
wanted to insert at the tail then the
list needs a reference to the tail node
otherwise we would have to start at the
head and walk down the length of the
list or traverse it to find the tail
since our list only keeps a reference to
the head we're going to add new items at
the head of the list
now before we add our new method i
forgot that i didn't show you in the
last video how to actually use the code
we just added and how to check every
time you know when we add new code that
it works correctly
so like before we're gonna bring up the
console and here we're gonna say python
dash i
linked underscore list dot pi which
should load it
load the contents of our file
and now we'll start here by creating a
linked list so l equal linked list
and then we'll use a node so n1 equal
node
with the value 10
and now we can assign n1 to the nodes or
to the linked lists head attribute so l1
dot head equal n1
and then
we can see if size works correctly so if
we call l1 dot size and since this is a
method we need a set of parentheses at
the end
and enter you'll see that we get back
one correctly okay so it works
now let's add our new method which we're
going to call add
add is going to accept some data to add
to the list inside of a node
so we'll say def
add
and every python method takes self as an
argument and then we want to add some
data to this node so we're going to say
data for the second argument
inside the method first we'll create a
new node to hold on to the data so new
underscore node equal
node with the data
before we set the new node as the head
of the list we need to point the new
node's next property at whatever node is
currently at head this way when we set
the new node as the head of the list we
don't lose a reference to the old head
so new underscore node dot next node
equal self.head
now if there was no node at head this
correctly sets next node to none
now we can set the new node as the head
of the node so say self.head equal
new underscore node because the insert
operation is simply a reassignment of
the head and next node properties this
is a constant time operation so let's
add that in as a docs string
first what the method does so it adds a
new node
containing data
at the head of the list
this operation takes
constant time which is our best case
scenario
okay let's test this out so i'm going to
bring the console back up we'll exit out
of
our current reply
and we'll load
the contents of the file again
and now we don't need to create a node
like we did earlier so we can say l
equal linked
list
l.add one
okay let's see if this works we'll call
size
and if it worked
the linked list should now have a size
of one there we go you can also do
l.add2
l.add three
and l dot size should now be three there
we go now if we i were to type l and
just hit print
again what we get in the repel is
nothing useful
so like before we'll implement the
wrapper function for our linked list
now
i'm just going to copy paste this in and
we'll walk through it
okay so this is what our implementation
of wrapper looks like for the linked
list object you can grab this code from
the notes section of this video
okay so at the top you'll see a docs
string where it says it returns a string
representation of the list and like
everything we need to do with a linked
list we need to traverse it so this is
going to take linear time we start by
creating an empty list now i need to
distinguish this is a python list not a
linked list so we create an empty list
called nodes and two nodes we're going
to add strings that have a description
that provide a description of each node
but we're not going to use the
description that we implemented in the
node class because we're going to
customize it a bit here
next we start by assigning self.head to
current so we sort of have a pointer to
the head node as long as current does
not equal none which means we're not at
the tail we're going to implement some
logic
so in the first scenario if the node
assigned to current is the same as the
head
then we're going to append this string
to our nodes list
and the string is simply
going to say that hey this is a head
node and it contains some data which
will extract using current.data
next scenario is if the node assigned to
current's next node is none meaning
we're at the tail node then we'll assign
a different kind of string so it's the
same as earlier except we're saying tail
here and then finally in any other
scenario which means we're not at the
head or not of the tail we'll simply
print the node's value inside and again
we'll extract it using current.data with
every iteration of the loop we'll move
current forward by calling
current.nextnode and reassigning it
and then at the very end when we're done
we'll join all the strings that are
inside the nodes list together using the
python join method and we'll say that
with every join so when you join these
two strings together to make one string
you need to put this set of characters
in between all right so let's see what
this looks like
so i'm going to come down here exit out
of the console again
clear it out
load the contents of the file again and
let's try that so we'll say l equal
linked list
all right so l dot add one l dot add two
l dot add three that seems enough
and then now if i type out l and hit
enter we get a nice string
representation of the list so you can
see that we add every new node to the
head so we added one first one ends up
being the tail because it keeps getting
pushed out
then two and then finally three so three
is at the head
so far we've only implemented a single
method which functions much like the
append method on a python list or an
array
except it adds it to the start of the
linked list it pre-pens it
like append this happens in constant
time in the next video let's add the
ability to search through our list for
the search operation we're going to
define a method that takes a value to
search for and returns either the node
containing the value if the value is
found or none if it isn't
so right after actually you know what
we'll make sure wrapper is the last
function our last method
in our class so we'll add it above it so
here we'll say def search
self
and then key
in the last video we implemented the
wrapper method to provide a string
representation of the list
so we're going to use similar logic here
to implement the search function we'll
start by setting a local variable
current to point to the head of the list
while the value assigned to current is a
valid node that is it isn't none
we'll check if the data on that node
matches the key that we're searching for
so while current
we'll say if
current.data
is the key
then we'll return current
if it does match we'll go ahead and
return it like we've done here but if it
doesn't we'll assign the next node in
the list to current and check again so
say else
current equal current dot next node
once we hit the tail node and haven't
found the key
current gets set to none and the while
loop exits
at this point we know the list doesn't
contain the key so we can return
none
okay that completes the body of our
method
let's add a docs string to document this
so up at the top we'll say search
for the first node
containing data that matches
the key
now this is important because if our
linked list contains more than one node
with the same value it doesn't matter
we're going to return the first one with
this implementation
we'll also say here that it returns the
node or none
if not found
in the worst case scenario we'll need to
check every single node in the list
before we find the key or fail and as a
result this operation runs in linear
time so i'll say takes
o of n or linear time
so far we haven't seen anything that
indicates this data structure has any
advantage over an array or a python list
but we knew that
i mentioned the strength of linked lists
comes in inserts and deletes at specific
positions we'll check that out in the
next video but as always before we end
this one let's make sure everything
works
so we'll load the contents of the file
again
l equal linked
list
and then we'll say l.add 10
l dot add
20 2 doesn't matter l dot add
45 and one more metal dot add
15.
now we can say
l.search and we need to give it a value
so we'll say 45 and this returns a node
or none so we'll say n equal
and then we'll hit enter if this works
n should be a node
okay weirdly n
does not work here
at least it says it's not a node which
means i made a mistake in typing out our
code
and looking at it immediately it's
fairly obvious so this return none needs
to be outside of the while loop okay so
i'm going to hit save now so make sure
it's on the same indentation here which
means it's outside the while loop
and then we'll run through this again
okay so l is linked list
l.add 10
l dot add 2
l.add
45 and what was the last one we did i
believe it was 15
and now we should be able to say
l.search remember we're assigning this
to a node to a variable so l.search
45
and there you go we get that node back
and we can hit l
and we'll see a representation of our
list
okay so again in the next video inserts
and deletes at specific positions
insert operations on linked lists are
quite interesting
unlike arrays where when you insert an
element into the array all elements
after the particular index need to be
shifted with a linked list we just need
to change the references to next on a
few nodes and we're good to go
since each node points to the next one
by swapping out these references we can
insert a node at any point in the list
in constant time
much like binary search though there's a
catch
to find the node at that position we
want to insert we need to traverse the
list and get to that point
we just implemented our search algorithm
for the linked list type and we know
that this runs in linear time so while
actually inserting is fast finding the
position in the list you want to insert
it is not
this is why i mentioned that there were
some caveats to inserting
anyway let's see what this looks like in
code
we'll define a method named insert that
takes data to insert along with an index
position so we'll do this after search
right here
say def
insert
and this takes some data to insert and a
position to insert it at
you may be thinking wait a minute linked
lists don't have index positions right
and you're correct but we can mimic that
behavior by just counting the number of
times we access next node
if the index value passed into this
argument is 0 that means we want to
insert the new node at the head of the
list this is effectively the same
behavior as calling add which means the
logic is the same so we don't need to
repeat it we can call the add method we
wrote earlier so we'll say if
index if index equals 0 or if index is 0
then self dot add
data
if the index is greater than 0 then we
need to traverse the list to find the
current node at that index
so if index is greater than zero
now before we do that we need to create
a new node containing the data we want
to insert so we'll say new equal node
with some data
i'm going to assign index the argument
passed to our function to a local
variable named position and the head of
the list to a variable named current
position
equal index
current equal self.head
every time we call
current.nextnode meaning we're moving to
the next node in the list we'll decrease
the value of position by 1.
when position is zero we'll have arrived
at the node that's currently at the
position we want to insert in
in reality though we don't want to
decrease it all the way to zero
imagine we have a list with five nodes
and we want to insert a node at position
3. to insert a node at position 3 we
need to modify the nodes at positions 2
and 3.
node 2's next node attribute is going to
point to the new node and the new node's
next node attribute will point to node
3.
in this way an insert is a constant time
operation we don't need to shift every
single element we just modify a few next
node references
in a doubly linked list we can use node
3 to carry out both of these operations
node 3 in a doubly linked list would
have a reference to node 2 and we can
use this reference to modify all the
unnecessary links
and a singly linked list though which is
what we have if we kept decreasing
position until we're at 0 we arrive at
node 3.
we can then set the new node's next node
property to point to node 3 but we have
no way of getting a reference to node 2
which we also need
for this reason it's easier to decrease
position to just 1 when it equals 1 and
stop at node 2. so in here we'll say
while
position
is greater than one
now while the position is greater than
one we'll keep calling next node and
reassigning the current node so current
equal node.next
node and at the same time we'll
decrement position so position
equal to position
minus one which you can also succinctly
write as minus equal
one
this way when the position equals one
the loop exits and current will refer to
the node at the position before the
insert point so outside the while loop
we'll say previous equal current
and next equal current dot next
node
to make things more clear what i've done
here is name the node before the new one
previous and the node after the new one
next
all that's left to do now is to insert
the new node between previous and next
so we'll say previous dot next
node
equal
new
and then new dot next node
equal next
now it seems like there's an issue with
variable naming here and i'm most
probably conflicting with some globally
named next variable so actually go ahead
and call this next node
and
previous node so that we don't mess
things up here
previous node
so the dot next node is obviously the
attribute on a node but this is just a
local variable let's document this
method so up at the top
we'll add a docs string and it will say
inserts a new node
containing
data at index
position
insertion takes
constant time
but finding the node
at the insertion point
takes linear
time
let's add this to the next line
there we go
and then we'll say therefore it takes an
overall
linear time
this is why even though we can easily
insert a new node without having to
shift the rest ultimately adding to
either the head or the tail if you have
a reference is much more efficient
we have one more operation to add to our
linked list that will make it a robust
data structure
much like inserts removing a node is
actually quite fast and occurs in
constant time but to actually get to the
node that we want to remove and modify
the next connections we need to traverse
the entire list in our worst case so in
the worst case this takes linear time
let's add this operation to our data
structure
there are two ways we can define the
remove method one where we provide a key
to remove as an argument and one where
we provide an index now in the former
the key refers to the data the node
stores so in order to remove that node
we would first need to search for data
that matches the key i'm going to
implement that first method which we'll
call remove and i'll leave it up to you
to get some practice in and implement a
remove at index method to complete our
data structure so we'll add this after
the insert method right here
remove
is going to accept a key which we'll
need to search for before we can remove
a node earlier we defined a search
method that found a node containing data
that matches a key but we can't use that
method as is for the implementation of
remove when we remove a node much like
the insert operation we need to modify
the next node references
the node before the match needs to point
to the node after the match
if we use the search method we defined
earlier we get the node we want to
remove as a return value but because
this is a singly linked list we can't
obtain a reference to the previous node
like i said earlier if this was a doubly
linked list we could use the search
method since we would have a reference
to that previous node
we'll start here by setting a local
variable named current to point to the
head let's also define a variable named
previous
that will set to none to keep track of
the previous node as we traverse the
list
finally let's declare a variable named
found that we'll set to false
found is going to serve as a stopping
condition for the loop that we'll define
we'll use the loop to keep traversing
the linked list as long as found is
false meaning we haven't found the key
that we're looking for once we've found
it we'll set found to true and the loop
terminates so let's set up our loop so
we'll say while current
and
not
found
here we're defining a while loop that
contains two conditions
first we tell the loop to keep iterating
as long as current does not equal none
when current equals none this means
we've gone past the tail node and the
key doesn't exist
the second condition asks the loop to
keep evaluating as long as not found
equals true now this might be tricky
because it involves a negation here
right now found is set to false so not
found not false equals true this not
operator flips the value
when we find the key and we set found to
true
not true not found we'll equal false
then and the loop will stop
the end in the while loop means that
both conditions current being a valid
node and not found equalling true both
have to be true
if either one of them evaluates to false
then the loop will terminate
now inside the loop there are three
situations that we can run into
first the key matches the current node's
data and current is still at the head of
the list
this is a special case because the head
doesn't have a previous node and it's
the only node being referenced by the
list let's handle this case so we'll say
if current.data
double equals the key and current
is self.head which you can write out as
current equal self.head or current is
self.head
now if we hit this case
we'll indicate that we found the key by
setting found to true
and then this means that on the next
pass
this is going to evaluate to false
because not true will be false
and then the loop terminates once we do
that we want to remove the current node
and since it's the head node all we need
to do is point head to the second node
in the list which we can get by
referencing the next node attribute on
current self.head equal current.nextnode
so when we do this there's nothing
pointing to that first node so it's
automatically removed the next scenario
is when the key matches data in the node
and it's a node that's not the head
so here we'll say else if current dot
data equal key
if the current node contains the key
we're looking for we need to remove it
to remove the current node we need to go
to the previous node and modify its next
node reference to point to the node
after current
but first we'll set found
to true
and then we'll switch out the references
so
previous.nextnode
equal
current.nextnode
so far we haven't written any code to
keep track of the previous node
we'll do that in our else case here
so if we hit the else case it means that
the current node we're evaluating
doesn't contain the data that matches
the key so in this case we'll make
previous point to the current node and
then set current to the next node so
previous equal current
and current equal current.nextnode
and that's it for the implementation of
remove
now we're not doing anything at the
moment with the node we're removing but
it's common for remove operations to
return the value being removed so at the
bottom
outside the while loop
let's return
current
and with that we have a minimal
implementation of a linked list and your
first custom data structure how cool is
that
there's quite a bit we can do here to
improve our data structure particularly
in making it easy to use but this is a
good place to stop
before we move on to the next topic
let's document our method so the top
another docs string
and here we'll say removes node
containing data that matches the key
also it returns the node or none
if the key doesn't exist
and finally this takes
linear time because in the worst case
scenario we need to search the entire
list
if you'd like to get in some additional
practice implementing functionality for
linked lists two methods you can work on
are remove it index and node at index to
allow you to easily delete or read
values in a list at a given index
now that we have a linked list let's
talk about where you can use them the
honest answer is not a lot of places
linked lists are really useful
structures to build for learning
purposes because they're relatively
simple and are a good place to start to
introduce the kinds of operations we
need to implement for various data
structures it is quite rare however that
you will need to implement a linked list
on your own
there are typically much better and by
that i mean much more efficient data
structures that you can use
in addition many languages like java for
example provide an implementation of a
linked list already
now that we have a custom data structure
let's do something with it let's combine
the knowledge we have and look at how a
sorting algorithm can be implemented
across two different data structures
[Music]
now that we've seen two different data
structures let's circle back and apply
what we know about algorithms to these
new concepts
one of the first algorithms you learned
about was binary search and we learned
that with binary search there was one
precondition the data collection needs
to be sorted
over the next few videos let's implement
the merge sort algorithm which is one of
many sorting algorithms on both arrays
or python lists and the singly linked
list we just created
this way we can learn a new sorting
algorithm that has real world use cases
and see how a single algorithm can be
implemented on different data structures
before we get into code let's take a
look at how merge sort works
conceptually and we'll use an array to
work through this
we start with an unsorted array of
integers and our goal is to end up with
an array sorted in ascending order
merge sort works like binary sort by
splitting up the problem into sub
problems but it takes the process one
step further
on the first pass we're going to split
the array into two smaller arrays now in
binary search one of these subarrays
would be discarded but that's not what
happens here
on the second pass we're going to split
each of those subarrays into further
smaller evenly sized arrays and we're
going to keep doing this until we're
down to single element arrays
after that the merge sort algorithm
works backwards repeatedly merging the
single element arrays and sorting them
at the same time
since we start at the bottom by merging
to single element arrays we only need to
make a single comparison to sort the
resulting merge array by starting with
smaller arrays that are sorted as they
grow
merge sort has to execute fewer sort
operations than if it sorted the entire
array at once
solving a problem like this by
recursively breaking down the problem
into subparts until it is easily solved
is an algorithmic strategy known as
divide and conquer but instead of
talking about all of this in the
abstract let's dive into the code this
way we can analyze the runtime as we
implement it
for our first implementation of merge
sort we're going to use an array or a
python list
while the implementation won't be
different conceptually for a linked list
we will have to write more code because
of list traversal and how nodes are
arranged so once we have these concepts
squared away we'll come back to that
let's add a new file here
we'll call this merge underscore sort
dot pi
in our file let's create a new function
named merge sort that takes a list and
remember when i say list unless i
specify linked list i mean a python list
which is the equivalent of an array so
we'll say def
merge underscore sort
and takes a list
in the introduction to algorithms course
we started our study of each algorithm
by defining the specific steps that
comprise the algorithm
let's write that out as a docstring
in here the steps of the algorithm so
that we can refer to it right in our
code
this algorithm is going to sort the
given list in an ascending order so
we'll start by putting that in here as a
simple definition
sorts a list in ascending
order
there are many variations of merge sort
and in the one we're going to implement
we'll create and return a new sorted
list other implementations will sort the
list we pass in and this is less typical
in an operation known as sort in place
but i think that returning a new list
makes it easier to understand the code
now these choices do have implications
though and we'll talk about them as we
write this code
for our next bit of the docs string
let's write down the output of this
algorithm so returns
a new
sorted list
merge sort has three main steps
the first is the divide step where we
find the midpoint of the list so i'll
say divide
find the mid point of the list and
divide
into sub-lists
the second step is the conquer step
where we sort the sub-list that we
created in the divide step so we'll say
recursively
sort the sub-lists created in previous
step
and finally the combine the combined
step where we merge these recursively
sorted sub-lists back into a single list
so merge the sorted sub-lists
created in previous
step
when we learned about algorithms we
learned that a recursive function has a
basic pattern first we start with a base
case that includes a stopping condition
after that we have some logic that
breaks down the problem and recursively
calls itself
our stopping condition is our end goal a
sorted array
now to come up with a stopping condition
or a base case we need to come up with
the simplest condition that satisfies
this end result
so there are two possible values that
fit a single element list or an empty
list
now in both of these situations we don't
have any work to do
if we give the merge sort function an
empty list or a list with one element
it's technically already sorted we call
this naively sorting so let's add that
as our stopping condition we'll say if
len list if the length of the list is
less than or equal to one
then we can return the list
okay so this is a stopping condition
and now that we have a stopping
condition we can proceed with the list
of steps
first we need to divide the list into
sub lists
to make our functions easier to
understand we're going to put our logic
in a couple different functions instead
of one large one so i'll say it left
half
comma right half
equal
split
list so here we're calling a split
function that splits the list we pass in
and returns two lists split at the
midpoint because we're returning two
lists we can capture them in two
variables
now you should know that this split
function is not something that comes
built into python this is a global
function that we're about to write
next is the conquer step where we sort
each sub-list and return a new sorted
sub-list
so we'll say left equal
merge sort
left half
and right equal merge sort
right half
this is the recursive portion of our
function so here we're calling merge
sort on this divided sub list so we
divide the list into two here and then
we call merge sort on it again
this further splits that sublist into
two in the next pass through of merge
sort this is going to be called again
and again and again until we reach our
stopping condition where we have single
element lists or empty lists
when we've subdivided until we cannot
divide any more then we'll end up with a
left and a right half
and we can
start merging backwards so we'll say
return
merge
left and right
that brings us to the combined step
once two sub-lists are sorted and
combined we can return it
now obviously none of these functions
merge merge sort well merge sort is
written but merge and split haven't been
written so all we're going to do here if
we run it is raise an error so in the
next video let's implement the split
operation
the first bit of logic we're going to
write is the divide step of the
algorithm this step is fairly
straightforward and only requires a few
lines of code but is essential to get
the sorting process going
all right so as we saw earlier we're
going to call the function for the
divide step split so we'll say def split
and split is going to take as an
argument a list to split up
let's document how this function works
so we'll say
divide the unsorted list at midpoint
into sub lists and it's always good to
say what we're returning as well so
we'll say returns to sub-lists
left and right
all right so the first step is to
determine the midpoint of this list of
this array
we're going to use the floor division
operator for this
floor division carries out a division
operation and if we get a non-integer
value like 2.5 back it just gets rounded
down to two we'll define the midpoint to
be the length of the list divided by two
and then rounded down
so
lan list
and using the
two forward slashes for the floor
division operator we'll put number two
after it
okay once we have the midpoint we can
use the slicing notation in python to
extract portions of the list we want to
return
for instance we can define left
as the left sub-list that goes all the
way from the start of the list
all the way up to the midpoint without
including the midpoint
now over here we're using the slicing
syntax where it's like using the you
know subscript notation to access a
value from a list but instead we give
two index values as a start and stop
if we don't include a start value as
i've done here python interprets that as
starting from the zeroth index or the
start of the list now similarly we can
define right
[Music]
to be values on the right of the
midpoint so starting at the midpoint and
going all the way up to the end of the
list
so a couple things to note as i said
earlier when you don't include the
starting index it interprets it as to
start at the very beginning of the list
the index you give as the stopping
condition that value is not included in
the slice so over here we're starting at
the very beginning of list and we go all
the way up to midpoint but not including
midpoint and then right starts at
midpoint so it includes that value and
then goes all the way to the end of the
list
now once we have these two sub-lists we
can return them
so we'll return left and right notice
that we're returning two values here and
then in the merge sort function when we
call that split function
we're declaring two variables left half
and right half to assign so that we can
assign these two sub lists to them
okay and that's all there is to the
split function in the next video let's
implement the crucial portion of the
merge sort logic
once we run the split function
recursively over the array we should end
up with several single member or empty
arrays
at this point we need to merge them all
back and sort them in the process which
is what our merge function is for
the merge function is going to take two
arrays or lists as arguments and to
match the naming conventions we used in
the split function we'll call this left
and right as well so we'll say def merge
takes a left and a right list
now like before let's add some
documentation to our function so this
function merges to lists or arrays
sorting them in the process
and then it returns a new merged list
since our function is going to return a
new list let's start by creating one
now in the process of merging we need to
sort the values in both lists
to sort we need to compare values from
each array or each list so next let's
create two local variables to keep track
of index values that we're using for
each list
so the convention here is i and j so
we'll stick to it
so i equals 0 j equals 0.
as we inspect each value in either list
we'll use the variables to keep track of
the indexes of those values so we'll use
i to keep track of indexes in the left
list and j for indexes in the right list
when merging we want to keep sorting the
values until we've worked through both
lists so for our loop let's set up two
conditions with an and operator so we'll
say while
let's just stay up here while i is less
than
while i is less than the length of the
left list
and j
is less than the length
of the right list then we'll keep
executing our loop so here we're
ensuring that as long as i is less than
the length of the left list
and the and is important and j is less
than the length of the right list we're
going to keep executing the code now i
and j are both set to zero initially
which means that our first comparison
operation will be on the first element
of each list respectively so we'll say
if
left i so i zero so this is going to get
the first value out of the left list
is less than right
j
and again here
j is zero so we're going to get the
first value out of the right list now if
the value at index i in the left list is
less than the value at index j in the
right list what do we do well that means
the value being compared in left is less
than the value in the right and can be
placed at position 0 in the new array l
that we created earlier so here we'll
say l dot append
left
i
since we've read and done something with
the value at position i let's increment
that value so we move forward to
evaluate the next item in the left list
i plus one or we can say i plus equal
one okay next is an else statement
and here we'll say
if the value at index i so i don't have
to write out the actual logic because
it's implied so here we're saying that
left the value at left is less than the
value at right now in the else clause if
the value at so i equal
is greater and i haven't written out
that condition because it's implied so
here we're saying if the value in the
left is less than the value in the right
so in the else clause it's going to mean
that the value in the left is either
greater than or equal to the value in
the right but when we hit the else
clause if the value at index i in the
left list is greater
then we place the value at index j from
the right list at the start of the new
one list l
and similarly increment j so here we'll
say l dot append
right
j and then j equal j plus one
doing this doesn't necessarily mean that
in one step we'll have a completely
sorted array but remember that because
we start with single element arrays and
combine with each merge step we will
eventually sort all the values more than
one time and by the time the entire
process is done all the values are
correctly sorted
now this isn't all we need to do in the
merge step however there are two
situations we can run into one where the
left array is larger than the right and
vice versa so this can occur when an
array containing an odd number of
elements needs to be split so how do you
split a three element array or list well
the left can have two elements and the
right can have one or the other way
around
in either case our while loop uses an
and condition
where the variables used to store the
indexes need to be less than the length
of the lists if the left list is shorter
than the right then the first condition
returns false and the entire loop
returns false because it's an and
condition
this means that in such an event when
the while loop terminates not all the
values in the right list will have been
moved over to the new combined list
so to account for this let's add two
more while loops
the first while loop is going to account
for a situation where the right list is
shorter than the left and the previous
loop terminated because we reached the
end of the right list first
so in this case what we're going to do
is simply add the remaining elements in
the left to the new list
we're not going to compare elements
because we're going to assume that
within a list the elements are already
sorted
so while i
is less than length of left
then
it's the same logic l dot append left
i
and i
plus equal one
so the while loop is going to have the
similar condition keep the loop going
until it's at the last index
inside the body we're incrementing the
index with every iteration of the loop
our final loop accounts for the opposite
scenario where the left was shorter than
the right
the only difference here is that we're
going to use the variable j along with
the right list so we'll say while j
is less than length of right
l dot append
right
j
and j plus equal one okay let's stop
here in the next video let's test out
merge sort make sure our code is running
correctly and everything is written well
and then we'll wrap up this stage by
documenting our code and evaluating the
run time of our algorithm in the last
video we completed our implementation
for the merge sort algorithm but we
didn't test it in any way let's define a
new list at the bottom that contains
several numbers
you can put whatever you want in there
but make sure that the numbers are not
in order i'll call mine a list
and in here
we'll say 54
26 or 62 doesn't matter 93 17
77
31
just add enough so that you can make out
that it's sorted okay next we're going
to call the merge sort algorithm
and pass in our list let's assign this
to some variables so we'll say l equal
merge
underscore sort
a list
and then if it works correctly we should
be able to print this list and see what
it looks like so i'm going to hit save
down here in the console we'll tap out
python
merge sort dot pi
and before i hit enter i actually
noticed i made an error in the last
video but i'll hit enter anyway and you
should see the error pop up okay so what
i forgot to do which is a pretty crucial
part of our algorithm is in the merge
function i forgot to return the list
containing the sorted numbers after
carrying out all this logic
so here at the bottom
we'll say return
l
all right we'll save again
and now we'll clear this out and try
that one more time
and there we go
you should see a sorted list printed out
we can write out a more robust function
to test this because with bigger arrays
visually evaluating that printed list
won't always be feasible so bring this
back down
let's get rid of this
and we'll call our
function verify sorted
and this will take a list
first we're going to check inside the
body of the function we'll check the
length of the list
if the list is a single element list or
an empty list we don't need to do any
unnecessary work because remember it is
naively sorted so we'll say if n
equals 0 or
if n equals
1
then we'll return true we've verified
that it's sorted
now to conclude our function we're going
to write out one line of code that will
actually do quite a bit of work
so first we'll say return
list
zero so we'll take the first element out
of the list and we'll compare and see if
that's less than the second element in
the list okay so first we'll check that
the first element in the list is less
than the second element in the list
this returns either true or false so we
can return that directly
but this isn't sufficient if it were we
could trick the verify function by only
sorting the first two elements in the
list
so to this return statement we're going
to use an and operator to add on one
more condition for this condition we're
going to make a recursive function call
back to verify
sorted
and for the argument we're going to pass
in the list
going from the second element all the
way
to the end let's visualize how this
would work
we'll use a five element list as an
example so we'll call verify sorted and
pass in the entire list
this list is not one or zero elements
long so we skip that first if statement
there's only one line of code left in
the function and first we check that the
element at index 0 is less than the
element at index 1. if this is false the
function returns immediately with a
false value
an and operator requires both conditions
to be true for the entire line of code
to return true
since the first condition evaluates to
false we don't need to bother evaluating
the second the second condition is a
recursive call with a sub-list
containing elements from the original
list starting at position 1 and going to
the end
so on the second call again we can skip
that first if statement and proceed to
check whether the value at element 0 is
less than the value at element 1.
remember that because this list is a
sub-list of the original starting at the
element that was the second element in
the original list
by comparing the elements at position 0
and 1 in the sub list we're effectively
comparing the elements at position 1 and
2 in the original list with each
recursive call as we create new sub
lists that start at index position 1
we're able to check the entire list
without having to specify any checks
other than the first two elements
since this is a recursive function it
means we need a stopping condition and
we have it already it's that first if
condition
as we keep making sub lists once we
reach a single element list that element
is already sorted by definition so we
can return true since this recursive
function call is part of an and
condition
it means that every single recursive
call has to return true all the way back
to the beginning for our top level
function to return true and for the
function to say yes this is sorted
now we could have easily done this using
an iterative solution and a for loop but
this way you get another example of
recursion to work through and understand
so let's use this function
at the bottom we'll say print
verify sorted and first we'll pass in a
list
oops we got rid of that didn't we
okay let me write it out again so a list
equal
and i think i have those original
numbers here somewhere so we'll say 54
26 93
okay and then we assigned to l the
result of calling merge
sort
on a list
okay so now here we're going to use the
verify sorted function
and we'll check first that a list is
sorted that should return false and then
we'll check the same call on we'll pass
an l and this should return true
okay so now at the bottom here in the
console
we'll call python merge sort dot pi and
there we go it returned false for a list
meaning it's not sorted but l is sorted
cool so our merge sort function works in
the next video let's talk about the cost
of this algorithm
if we go back to the top level the merge
sort function what is the run time of
this function look like and what about
space complexity how does memory usage
grow as the algorithm runs
to answer those questions let's look at
the individual steps starting with the
split function in the split function all
we're doing is finding the midpoint of
the list and splitting the list at the
midpoint
this seems like a constant time
operation but remember that the split
function isn't called once it's called
as many times as we need it to to go
from the initial list down to a single
element list
now this is a pattern we've seen a
couple times now and we know that
overall this runs in logarithmic time so
let's add that as a comment so here i'll
say
takes
overall
big o of log
n time now there's a caveat here but
we'll come back to that
so next up is the merge step in the
merge step we've broken the original
list down into single element lists and
now we need to make comparison
operations and merge them back in the
reverse order
for a list of size n we will always need
to make an n number of merge operations
to get back from single element lists to
a merge list
this makes our overall runtime big o of
n times log n because that's an n number
of merge steps multiplied by log n
number of splits of the original list
so to our merge step here let's add a
comment we'll say it runs
in overall
oops there we go runs an overall linear
time
right it takes an n number of steps
number of merge steps but now that we
have these two so linear here and
logarithmic here we can multiply these
and say that the merge sort function the
top level function we can conclude that
the runtime of the overall sorting
process is big o of n times log n
now what about that caveat i mentioned
earlier
so if we go back to our split function
here
right here there we go
let's take a look at the way we're
actually splitting the list so we're
using python's list slicing operation
here
and passing in two indexes where the
split occurs
now if you go and poke around the python
documentation which i've done it says
that a slicing operation is not a
constant time operation and in fact has
a runtime of big o of k where k
represents the slice size
this means that in reality our
implementation of split this
implementation of split does not run in
logarithmic time but k times logarithmic
time because there is a slice operation
for each split
this means that our implementation is
much more expensive so
overall
that makes our overall top level merge
sort function not n times log n but k n
times log n which is much more expensive
now let's get rid of all that
to fix this we would need to remove this
slicing operation now we can do that by
using a technique we learned in a
previous course
in the introduction to algorithms course
we looked at two versions of binary
search in python a recursive and an
iterative version
in the recursive one we use list slicing
with every recursion call but we achieve
the same end result using an iterative
approach without using list slicing
over there we declared two variables to
keep track of the starting and ending
positions in the list
we could rewrite merge sort to do the
same but i'll leave that as an exercise
for you if you want some hints if you
want any direction i've included a link
in the notes with an implementation so
that is time complexity now just so we
know before moving on for python here
our
overall run time is not what i've listed
here but this is what the actual run
time of the merge sort algorithm looks
like so the merge step runs in linear
time and the split step takes
logarithmic time for an overall n times
log n and that is how merge sort
actually works
okay so what about space complexity
the merge sort algorithm takes linear
space and this is weird to think about
it first but as always a visualization
helps
so if we start at the top again with our
full list and carry out the split method
until we have single element lists each
of these new lists take up a certain
amount of space
so the second level here we have two
lists where each take up an n by two
amount of space
now this makes it seem that the sum of
all this space is the additional space
needed for merge sort but that's not
actually the case in reality there are
two factors that make a difference
first not every single one of these sub
lists are created simultaneously
at step two we create two n by two size
sub lists
when we move to the next step however we
don't hold on to the n by two sub lists
and then create four n by four size sub
lists for the next split
instead after the four n by four size
sub lists are created the n by two ones
are deleted from memory there's no
reason to hold on to them any longer now
the second point is that our code
doesn't execute every path
simultaneously
think of it this way when we pass our
list to the top level merge sort
function
our implementation calls split
which returns a left half and a right
half
the next line of code then calls merge
sort on the left half again
this runs the function the merge sort
function again with a new list
in that second run of the function split
is called again we get a second left and
right half and then again like before we
call merge sort on this left half as
well what this means is that the code
walks down the left path all the way
down until that initial left half is
sorted and merged back into one array
then it's going to walk all the way down
the right path and sort that until we're
back to that first split with two n by
two sized sublists
essentially we don't run all these paths
of code at once so the algorithm doesn't
need additional space for every sub-list
in fact it is the very last step that
matters
in the last step the two sub-lists are
merged back into the new sorted list and
returned
that sorted list has an equal number of
items as the original unsorted list
and since this is a new list it means
that at most the additional space the
algorithm will require at a given time
is n
yes at different points in the algorithm
we require log n amount of space but log
n is smaller than n and so we consider
the space complexity of merge sort to be
linear because that is the overall
factor
okay that was a lot so let's stop here
don't worry if you've got questions
about merge sort because we're not done
yet
over the next few videos let's wrap up
this course by implementing merge sort
on a linked list
[Music]
over the last few videos we implemented
the merge sort algorithm on the array or
list type in python merge sort is
probably the most complicated algorithm
we've written so far but in doing so we
learned about an important concept
divide and conquer
we also concluded the last video by
figuring out the run time of merge sort
based on our implementation
over the next few videos we're going to
implement merge sort again this time on
the linked list type
in doing so we're going to get a chance
to see how the implementation differs
based on the data structure while still
keeping the fundamentals of the
algorithm the same and we'll also see
how the run time may be affected by the
kinds of operations we need to implement
let's create a new file to put our
second implementation of merge sort in
so file over here new file
and it's going to have a rather long
name we'll call this linked
list
merge sort with underscores everywhere
dot pi
we're going to need the linked list
class that we created earlier so we'll
start at the top by importing the linked
list class from the linkedlist.pi file
the way we do that is we'll say from
linked
list
import linked list
right so that imports the class
uh let's test if this works really quick
we'll just do something like l equal
linked
list
l.add
ten
or one doesn't matter print l
okay and if i hit save
and then down here we'll say python
linked list
merge sword dot pi
okay it works so this is how we get some
of the code how we reuse the code that
we've written in other files into this
current file
and get rid of this now
okay like we did with the first
implementation of merge sort we're going
to split the code up across three
functions
the main function merge sort
a split function and a merge function
now if you were to look up a merge sort
implementation in python both for a
regular list an array or a linked list
you would find much more concise
versions out there but they're kind of
hard to explain so splitting it up into
three will sort of help it you know be
easier to understand so we'll call this
merge sort at the top level and this
time it's going to take a linked list
let's add a dog string to document the
function
so say that this function sorts a linked
list in ascending order
and like before we'll add the steps in
here so we'll say you first recursively
divide the linked list into sub lists
containing
a single
node
then
we repeatedly
merge these sub-lists
to produce sorted sub-lists
until one remains
and then finally this function returns a
sorted
linked list
the implementation of this top level
merge function is nearly identical to
the array or list version we wrote
earlier so first we'll provide a
stopping condition or two if the size of
the list is one or it's an empty list
we'll return the linked list since it's
naively sorted so if linked
list dot size remember that function we
run equal one
then we'll return
linked
list
else if
linked list dot head
is none meaning it's an empty list then
we'll return linked list as well okay
next let's split the linked list into a
left and right half
conceptually this is no different but in
practice we need to actually traverse
the list we'll implement a helper method
to make this easier
but we'll say left half
comma right half
equal split
linked list
now once we have two sub lists like
before we can call merge sort the top
level function on each
so left equal merge sort
left half
and right equal merge sort
on the right half
finally we'll merge these two top-level
sub-lists and return it so merge left
and right
okay nothing new here but in the next
video let's implement the split logic
the next step in the merge sort
algorithm is the divide step or rather
an implementation of the split function
so down here
we'll call this split like before and
this is going to take a linked
list
documenting things is good and we've
been doing it so far so let's add a
docstring
divide the unsorted list at midpoint
into sub-lists
now of course when i say sub-lists here
i mean sub-linked lists but that's a
long word to say
now here's where things start to deviate
from the previous version
with the list type we could rely on the
fact that finding the midpoint using an
index and list slicing to split into two
lists would work even if an empty list
was passed in
since we have no automatic behavior like
that we need to account for this when
using a linked list so our first
condition is if the linked list is none
or if it's empty that is if head is
equal to none
so we'll say if linked list
equal none
or you can write is there it doesn't
matter or linked list dot head is none
well linked list can be none for example
if we call split on a linked list
containing a single node a split on such
a list would mean left would contain the
single node while right would be none
now in either case we're going to assign
the entire list to the left half and
assign none to the right so we'll say
left half
equal linked list
and then right half
equal none
you could also assign the single element
list or none to left and then create a
new empty linked list assigned to the
right half but that's unnecessary work
so now that we've done this we can
return
left half
and right half
so that's our first condition let's add
an else clause to account for non-empty
linked lists first we'll calculate the
size of the list now this is easy
because we've done the work already and
we can just call the size method that
we've defined we'll say size equal
linked underscore list dot size
using this size we can determine the
midpoint so mid equal size and here
we'll use that floor division operator
to divide it by two once we have the
midpoint we need to get the node at that
midpoint
now make sure you hit command s to save
here and we're going to navigate back to
linkedlist.hi
in here we're going to add a convenience
method at the very bottom right before
the wrapper function right here
and this convenience method is going to
return a node at a given index so i'll
call this node
at
index and it's going to take an index
value
this way instead of having to traverse
the list inside of our split function we
can simply call node at index and pass
it the midpoint index we calculated to
give us the node right there so we can
perform the split
okay so this method accepts as an
argument the index we want to get the
node for if this index is zero then
we'll return the head of the list so if
index double equals zero return
self.head
the rest of the implementation involves
traversing the linked list and counting
up to the index as we visit each node
the rest of the implementation involves
traversing the linked list and counting
up to the index as we visit each node so
i'll add an else clause here
and we'll start at the head so we'll say
current equal self.head
let's also declare a variable called
position
to indicate where we are in the list
we can use a while loop to walk down the
list our condition here is as long as
the position is less than the index
value
so i'll say while position
is less than index
inside the loop we'll assign the next
node to current and increment the value
of position by one
so current equal current dot next node
position
plus equal one
once the position value equals the index
value current refers to the node we're
looking for and
we can return it we'll say return
current
let's get rid of all this empty space
there we go now back in linked list
merge sort
dot pi
we can use this method to get at the
node after we've calculated the midpoint
to get the node at the midpoint of the
list
so we'll say mid node
equal
linked
list
dot node at index
and here i'm going to do something
slightly confusing i'm going to do mid
minus 1. remember we're subtracting 1
here
because we used size
to calculate the midpoint and like the
len function size will always return a
value greater than the maximum index
value
so think of a linked list with two nodes
size would return two
the midpoint though and the way we're
calculating the index we always start at
zero which means size is going to be one
greater than that so we're going to
deduct one from it to get the value we
want but we're using the floor division
operator so it's going to round that
down even more no big deal with the node
at the midpoint now that we have this
midnote we can actually split the list
so first we're going to assign the
entire linked list to a variable named
left half so left half
equal linked list
this seems counterintuitive but make
sense in a second
for the right half we're going to assign
a new instance of linked list so right
half equal
linked list
this newly created list is empty but we
can fix that by assigning the node that
comes after the midpoint so after the
midpoint of the original linked list we
can assign the node that comes after
that midpoint node as the head of this
newly created
right linked list
so here we'll say right half
dot head
equal mid node dot
node
once we do that we can assign none to
the next node property on mid node to
effectively sever that connection and
make what was the mid node now the tail
node of the left linked list so i'll say
mid node
dot next node
equal none
if that's confusing here's a quick
visualization of what just happened
we start off with a single linked list
and find the midpoint the node that
comes after the node at midpoint is
assigned to the head of a newly created
linked list and the connection between
the midpoint node and the one after is
removed
we now have two distinct linked lists
split at the midpoint
and with that we can return the two sub
lists so we'll return left half
and right half
in the next video let's tackle our merge
function in the last video we defined an
implementation for the version of the
split function that works on linked
lists it contained a tiny bit more code
than the array or list version that was
expected the merge function is no
different because like with the split
function after we carry out a comparison
operation we also need to swap
references to corresponding nodes all
right let's add our merge function over
here at the bottom below
the split functions we'll call this
merge and it's going to take a left
and right
now because this can get complicated
we're going to document this function
extensively and as always we're going to
start with a doc string
so we'll say that this function merges
two linked lists
sorting
by data in the nodes
and it returns a new
merged list
remember that in the merge step we're
going to compare values across two
linked lists and then return a new
linked list with nodes where the data is
sorted
so first we need to create that new
linked list let's add a comment in here
we'll say create
a new linked list
that contains nodes from
let's add a new line merging left and
right
okay and then create the list so merged
equal
new linked list
to this list we're going to do something
unusual we're going to add a fake head
this is so that when adding sorted nodes
we can reduce the amount of code we have
to write by not worrying about whether
we're at the head of the list once we're
done we can assign the first sorted node
as the head and discard the fake head
now this might not make sense at first
but not having to worry about whether
the new linked list already contains a
head or not makes the code simpler we'll
add another comment
and a fake hand that is discarded
later
we'll say merged dot add zero
like we've been doing so far we'll
declare a variable named current to
point to the head of the list
set current to the head of the linked
list and then current equal
merged dot head
next we'll get a reference to the head
on each of the linked lists left and
right
so we'll say obtain
head nodes
for left and right linked lists
and here's call this left head
equal
left dot head
and right hand equal right dot head
okay so with that setup out of the way
let's start iterating over both lists
so another comment
iterate over left and right
as long
or we'll say until
the
until we reach the tail node
of either
and we'll do that by saying while
left head
or right head
so this is a pattern that we've been
following all along we're going to
iterate until we hit the tail nodes of
both lists and we'll move this pointer
forward every time so that we traverse
the list with every iteration if you
remember the logic behind this from the
earlier version once we hit the tail
note of one list if there are nodes left
over in the other linked list we don't
need to carry out a comparison operation
anymore and we can simply add those
nodes to the merged list
the first scenario we'll consider is if
the head of the left linked list is none
this means we're already past the tail
of left and we can add all the nodes
from the right linked list to the final
merge list so here i'll say if
the head node of left is none
we're past the tail
add the node
from the right from right to merged
linked
list so here we'll say if
left head
is none
current dot next node
remember current points to the head of
the merge list that we're going to
return so here we're setting its next
node reference to the head node on the
right link list so we'll say right head
then when we do that we'll move the
right head forward to the next node so
let's say right
head
equal right hand
dot next node
this terminates the loop on the next
iteration let's look at a visualization
to understand why
let's say we start off with a linked
list containing four nodes so we keep
calling split on it until we have lists
with just a single head single node
linked lists essentially
so let's focus on these two down here
that we'll call left and right
we haven't implemented the logic for
this part yet but here we would compare
the data values and see which one is
less than the other
so we'll assume that left's head is
lesser than right's head so we'll set
this as the next node in the final merge
list
left is now an empty length list so left
dot head equals none on the next pass
through the loop left head is none which
is the situation we just implemented
here we can go ahead and now assign
right head as the next note in the merge
link list we know that right is also a
singly linked list
here's the crucial bit when we move the
pointer forward by calling next node on
the right node there is no node and the
right link the right linked list is also
empty now which means that both left
head and right head are none and either
one of these would cause our loop
condition to terminate
so what we've done here is encoded a
stopping condition for the loop so we
need to document this because it can get
fuzzy so right above that line of code
i'll say call next
on right
to
set loop condition
to false
okay there's another way we can arrive
at this stopping condition and that's in
the opposite direction if we start with
the right head being none so here we'll
say i'm going to add another comment
if oops not there there
if
the head node of right
is none
we're past the tail
then we'll say
add the tail node from left
to merged linked list
and then we'll add that condition we'll
say else if right head
is none
now remember we can enter these even if
left head is none we can still go into
this condition we can still enter this
if statement and execute this logic
because the while loop the loop
condition here is an or statement so
even if left head is false if this
returns true because there's a value
there there's a node there the loop will
keep going
okay now in this case we want to set the
head of the left linked list as the next
node on the merge list so this is simply
the opposite of what we did over here
we'll set current dot next node
equal to left head
and then we'll move so after doing that
we can move the variable pointing to
left head forwards which as we saw
earlier is past the tail node and then
results in the loop terminating so we'll
say left hand
equal
left
head dot next node and we'll add that
comment here as well so we'll say call
next on left to set loop condition
to false
because here right head is none and now
we make left head none these two
conditions we looked at where either the
left head or right head
were at the tail nodes of our respective
lists those are conditions that we run
into when we've reached the bottom of
our split where we have single element
linked lists or empty linked lists let's
account for our final condition where
we're evaluating a node that is neither
the head nor the tail of the list
and this condition we need to reach into
the nodes and actually compare the data
values to one another before we can
decide which node to add first to the
merged list
so here this is an else because we've
arrived at our third condition third and
final
and here we'll say not at either tail
node
obtain
no data to perform
comparison operations so let's get each
of those data values out of the
respective nodes so that we can compare
it so we'll say left
data equal left head dot data
and write data
equal right head righthead.data
okay what do we do next well we compare
but first let's add a comment so we'll
say if data
on left
is less than right
set current to left node and then
move
actually we'll add this in a second so
here we'll say if left data
is less than write data
then current dot next node
equal left head
and then
we'll add a comment and we'll say move
left head to next node
on that list so we'll say left head
equal left head
dot next node
just as our comment says we'll check if
the left data is less than the right
data if it is since we want a list in
ascending order we'll assign the left
node to be the next node in the merged
list we'll also move the left head
forward to traverse down to the next
node in that particular list now if left
is larger than right then we want to do
the opposite so we'll go back to spaces
another comment
if data on left is greater than right
set current
to
right node
okay so else
here we assign the right head to be the
next node in the merge list so
current.nextnode
equal right
head
and then comment
move right head to next node
so right
head equal
right head
dot next
node okay after doing that we move the
right head pointer to reference the next
node in the right list
and finally at the end of each iteration
of the while loop so not here but two
spaces back right make sure we're
indented at the same level as the while
so we got to go yep or not the same
level as the wild but the same outer
scope
and then there we're going to say
move current to next node
so current equal current dot next node
okay don't worry if this is confusing as
always we'll look at a visualization in
just a bit so we'll wrap up this
function by discarding that fake head we
set earlier setting the correct node as
head and returning the linked list so
we'll add a comment
discard fake head
and set
first
merged node as head so here we'll say
head equal
merged dot head dot next
node and then merged dot head equal head
and finally return
merged
okay we wrote a lot of code here a lot
of it was comments but still it's a
bunch let's take a quick break in the
next video we'll test this out evaluate
our results and determine the runtime of
our algorithm
okay first things first let's test out
our code now we'll keep it simple
because writing a robust verify function
would actually take up this entire video
instead i'll leave that up to you to try
as homework
okay so
at the very end
let's create a new linked list
let's add a few notes to this so l add
i'm going to copy paste this
so it makes it easier for me
not to have to retype a bunch so i'll
add 10
uh then set 2
44
15
and something like 200. okay then we'll
go ahead and print l so that we can
inspect this list
next
let's create a declare variable here so
we'll call this sorted linked list
and to this we're going to assign the
result of calling merge sort on l
and then we'll print this
so sorted
linked
list
okay since we've taken care of all the
logic we know that this gets added in as
nodes and then
let's see what this looks like all right
so hit save
and then bring up the console we're
going to type out python
linked
list underscore merge sort dot pi and
then enter okay so we see that linked
list we first created remember that what
we add first right that eventually
becomes a tail or right yeah so 10 is
the tail 200 is the last one so 200 is
the head because i'm calling add it
simply adds each one to the head of the
list so here we have 10 to 44 15 and 200
in the order we added and then the
sorted linked list sorts it out so it's
2 10 15 44 and 200. look at that a
sorted linked list
okay so let's visualize this from the
top
we have a linked list containing five
nodes with integers 10 2 4 15 and 200 as
data respectively our merge sort
function calls split on this list the
split function calls size on the list
and gets back 5 which makes our midpoint
2.
using this midpoint we can split the
list using the node at index method
remember that when doing this we deduct
1 from the value of mid so we're going
to split here using an index value of 1.
effectively this is the same since we're
starting with an index value of 0 1
means we split after node 2. we assign
the entire list to left half
then create a new list and assign that
to right half
we can assign node 3 at index value 2 as
the head of the right list and remove
the references between node two and node
three so far so good right
okay so now we're back in the merge sort
function after having called split and
we have two linked lists
let's focus on just the left half
because if you go back and look at our
code we're going to call merge sort on
the left linked list again
this means the next thing we'll do is
run through that split process since
this is a linked list containing two
nodes this means that split is going to
return a new left and right list each
with one node again we're back in the
merge sort function which means that we
call merge sort on this left list again
since this is a single node linked list
on calling merge sort on it we
immediately return before we split since
we hit that stopping condition so we go
to the next line of code which is
calling merge sort on the right list as
well but again we'll get back
immediately because we hit that stopping
condition now that we have a left and
right that we get back from calling
merge sort we can call merge on them
inside the merge function we start by
creating a new linked list and attaching
a fake head
then we evaluate whether either the left
or the right head is none
since neither condition is true we go to
the final step where we evaluate the
data in each node
in this case the data in the right node
is less than the left node so we assign
the right node as the next node in the
merge link list and move the right head
pointer forward
in the merge link list we move our
current pointer forward to this new node
we've added and that completes one
iteration of the loop
on the next iteration righthead now
points to none since that was a single
node list and we can assign the rest of
the left linked list which is
effectively the single node over to the
merge link list here we discard the fake
head move the next node up to be the
correct head and return the newly merged
sorted linked list remember that at this
point because right head and left head
pointed to none are while loop
terminated
so in this way we recursively split and
repeatedly merge sub-lists until we're
back with one sorted linked list
the merge sort algorithm is a powerful
sorting algorithm but ultimately it
doesn't really do anything complicated
it just breaks the problem down until
it's really simple to solve
remember the technique here which we've
talked about before is called divide and
conquer so i like to think of merge sort
in this way there's a teacher at the
front of the room and she has a bunch of
books that she needs to sort into
alphabetical order instead of doing all
that work herself she splits that pile
into two and hands it to two students at
the front
each of those students split it into two
more and hand it to the four students
seated behind them as each student does
this eventually a bunch of single
students has two books to compare and
they can sort it very easily and hand it
back to the student who gave it to them
in front of them who repeats the process
backwards so ultimately it's really
simple work is just efficiently
delegated
now back to our implementation here
let's talk about runtime so far other
than the node swapping we had to do it
seems like most of our implementation is
the same right in fact it is including
the problems that we ran into in the
list version as well so in the first
implementation of merge sort we thought
we had an algorithm that ran in big o of
n log n but turns out we didn't why well
the python list slicing operation if you
remember actually takes up some amount
of time amounting to big o of k
a true implementation of merge sort runs
in quasi-linear or log linear time that
is n times log n so we almost got there
but we didn't now in our implementation
of merge sort on a linked list we
introduce the same problem so if we go
back up to
the merge or rather the split function
this is where it happens now swapping
node references that's a constant time
operation no big deal comparing values
also constant time
the bottleneck here like list slicing is
in splitting a late list at the midpoint
if we go back to our implementation you
can see here that we use the node at
index method which finds the node we
want by traversing the list
this means that every split operation
incurs a big o of k cost where k here is
the midpoint of the list effectively n
by 2 because we have to walk down the
list counting up the index until we get
to that node
given that overall splits take
logarithmic time our split function just
like the one we wrote earlier
incurs a cost of
big o of
k log n so here we'll say it takes
big o of k times log n
now the merge function also like the one
we wrote earlier takes linear time so
that one is good that one runs in the
expected amount of time so here we'll
say runs in linear
time
and that would bring our overall run
time so up at the merge sort function we
can say this runs in
big o of k n times log
n
it's okay though this is a good start
and one day when we talk about constant
factors and look at ways we can reduce
the cost of these operations using
different strategies we can come back
and re-evaluate our code to improve our
implementation for now as long as you
understand how merge sort works
conceptually what the run time and space
complexities look like and where the
bottlenecks are in your code that's
plenty of stuff
if you're interested in learning more
about how we would solve this problem
check out the notes in the teachers
video in the next video let's wrap this
course up
and with that let's wrap up this course
in the prerequisite to this course
introduction to algorithms we learned
about basic algorithms along with some
concepts like recursion and big o that
set the foundation for learning about
implementing and evaluating algorithms
in this course we learned what a data
structure is and how data structures go
hand in hand with algorithms
we started off by exploring a data
structure that many of us use in our
day-to-day programming arrays or lists
as they are known in python
we take a peek under the hood at how
arrays are created and stored and
examine some of the common operations
carried out on arrays
these are operations that we write and
execute all the time but here we took a
step back and evaluated the run times of
these operations and how they affect the
performance of our code
after that we jumped into an entirely
new world where we wrote our own data
structure a singly linked list
admittedly linked lists aren't used much
in day-to-day problem solving but it is
a good data structure to start off with
because it is fairly straightforward to
understand and not that much different
from an array
we carried out the same exercise as we
did on arrays in that we looked at
common data operations but since this
was a type we defined on our own we
implemented these operations ourselves
and got to examine with a fine-tooth
comb how our code and the structure of
the type affected the runtime of these
operations
the next topic we tackled was
essentially worlds colliding we
implemented a sorting algorithm to sort
two different data structures
here we got to see how all of the
concepts we've learned so far
algorithmic thinking time and space
complexity and data structures all come
together to tackle the problem of
sorting data
this kind of exercise is one we're going
to focus on moving forward as we try to
solve more real-world programming
problems using different data structures
and algorithms
if you've stuck with this content so far
keep up the great work this can be a
complex topic but a really interesting
one and if you take your time with it
you will get a deeper understanding of
programming and problem solving as
always check the notes for more
resources and happy coding
[Music]
you may have heard that algorithms and
computer science are boring or
frustrating they certainly can be hard
to figure out especially the way some
textbooks explain them but once you
understand what's going on algorithms
can seem fascinating clever or even
magical
to help further your understanding of
algorithms this course is going to look
at two categories sorting algorithms and
searching algorithms you could argue
that these are the easiest kinds of
algorithms to learn but in learning how
these algorithms are designed we'll
cover useful concepts like recursion and
divide and conquer that are used in many
other sorts of algorithms and can even
be used to create brand new ones
by the way all the code samples i'm
going to show in the videos will be in
python because it's a popular language
that's relatively easy to read but you
don't need to know python to benefit
from this course you can see the
teacher's notes for each video for info
on implementing these algorithms in your
own favorite language
our goal with this course is to give you
an overview of how sorting and searching
algorithms work but many algorithms have
details that can be handled in different
ways some of these details may distract
from the big picture so we've put them
in the teachers notes instead you don't
need to worry about these when
completing the course for the first time
but if you're going back and referring
to it later be sure to check the
teacher's notes for additional info
suppose we have a list of names it's a
pretty big list a hundred thousand names
long this list could be part of an
address book or social media app
and we need to find the locations of
individual names within the list
possibly to look up additional data
that's connected to the name
let's assume there's no existing
function in our programming language to
do this or that the existing function
doesn't suit our purpose in some way
for an unsorted list our only option may
be to use linear search also known as
sequential search
linear search is covered in more detail
elsewhere on our site check the
teacher's notes for a link if you want
more details
you start at the first element you
compare it to the value you're searching
for if it's a match you return it if not
you go to the next element
you compare that to your target if it's
a match you return it if not you go to
the next element and so on through the
whole list
the problem with this is that you have
to search the entire list every single
time we're not doing anything to narrow
down the search each time we have to
search all of it
if you're searching a big list or
searching it repeatedly this amount of
time can slow your whole lap down to the
point that people may not want to use it
anymore that's why it's much more common
to use a different algorithm for
searching lists binary search
binary search is also covered in more
detail elsewhere on our site check the
teacher's notes for a link
binary search does narrow the search
down for us specifically it lets us get
rid of half the remaining items we need
to search through each time
it does this by requiring that the list
of values be sorted
it looks at the value in the middle of
the list
if the value it finds is greater than
the target value it ignores all values
after the value it's looking at
if the value it finds is less than the
target value it ignores all values
before the value it's looking at
then it takes the set of values that
remain and looks at the value in the
middle of that list again if the value
it finds is greater than the target
value it ignores all values after the
value it's looking at if the value it
finds is less than the target value it
ignores all values before the value it's
looking at
but as we mentioned binary search
requires the list of values you're
searching through to be sorted
if the lists weren't sorted you would
have no idea which half of the values to
ignore because either half could contain
the value you're looking for you'd have
no choice but to use linear search
so before we can use binary search on a
list we need to be able to sort that
list we'll look at how to do that next
our end goal is to sort a list of names
but comparing numbers is a little easier
than comparing strings so we're going to
start by sorting a list of numbers
i'll show you how to modify our examples
to sort strings at the end of the course
to help make clear the importance of
choosing a good sorting algorithm we're
going to start with a bad one it's
called bogosort basically bogosort just
randomizes the order of the list
repeatedly until it's sorted
here's a python code file where we're
going to implement bogosort
it's not important to understand this
code here at the top although we'll have
info on it in the teachers notes if you
really want it all you need to know is
that it takes the name of a file that we
pass on the command line loads it and
returns a python list which is just like
an array in other languages containing
all the numbers that it read from the
file
let me have the program print out the
list of numbers it loads so you can see
it we'll call the print method and we'll
pass it the list of numbers
save that let's run it real quick
with python bogosort.pi
oh whoops and we need to
provide it
the name of the file here on the command
line that we're going to load so it's in
the numbers directory a slash separates
the directory name from the file name
five dot text
and there's our list of numbers that was
loaded from the file
okay let me delete that print statement
and then we'll move on
bogo sort just randomly rearranges the
list of values over and over so the
first thing we're going to need is a
function to detect when the list is
sorted
we'll write an is sorted function that
takes a list of values as a parameter
it'll return true if the list passed in
is sorted or false if it isn't
we'll loop through the numeric index of
each value in the list from 0 to 1 less
than the length of the list like many
languages python list indexes begin at 0
so a list with a length of 5 has indexes
going from 0 through 4.
if the list is sorted then every value
in it will be less than the one that
comes after it so we test to see whether
the current item is greater than the one
that follows it
if it is it means the whole list is not
sorted so we can return false
if we get down here it means the loop
completed without finding any unsorted
values python uses white space to mark
code blocks so unindenting the code like
this marks the end of the loop
since all the values are sorted we can
return true
now we need to write the function that
will actually do the so-called sorting
the bogosort function will also take the
list of values it's working with as a
parameter
we'll call our is sorted function to
test whether the list is sorted we'll
keep looping until is sorted returns
true
python has a ready-made function that
randomizes the order of elements in the
list
since the list isn't sorted we'll call
that function here
and since this is inside the loop it'll
be randomized over and over until our is
sorted function returns true
if the loop exits it means is sorted
returned true and the list is sorted so
we can now return the sorted list
finally we need to call our bogosort
function pass it the list we loaded from
the file and print the sorted list it
returns
okay let's save this and try running it
we do so with python the name of the
script bogosort.pi
and the name of the file we're going to
run it on
numbers directory5.txt
it looks like it's sorting our list
successfully
but how efficient is this let's add some
code to track the number of times it
attempts to sort the list
up here at the top of the bogus sort
function we'll add a variable to track
the number of attempts it's made we'll
name it attempts and we'll set its
initial value to zero since we haven't
made any attempts yet
with each pass through the loop we'll
print the current number of attempts
and then here at the end of the loop
after attempting to shuffle the values
we'll add one to the count of attempts
let's save this and let's try running it
again a couple times
in the console i can just press the up
arrow to bring up the previous command
and re-run it
so it looks like this first run to sort
this five element list took 363 attempts
let's try it again
this time it only took 91 attempts
we're simply randomizing the list with
each attempt so each
run of the program takes a random number
of attempts
now let's try this same program with a
larger number of items
python bogo sort
numbers
i have a list of eight items set up here
in this other file
this time it takes 11 000 attempts
only 487 this time
and this time thirteen thousand you can
see that the trend is increasing
steadily
the problem with bogosort is that it
doesn't make any progress toward a
solution with each pass
it could generate a list where just one
value is out of order but then on the
next attempt it could generate a list
where all the elements are out of order
again
stumbling on a solution is literally a
matter of luck and for lists with more
than a few items it might never happen
up next we'll look at selection sort
it's a sorting algorithm that's still
slow but it's better than bogo's sort
previously we showed you bogo sort a
terrible sorting algorithm that
basically randomizes the order of a list
and then checks to see if it happens to
be sorted
the problem with bogo's sort is that it
doesn't get any closer to a solution
with each operation and so with lists
that have more than a few items it'll
probably never finish sorting them
now we're going to look at an algorithm
named selection sort it's still slow but
at least each pass through the list
brings it a little closer to completion
our implementation of selection sort is
going to use two arrays an unsorted
array and a sorted one some versions
move values around within just one array
but we're using two arrays to keep the
code simpler the sorted list starts out
empty but we'll be moving values from
the unsorted list to the sorted list one
at a time
with each pass we'll look through each
of the values in the unsorted array find
the smallest one and move that to the
end of the sorted array
we'll start with the first value in the
unsorted array and say that's the
minimum or smallest value we've seen so
far
then we'll look at the next value and
see if that's smaller than the current
minimum if it is we'll mark that as the
new minimum
then we'll move to the next value and
compare that to the minimum again if
it's smaller that becomes the new
minimum we continue that way until we
reach the end of the list
at that point we know whatever value we
have marked as the minimum is the
smallest value in the whole list
now here's the part that makes selection
sort better than bogo sort we then move
that minimum value from the unsorted
list to the end of the sorted list
the minimum value isn't part of the
unsorted list anymore so we don't have
to waste time looking at it anymore all
our remaining comparisons will be on the
remaining values in the unsorted list
then we start the process over at this
point our list consists of the numbers 8
5 4 and 7. our first minimum is 8.
we start by comparing the minimum to
five five is smaller than eight so five
becomes the new minimum then we compare
five to four and four becomes the new
minimum four is not smaller than seven
though so four remains the minimum four
gets moved to the end of the sorted
array becoming its second element
the process repeats again eight is the
first minimum but five is smaller so
that becomes the minimum seven is larger
so five stays is the minimum and five is
what gets moved over to the sort of
array and so on until there are no more
items left in the unsorted array and all
we have left is the sorted array
so that's how selection sort works in
general now let's do an actual
implementation of it
this code here at the top is the same as
we saw in the bogo sword example it just
loads a python list of numbers from a
file
let's implement the function that will
do our selection sort we're going to
pass in our python list containing all
the unsorted numbers we'll create an
empty list that will hold all our sorted
values
we'll loop once for each value in the
list
we call a function named index submin
which we're going to write in just a
minute that finds the minimum value in
the unsorted list and returns its index
then we call the pop method on the list
and pass it the index of the minimum
value pop will remove that item from the
list and return it we then add that
value to the end of the sorted list
going up a level of indentation signals
to python that we're ending the loop
after the loop finishes we return the
sorted list
now we need to write the function that
picks out the minimum value we pass in
the list we're going to search
we mark the first value in the list as
the minimum it may or may not be the
actual minimum but it's the smallest
we've seen on this pass through the list
it's also the only value we've seen on
this pass through the list so far
now we loop through the remaining values
in the list after the first
we test whether the value we're
currently looking at is less than the
previously recorded
minimum if it is then we set the current
index as the new index of the minimum
value
after we've looped through all the
values we return the index of the
smallest value we found
lastly we need to actually run our
selection sort method and print the
sorted list it returns
let's save this and now let's try
running it we run the python command and
pass it the name of our script
selectionsort.pi
in the numbers directory i've saved
several data files filled with random
numbers one on each line five dot text
has five lines eight dot text has eight
lines and to help us really measure the
speed of our algorithms ten thousand dot
text has ten thousand lines i've even
created a file with a million numbers
our script takes the path of a file to
load as an argument so i'll give it the
path of our file with five numbers
numbers slash five dot text
the script runs reads the numbers in the
file into a list calls our selection
sort method with that list and then
prints the sorted list
let me add a couple print statements
within the selection sort function so
you can watch the sort happening
don't worry about figuring out the
python formatting string that i use it's
just there to keep the two lists neatly
aligned
i'll add the first print statement
before the loop runs at all
i'll have it print out the unsorted list
and the sorted list
i'll add an identical print statement
within the loop so we can watch values
moving from the unsorted list to the
sorted list
let's save this
and we'll try running the same command
again the output looks like this you can
see the unsorted list on the left and
the sorted list on the right
initially the sorted list is empty on
the first pass it selects the lowest
number 1 and moves it to the sorted list
then it moves the next lowest number
over four
this repeats until all the numbers have
been moved to the sorted list
i have another file with eight different
numbers in it let's try our program with
that
python selection sort dot pi numbers
8.text
you can see the same process at work
here notice that this file had some
duplicate values too that's okay though
because the index of min function only
updates the minimum index if the current
value is less than the previous minimum
if they're equal it just keeps the first
minimum value it found and waits to move
the duplicate value over until the next
pass through the list
so now we know that the selection sort
algorithm works but the data sets we've
been giving it sort are tiny in the real
world algorithms need to work with data
sets of tens of thousands or even
millions of items and do it fast i have
another file with ten thousand random
numbers in it
let's see if selection sort can handle
that
if i run this as it is now though it'll
print out a lot of debug info as it
sorts the list so first i'm going to go
into the program and remove the two
print statements in the selection sort
function
now let's run the program again on the
dot text file and see how long it takes
python selection sort dot pi
numbers
ten thousand dot text
one one thousand two one thousand three
one four one thousand five one thousand
six one thousand seven one thousand
eight one thousand nine one thousand ten
one thousand eleven thousand twelve
thousand thirteen thousand and it prints
out all ten thousand of those numbers
neatly sorted it took a little bit
though how long well counting the time
off vocally isn't very precise and other
programs running on the system can skew
the amount of time your program takes to
complete
let me show you a unix command that's
available here in workspaces which can
help you type time followed by a space
and then the command you want to run
so this command by itself will print the
contents of our 5.txt file cat as in
concatenate numbers 5.text
and this command will do the same thing
but it'll also keep track of how long it
takes the cat program to complete and
report the result time
cat
numbers five dot text
the real row in the results is the
actual amount of time for when the
program started running to when it
completed we can see it finished in a
fraction of a second but as we said
other programs running on the system can
take cpu resources in which case your
program will seem slower than it is so
we generally want to ignore the real
result
the user result is the amount of time
the cpu actually spent running the
program code so this is the total amount
of time the code inside the cat program
took to run
the sys result is the amount of time the
cpu spent running linux kernel calls
that your code made the linux kernel is
responsible for things like network
communications and reading files so
loading the 5.txt file is probably
included in this result
in evaluating code's performance we're
generally going to want to add together
the user and sys results but cad is a
very simple program let's try running
the time command on our code and see if
we get a more interesting result
time python
selection sort dot pi
numbers
ten thousand dot text
this takes much longer to complete
nearly 12 seconds according to the real
time measurement but as we said the real
result is often skewed so let's
disregard that
if we add the user and cis runtimes
together we get about 6 seconds
the time for the program to complete
will vary a little bit each time you run
it but if it's doing the same operations
it usually won't change more than a
fraction of a second if i run our
selection sort script on the same file
you can see it completes in roughly the
same time
now let's try it on another file with 1
million numbers time python selection
sort dot pi numbers
1 million dot text
how long does this one take i don't even
know while designing this course i tried
running this command and my workspace
connection timed out before it completed
so we'll just say that selection sort
takes a very very long time to sort a
million numbers
if we're going to sort a list that big
we're going to need a faster algorithm
we'll look into alternative sorting
algorithms shortly
the next two sorting algorithms we look
at will rely on recursion which is the
ability of a function to call itself so
before we move on we need to show you
how recursion works
recursive functions can be very tricky
to understand imagine a row of dominoes
stood on end where one domino falling
over causes the next domino to fall over
which causes the next domino to fall
over causing a chain reaction it's kind
of like that
let's suppose we need to write a
function that adds together all the
numbers in an array or in the case of
python a list
normally we'd probably use a loop for
this sort of operation
the function takes a list of the numbers
we want to add
the total starts at zero
we loop over every number contained in
the list and we add the current number
to the total
once we're done looping we return the
accumulated total
if we call this sum function with a list
of numbers it'll return the total when
we run this program it'll print out that
return value 19. let's try it real quick
python
recursion.pi oh whoops
mustn't forget to save my work here
and run it and we see the result 19.
to demonstrate how recursion works let's
revise the sum function to use recursion
instead note that recursion is not the
most efficient way to add a list of
numbers together but this is a good
problem to use to demonstrate recursion
because it's so simple one thing before
i show you the recursive version though
this example is going to use the python
slice syntax so i need to take a moment
to explain that for those not familiar
with it
a slice is a way to get a series of
values from a list
let's load up the python repel or read
evaluate print loop so i can demonstrate
we'll start by creating a list of
numbers to work with numbers equals
a list
with 0 1 2 3 and 4
containing those numbers
like arrays in most other languages
python list indexes start at 0 so
numbers
1
will actually get the second item from
the list
with slice notation i can actually get
several items back
it looks just like accessing an
individual index of a list
but then i type a colon
followed by the list index that i want
up to but not including
so numbers 1 colon 4 would get us the
second up to but not including the fifth
items from the list that is it'll get us
the second through the fourth items
now i know what you're thinking and
you're right that up to but not
including rule is a little
counterintuitive but you can just forget
all about it for now because we won't be
using a second index with any of our
python slice operations in this course
here's what we will be using when you
leave the second index off of a python
slice it gives you the items from the
first index up through the end of the
list wherever that is so numbers 1 colon
with no index following it will give us
items from the second index up through
the end of the list
numbers 2 colon will give us items from
the third index up to the end of the
list
you can also leave the first index off
to get everything from the beginning of
the list numbers
colon 3 will get us everything from the
beginning of the list up to but not
including the third index
it's also worth noting that if you take
a list with only one item and you try to
get everything from the non-existent
second item onwards the result will be
an empty list
so if i create a list with just one item
in it
and i try
to access from the second element
onwards the second element doesn't exist
so the result will be an empty list
don't worry too much about remembering
python slice syntax it's not an
essential part of sorting algorithms or
recursion i'm only explaining it to help
you read the code you're about to see
so i'm going to exit the python rebel
now that we've covered recursion we can
convert our sum function to a recursive
function
it'll take the list of numbers to add
just like before
now here's the recursive part we'll have
the sum function call itself we use
slice notation to pass the entire list
of numbers except the first one
then we add the first number in the list
to the result of the recursive function
call and return the result
so if we call sum with four numbers
first it'll call itself with the
remaining three numbers that call to sum
will then call itself with the remaining
two numbers and so on
but if we save this and try to run it
pythonrecursion.pi
well first we get a syntax error it
looks like i accidentally indented
something i shouldn't have so let me go
fix that real quick
there we go that's suggested to python
that there was a loop or something there
when there wasn't
so let's go back to the terminal and try
running this again
there we go now we're getting the error
i was expecting recursion error maximum
recursion depth exceeded
this happens because some gets into an
infinite loop it keeps calling itself
over and over the reason is that when we
get down to a list of just one element
and we take a slice from the
non-existent second element to the end
the result is an empty list that empty
list gets passed to the recursive call
to sum which passes an empty list in its
recursive call to sum and so on until
the python interpreter detects too many
recursive calls and shuts the program
down what we need is to add a base case
to this recursive function a condition
where the recursion stops this will keep
it from getting into an infinite loop
with the sum function the base case is
when there are no elements left in the
list in that case there is nothing left
to add and the recursion can stop
a base case is the alternative to a
recursive case a condition where
recursion should occur for the sum
function the recursive case is when
there are still elements in the list to
add together
let's add a base case at the top of the
function
python treats a list that contains one
or more values as a true value and it
treats a list containing no values as a
false value
so we'll add an if statement that says
if there are no numbers in the list we
should return a sum of zero that way the
function will exit immediately without
making any further recursive calls to
itself
we'll leave the code for the recursive
case unchanged
if there are still numbers in the list
the function will call itself with any
numbers after the first then add the
return value to the first number in the
list
let's save this and try running it again
python recursion dot pi
output the sum of the numbers in the
list 19 but it's still not really clear
how this worked let's add a couple print
statements that will show us what it's
doing
we'll show the recursive call to sum and
what it's being called with
we'll also add a call to print right
before we return showing which of the
calls the sum is returning and what it's
returning
let me save this and resize the console
a bit
and let's try running it again
python recursion.pi
since the print calls are inside the sum
function the first call to sum 1279
isn't shown only the recursive calls are
this first call to sum ignores the first
item in the list 1 and calls itself
recursively it passes the remaining
items from the list 2 7 and 9.
that call to sum again ignores the first
item in the list it receives 2 and again
calls itself recursively it passes the
remaining items in the list 7 and 9.
that call ignores the 7 and calls itself
with a 9
and the last call shown here ignores the
9
and calls itself with an empty list
at this point none of our recursive
calls to sum have returned yet each of
them is waiting on the recursive call it
made to sum to complete
python and other programming languages
use something called a call stack to
keep track of this series of function
calls each function call is added to the
stack along with the place in the code
that it needs to return when it
completes
but now the empty list triggers the base
case causing the recursion to end and
the sum function to return zero
that zero value is returned to its
caller the caller adds the zero to the
first and only value in its list nine
the result is nine
that nine value gets returned to the
caller which adds it to the first value
in the list it received seven
the result is sixteen
that sixteen value is returned to the
caller which adds it to the first value
in the list it received two the result
is 18.
that 18 value is returned to the caller
which adds it to the first value in the
list it received one the result is 19.
that 19 value is returned to the caller
which is not the sum function
recursively calling itself but our main
program this is our final result which
gets printed
it's the same result we got from the
loop-based version of our program the
end
we don't want the print statements in
our final version of the program so let
me just delete those real quick
and there you have it a very simple
recursive function well the function is
simple but as you can see the flow of
control is very complex don't worry if
you didn't understand every detail here
because we won't be using this
particular example again
there are two fundamental mechanisms you
need to remember a recursive function
needs a recursive case that causes it to
call itself
and it also needs to eventually reach a
base case that causes the recursion to
stop
you've seen bogo sort which doesn't make
any progress towards sorting a list with
each pass either it's entirely sorted or
it isn't
you've seen selection sort which moves
one value over to a sorted list with
each pass so that it has fewer items to
compare each time
now let's look at an algorithm that
speeds up the process further by further
reducing the number of comparisons it
makes it's called quick sort
here's some python code where we'll
implement quick sort again you can
ignore these lines at the top we're just
using them to load a file full of
numbers into a list
the quick sort algorithm relies on
recursion to implement it we'll write a
recursive function we'll accept the list
of numbers to sort as a parameter
quicksort is recursive because it keeps
calling itself with smaller and smaller
subsets of the list you're trying to
sort we're going to need a base case
where the recursion stops so it doesn't
enter an infinite loop
lists that are empty don't need to be
sorted and lists with just one element
don't need to be sorted either in both
cases there's nothing to flip around so
we'll make that our base case if there
are zero or one elements in the list
passed to the quick sort function we'll
return the unaltered list to the caller
lastly we need to call our quick sort
function with our list of numbers and
print the list it returns
that takes care of our base case now we
need a recursive case
we're going to rely on a technique
that's common in algorithm design called
divide and conquer basically we're going
to take our problem and split it into
smaller and smaller problems until
they're easy to solve
in this case that means taking our list
and splitting it into smaller lists
viewers a suggestion the process i'm
about to describe is complex there's
just no way around it if you're having
trouble following along remember the
video playback controls feel free to
slow the play back down rewind or pause
the video as needed after you watch this
the first time you may also find it
helpful to rewind and make your own
diagram of the process as we go
okay ready here goes
suppose we load the numbers from our
8.txt file into a list how do we divide
it
it would probably be smart to have our
quicksort function divide the list in a
way that brings it closer to being
sorted let's pick an item from the list
we'll just pick the first item for now
four
we'll call this value we've picked the
pivot like the center of a seesaw on a
playground
we'll break the list into two sublists
the first sub-list will contain all the
items in the original list that are
smaller than the pivot the second
sub-list will contain all the items in
the original list that are greater than
the pivot
the sub list of values less than and
greater than the pivot aren't sorted
but what if they were you could just
join the sub lists and the pivot all
together into one list and the whole
thing would be sorted
so how do we sort the sublist we call
our quick sort function recursively on
them this may seem like magic but it's
not it's the divide and conquer
algorithm design technique at work
if our quick sort function works on the
big list then it will work on the
smaller list too
for our first sub list we take the first
item it's the pivot again
that's three
we break the sub list into two sub lists
one with everything less than the pivot
and one with everything greater than the
pivot
notice that there's a value equal to the
pivot that gets put into the less than
sub-list our finished quicksort function
is actually going to put everything
that's less than or equal to the pivot
in the first sub-list
but i don't want to say less than or
equal to over and over so i'm just
referring to it as the less than pivot
sub-list
also notice that there are no values
greater than the pivot that's okay when
we join the sub-lists back together that
just means nothing will be in the return
list after the pivot
we still have one sub list that's more
than one element long so we call our
quick sort function on that too you and
i can see that it's already sorted but
the computer doesn't know that so it'll
call it anyway just in case
it picks the first element 2 as a pivot
there are no elements less than the
pivot and only one element greater than
the pivot
that's it for the recursive case we've
finally hit the base case for our quick
sort function it'll be called on both
the empty list of elements less than the
pivot and the one item list of elements
greater than the pivot but both of these
lists will be returned as they are
because there's nothing to sort
so now at the level of the call stack
above this the return sorted lists are
used in place of the unsorted sub-list
that's less than the pivot and the
unsorted sub-list that's greater than
the pivot
these are joined together into one
sorted list remember that any empty
lists get discarded
then at the level of the call stack
above that the return sorted lists are
used in place of the unsorted sub-lists
there again they were already sorted but
the quick sort method was called on them
anyway just in case
the sub-lists are joined together into
one sorted list at the level of the call
stack above that the return sorted list
is used in place of the unsorted
sub-list that's less than the pivot so
now everything that's less than or equal
to the pivot is sorted
now we call quick sort on the unsorted
sub-list that's greater than the pivot
and the process repeats for that
sub-list
we pick the first element six is the
pivot we split the sub-list into
sub-lists of elements that are less than
and greater than this pivot and we
recursively call the quicksort function
until those sub-lists are sorted
eventually a sorted sub-list is returned
to our first quick sort function call
we combine the sub-list that's less than
or equal to the pivot the pivot itself
and the sub-list that's greater than the
pivot into a single list and because we
recursively sorted the sub lists the
whole list is sorted
so that's how the quick sort function is
going to work in the next video we'll
show you the actual code
quicksort works by picking a pivot value
then splitting the full list into two
sub-lists the first sub-list has all the
values less than or equal to the pivot
and the second sub-list has all the
values greater than the pivot the quick
sort function recursively calls itself
to sort these sub-lists and then to sort
the sub-lists of those sub-lists until
the full list is sorted
now it's time to actually implement this
in code
we already have the base case written
any list passed in that consists of 0 or
1 values will be returned as is because
there's nothing to sort
now we need to create a list that will
hold all the values less than the pivot
that list will be empty at first we do
the same for values greater than the
pivot
next we need to choose the pivot value
for now we just grab the first item from
the list
then we loop through all the items in
the list following the pivot
we check to see whether the current
value is less than or equal to the pivot
if it is we copy it to the sub-list of
values less than the pivot
otherwise the current value must be
greater than the pivot
so we copy it to the other list
this last line is where the recursive
magic happens we call quick sort
recursively on the sub-list that's less
than the pivot we do the same for the
sub-list that's greater than the pivot
those two calls will return sorted lists
so we combine the sort of values less
than the pivot the pivot itself and the
sort of values greater than the pivot
that gives us a complete sorted list
which we return
this took a lot of prep work are you
ready let's try running it python
quick sort
dot pi
numbers 8.text
it outputs our sorted list
i don't know about you but this whole
thing still seems a little too magical
to me let's add a couple print
statements to the program so we can see
what it's doing
first we'll add a print statement right
before the first call to the quick sort
function so we can see the unsorted list
we'll also add a print right within the
quick sort function right before the
recursive calls again this string
formatting code is just to keep the info
aligned in columns
let's try running this again
and now you can see our new debug output
each time quicksort goes to call itself
recursively it prints out the pivot as
well as the sub list of items less than
or equal to the pivot if any and the sub
list of items greater than the pivot if
any you can see that first it sorts the
sub list of items less than the pivot at
the top level
it goes through a couple levels of
recursion to do that
there are actually additional levels of
recursion but they're from calls to
quick sort with a list of 0 or 1
elements and those calls return before
the print statement is reached
then it starts sorting the second sub
list from the top level with items
greater than the original pivot
you can see a couple levels of recursion
for that sort as well
finally when both sublists are
recursively sorted the original call to
the quicksort function returns and we
get the sorted list back
so we know that it works the next
question is how well does it work let's
go back to our file of ten thousand
numbers and see if it can sort those
first though i'm going to remove our two
debug calls to print so it doesn't
produce unreadable output
a quick note if you try running this on
a file with a lot of repeated values
it's possible you'll get a runtime error
maximum recursion depth exceeded
if you do see the teacher's notes for a
possible solution
now let's try running our quick sort
program against the ten thousand dot
text file python
quick sort dot pi
numbers 10 000 dot text
there we go and it seems pretty fast but
how fast exactly let's run it with the
time command to see how long it takes
time python
quick sort dot pi
numbers 10 000.text
remember we need to ignore the real
result and add the user and sys results
it took less than a second of cpu time
to sort 10 000 numbers with quicksort
remember that selection sort took about
13 seconds
that's a pretty substantial improvement
and with a million numbers selection
sort took so long that it never even
finished successfully let's see if
quicksort performs any better
time python quick sort dot pi
numbers
1 million dot text
not only did quicksort sort a million
numbers successfully it only took about
11 seconds of cpu time
quicksort is clearly much much faster
than selection sort how much faster
that's something we'll discuss in a
later video
what we've shown you here is just one
way to implement quicksort
although the basic algorithm is always
the same the details can vary like how
you pick the pivot see the teacher's
notes for more details
let's review another sorting algorithm
merge sort so that we can compare it
with quick sort merge sort is already
covered elsewhere on the site so we
won't go into as much detail about it
but we'll have more info in the
teacher's notes if you want it
both quicksort and merge sword are
recursive the difference between them is
in the sorting mechanism itself whereas
quicksort sorts a list into two
sub-lists that are less than or greater
than a pivot value
merge sort simply splits the list in
half recursively and then sorts the
halves as it merges them back together
that's why it's called merge sort
you may recognize this code at the top
by now it just loads a file full of
numbers into a list
let's define a recursive merge sort
function as usual it'll take the list or
sub-list that we want it to sort
our base case is the same as with
quicksort if the list has zero or one
values there's nothing to sort so we
return it as is
if we didn't return it means we're in
the recursive case so first we need to
split the list in half we need to know
the index we should split on so we get
the length of the list and divide it by
two so for example if there are eight
items in the list we'll want an index of
four
but what if there were an odd number of
items in the list like seven we can't
have an index of 3.5 so we'll need to
round down in that case since we're
working in python currently we can take
advantage of a special python operator
that divides and rounds the result down
the floor division operator it consists
of a double slash
now we'll use the python slice syntax to
get the left half of the list
we'll pass that list to a recursive call
to the merge sort function
we'll also use slice syntax to get the
right half of the list and pass that to
merge sort as well
now we need to merge the two halves
together and sort them as we do it we'll
create a list to hold the sorted values
and now we get to the complicated part
merging the two halves together and
sorted them as we do it
we'll be moving from left to right
through the left half of the list
copying values over to the sorted values
list as we go this left index variable
will help us keep track of our position
at the same time we'll also be moving
from left to right through the right
half of the list and copying values over
so we need a separate write index
variable to track that position as well
we'll keep looping until we've processed
all of the values in both halves of the
list
we're looking to copy over the lowest
values first so first we test whether
the current value on the left side is
less than the value on the right side
if the left side value is less that's
what we'll copy over to the sorted list
and then we'll move to the next value in
the left half of the list
otherwise the current value from the
right half must have been lower
so we'll copy that value to the sorted
list instead
and then we'll move to the next value in
the right half of the list
that ends the loop at this point one of
the two unsorted halves still has a
value remaining and the other is empty
we won't waste time checking which is
which we'll just copy the remainder of
both lists over to the sorted list the
one with the value left will add that
value and the empty one will add nothing
all the numbers from both halves should
now be copied to the sorted list so we
can return it
finally we need to kick the whole
process off we'll call the merge sort
function with the list of numbers we
loaded and print the result
let's save this
and we'll try it out on our file with
eight numbers
python merge sort dot pi
numbers
eight dot text
and it prints out the sorted list
but again this seems pretty magical
let's add some print statements to get
some insight into what it's doing
first we'll print the unsorted list so
we can refer to it we'll add a print
statement right before we call the merge
sort function for the first time
then we'll add another print statement
within the merge sort function right
after the recursive calls this will show
us the sorted left half and right half
that it's returning again don't worry
about the fancy python formatting string
it just keeps the values neatly aligned
let me resize my console
clear the screen
and then we'll try running this again
what we're seeing are the values being
returned from the recursive merge sort
function calls not the original calls to
merge sort so what you see here is after
we reach the base case with a list
that's only one item in length and the
recursive calls start returning
the original list gets split into two
unsorted halves four six three and two
and nine seven three and five
the first half gets split in half again
four and six and three and two
and each of those halves is halved again
into single element lists
there's nothing to sort in the single
element list so they're returned from
the merge sort function as is
those single element lists get merged
into two sub lists and sorted as they do
so the four and six sub-list looks the
same after sorting as it did before
sorting but the three and the two get
sorted as they're combined into a
sub-list the new order is two three
the order is shifted again when those
two sub-lists get combined back into a
single list two three four six
then we recursively sort the right half
of the original list
nine seven three five
it gets split in half again nine seven
and three five
and each of those halves get broken into
single element lists
there's nothing to sort there so the
single element lists are returned as is
the first two are sorted as they're
merged seven nine and so are the second
three five
and then those two sub lists get sorted
as they're combined into another sub
list three five seven nine
and finally everything is sorted as it's
merged back into the full sorted list
two three three four five six seven nine
that's how merge sort works on a list of
eight numbers let's see if it works on a
bigger list
first i'll remove the two print
statements so we don't get an
overwhelming amount of debug output
then i'll run it on a list of ten
thousand items python merge sort dot pi
numbers ten thousand dot
text
not only did it work it was pretty fast
but which is faster merge sort or quick
sort we'll look at that next
i've removed the call to print that
displays the sorted list at the end of
our selection sort quick sort and merge
sort scripts
that way it'll still run the sort but
the output won't get in the way of our
comparing runtimes
let's try running each of these scripts
and see how long it takes
time python
selection sort we'll do that one first
numbers
10 000 dot text
we combine the user and sys results and
that gives us about six seconds
now let's try quick sort time python
quick sort
dot pi numbers
ten thousand dot text
much faster less than a second and
finally time python
merge sort dot pi numbers ten thousand
dot text
a little longer but far less than a
second so even on a list with just 10
000 numbers selection sort takes many
times as long as quicksort and merge
sort
and remember i ran the selection sort
script on a file with a million numbers
and it took so long that my workspace
timed out before it completed
it looks like selection sort is out of
the running as a viable sorting
algorithm it may be easy to understand
and implement but it's just too slow to
handle the huge data sets that are out
in the real world
now let's try quicksort and merge sort
on our file with a million numbers and
see how they compare there time python
quicksort dot pi
numbers
million
dot text
looks like it took about 11 seconds of
cpu time
now let's try merge sort time python
merge sort dot pi
numbers
1 million
dot text
that took about 15 seconds of cpu time
it looks like quicksort is marginally
faster than merge sort on this sample
data
we had to learn a lot of details for
each algorithm we've covered in this
course developers who need to implement
their own algorithms often need to
choose an algorithm for each and every
problem they need to solve and they
often need to discuss their decisions
with other developers can you imagine
needing to describe all the algorithms
in this same level of detail all the
time you'd spend all your time in
meetings rather than programming
that's why big o notation was created as
a way of quickly describing how an
algorithm performs as the data set it's
working on increases in size
big o notation lets you quickly compare
several algorithms to choose the best
one for your problem
the algorithms we've discussed in this
course are very well known some job
interviewers are going to expect you to
know their big o run times so let's look
at them
remember that the n in big o notation
refers to the number of elements you're
operating on with selection sort you
need to check each item in the list to
see if it's the lowest so you can move
it over to the sorted list so that's in
operations
suppose you're doing selection sort on a
list of five items and in this case
would be five so that's five operations
before you can move an item to the
sorted list
but with selection sort you have to loop
over the entire list for each item you
want to move there are five items in the
list and you have to do five comparisons
to move each one so it's more like 5
times 5 operations or if we replace 5
with n it's n times n or n squared
but wait you might say half of that 5 by
5 grid of operations is missing because
we're testing one fewer item in the
unsorted list with each pass so isn't it
more like one half times n times n
and this is true we're not doing a full
n squared operations
but remember in big o notation as the
value of n gets really big constants
like one half become insignificant and
so we discard them
the big o runtime of selection sword is
widely recognized as being o n squared
quicksort requires one operation for
each element of the list it's sorting
it needs to select a pivot first and
then it needs to sort elements into
lists that are less than or greater than
the pivot
so that's n operations to put that
another way if you have a list of eight
items then n is eight so it will take
eight operations to split the list
around the pivot
but of course the list isn't sorted
after splitting it around the pivot just
once you have to repeat those eight
operations several times in the best
case you'll pick a pivot that's right in
the middle of the list so that you're
dividing the list exactly in half
then you keep dividing the list in half
until you have a list with a length of
one
the number of times you need to divide n
in half until you reach one is expressed
as log n
so you need to repeat n sorting
operations log n times that leaves us
with the best case run time for quick
sort of o n log n
but that's the best case what about the
worst case well if you pick the wrong
pivot you won't be dividing the list
exactly in half if you pick a really bad
pivot the next recursive call to
quicksort will only reduce the list
length by one
since our quicksort function simply
picks the first item to use as a pivot
we can make it pick the worst possible
pivot repeatedly simply by giving it a
list that's sorted in reverse order
if we pick the worst possible pivot
every time we'll have to split the list
once for every item it contains and then
do end sorting operations on it
you already know another sorting
algorithm that only manages to reduce
the list by one element with each pass
selection sort
selection sort has a runtime of o n
squared and in the worst case that's the
run time for quicksort as well
so which do we consider when trying to
decide whether to use quicksort the best
case or the worst case
well as long as your implementation
doesn't just pick the first item as a
pivot which we did so we could
demonstrate this issue
it turns out that on average quicksort
performs closer to the best case
many quicksort implementations
accomplish this simply by picking a
pivot at random on each recursive loop
here we are sorting our reverse sorted
data again but this time we pick pivots
at random which reduces the number of
recursive operations needed
sure random pivots sometimes give you
the best case and sometimes you'll
randomly get the worst case but it all
averages out over multiple calls to the
quick sort function
now with merge sort there's no pivot to
pick your list of n items always gets
divided in half log n times
that means merged sort always has a big
o runtime of o and log in
contrast that with quicksort which only
has a runtime of o and log n in the best
case in the worst case quick sorts
runtime is o n squared
and yet out in the real world quicksort
is more commonly used than merge sort
now why is that if quicksort's big o
runtime can sometimes be worse than
merge sorts
this is one of those situations where
big o notation doesn't tell you the
whole story all big o can tell you is
the number of times an operation is
performed it doesn't describe how long
that operation takes
and the operation mergesor performs
repeatedly takes longer than the
operation quicksort performs repeatedly
big-o is a useful tool for quickly
describing how the runtime of an
algorithm increases is the data set it's
operating on gets really really big
but you can't always choose between two
algorithms based just on their big o
runtimes sometimes there's additional
info you need to know about an algorithm
to make a good decision
now that we can sort a list of items
we're well on our way to being able to
search a list efficiently as well we'll
look at how to do that in the next stage
[Music]
now that we've covered sorting
algorithms the groundwork has been laid
to talk about searching algorithms
if you need to search through an
unsorted list of items binary search
isn't an option because you have no idea
which half of the list contains the item
you're looking for your only real option
is to start at the beginning and compare
each item in the list to your target
value one at a time until you find the
value you're looking for
this algorithm is called linear search
or sequential search because the search
proceeds in a straight line or sequence
even though linear search is inefficient
searching for just one name will happen
so fast that we won't be able to tell
anything useful about the algorithm's
runtime so let's suppose we had a
hundred different names and that we
needed to know where they appear in a
list of unsorted names
here's some code that demonstrates
as usual this code at the top isn't
relevant to the search algorithm it's
just like the code that loaded a list of
numbers from a file in the previous
stage but this code calls a different
function load strings that loads a list
of strings in
if you want the load strings python code
we'll have it for you in the teacher's
notes
here's a separate hard-coded list
containing the 100 names we're going to
search for we'll loop through each name
in this list and pass it to our search
function to get the index within the
full list where it appears
now let's implement the search function
compared to the sorting algorithms this
is going to be short the index of item
function takes the python list you want
to search through and a single target
value you want to search for
now we need to loop over each item in
the list the range function gives us a
range of numbers from its first argument
up to but not including its second
argument so if our list had a length of
5 this would loop over the indexes 0
through 4.
we test whether the list item at the
current index matches our target
if it does then we return the index of
the current item this will exit the
index of item function without looping
over the remaining items in the list
if we reach the end of the loop without
finding the target value that means it
wasn't in the list so instead of
returning an index we return the special
python value none which indicates the
absence of a value
other languages have similar values like
nil or null but if yours doesn't you
might have to return a value that would
otherwise be impossible like an index of
negative 1.
now let's call our new search function
we start by looping over the list of 100
values we're looking for we're using the
values themselves this time not their
indexes within the list so there's no
need to mess with python's range
function here's the actual call to the
index of item function we pass it the
full list of names that we loaded from
the file plus the name we want to search
for within that list then we store the
index it returns in a variable
and lastly we print the index we get
back from the index of item function
let's save this and go to our console
and see if it works
python linear search dot pi
names
unsorted dot text
and it'll print out the list of indexes
for each name
i actually set it up so that the last
two items in the list of names we're
going to search for corresponded to the
first and last name within the file
so if we open up our unsorted.txt file
we'll see mary rosenberger is the first
name and alonso viviano is the last name
and those are the last two values in our
list of names we're searching for
so it returned an index of zero for that
second to last name and you can see that
name here on line one of the file
the line numbering starts at one and the
python list indexes start at zero so
that makes sense
and for the last name it returned an
index of 109873
and you can see that name here on line
109 874 so we can see that it's
returning the correct indexes
but right now we're just searching for a
hundred different names in a list of one
hundred thousand names in the real world
we're going to be looking for many more
names than that within much bigger lists
than that can we do this any faster yes
but we'll need to use the binary search
algorithm and for that to work we need
to sort our list of strings we'll do
that in the next video
before we can use the binary search
algorithm on our list of names we need
to sort it let's do that now we need to
load our unsorted list of names from a
file sorted and write the sorted names
back out to a new file
again this code at the top just loads a
file full of strings into a list
we'll use our quick sort method to sort
the list of names its code is completely
unchanged from when you saw it in the
previous stage
we just call our quick sort function on
the list of names loaded from the file
and save the list to a variable
then we loop through each name in the
sorted list
and we print that name
that's all there is to it let's save
this script and try running it
python
quicksort strings stop pi
and we'll pass it the
names unsorted.text file
let me resize the console window here a
little bit
that prints the sorted list of names out
to the terminal but we need it in a file
so we'll do what's called a redirect of
the program's output we'll run the same
command as before but at the end we'll
put a greater than sign followed by the
path to a file that we want the program
output written to names
sorted dot text
redirecting works not only on linux
based systems like workspaces but also
on macs and even on windows machines you
just need to be careful because if you
redirect to an existing file its
contents will be overwritten without
asking you
let me refresh the list of files in the
sidebar
and you'll see that we now have a new
sorted dot text file in the names
directory
it's the same number of lines as the
unsorted dot text file but all the names
are sorted now
now we can load this file of sorted
names into a list and we'll be able to
use that list with the binary search
algorithm we'll see how to do that next
now that we have our list of names
sorted we can use the binary search
algorithm on it let's see if we can use
it to speed up our search for the
indexes of 100 names
binary search keeps narrowing down the
list until it has the value it's looking
for it's faster than linear search
because it discards half the potential
matches each time
our code here at the top of our binary
search script is unchanged from the
previous scripts we just call the load
strings function to load our 100 000
sorted names from a file
here we've hard coded the list of 100
names we're going to search for again
it's identical to the list from the
linear search script except that i've
again changed the last two names to
correspond to the names on the first and
last lines of the file we'll be loading
now let's write the function that will
implement our binary search algorithm
like the linear search function before
it'll take two arguments the first is
the list we're going to search through
and the second is the target value we'll
be searching for again the binary search
function will return the index it found
the value at or the special value none
if it wasn't found
binary search is faster than a linear
search because it discards half the
values it has to search through each
time to do this it needs to keep track
of a range that it still needs to search
through
to start that range is going to include
the full list
the first variable will track the lowest
index in the range we're searching to
start it's going to be 0 the first index
in the full list
likewise the last variable will track
the highest index in the range we're
searching to start we'll set it to the
highest index in the full list
if the first and last variables are
equal then it means the size of the
search range has shrunk to zero and
there is no match until that happens
though we'll keep looping to continue
the search we want to divide the list of
potential matches in half each time to
do that we need to check the value
that's in the middle of the range we're
searching in
we add the indexes in the first and last
variables then divide by two to get
their average we might get a fractional
number which can't be used as a list
index so we also round down using
python's double slash floor division
operator
all this will give us the index of the
list element that's the midpoint of the
range we're searching we store that in
the midpoint variable
whoops looks like my indentation got
mixed up there let me fix that real
quick there we go now we test whether
the list element at the midpoint matches
the target value
if it does we return the midpoint index
without looping any further our search
is complete
otherwise if the midpoint element's
value is less than the target value
then we know that our target value can't
be at the midpoint or any index prior to
that so we move the new start of our
search range to just after the old
midpoint
otherwise the midpoint element's value
must have been greater than the target
value
we know that our target value can't be
at the midpoint or any index after that
so we move the new end of our search
range to just before the old midpoint
by unindenting here we mark the end of
the loop if the loop completes it means
the search range shrank to nothing
without our finding a match and that
means there's no matching value in the
list so we return the special python
value none to indicate this
lastly just as we did in our linear
search script we need to search for each
of the 100 names we loop over each name
in our hard-coded list
and we call the binary search function
with the sorted list of names we're
going to load from the file and the
current name we're searching for
we store the returned list index in the
index variable
and finally we print that variable
let's save this and go to our console
and try running it
python
binarysearch.pi
and it's important to give it the name
of the sorted file if it loads the
unsorted file the binary search won't
work so names
sorted dot text
again it prints out the list of indexes
for each name
i once again set it up so the last two
items in the list of names we're going
to search for corresponded to the first
and last name in the file
so it returned an index of zero for the
second to last name
and you can see that name
here's the second to last name aaron
augustine
you can see that name here on line one
of the file
and for the last name it returned an
index of one zero nine eight seven three
and you can see that name here on line
one zero nine eight seven four
let's check the third to last name for
good measure it looks like an index of
97022 was printed for that name stephen
daras
let's search for steve and daras within
the file
and here it is on line 97023
remember that line numbers start on one
instead of zero so this actually matches
up with the printed list index of 97022
it looks like our binary search script
is working correctly
let's try our linear search and binary
search scripts out with the time command
and see how they compare i've commented
out the lines that print the indexes of
matches in the two scripts
that way they'll still call their
respective search functions what the 100
names we're searching for but they won't
actually print the indexes out so we
won't have a bunch of output obscuring
the results of the time command
first let's try the linear search script
time python
linear search dot pi
names
and we can just use the unsorted list of
names for linear search
remember we want to ignore the real
result and add the user and sys results
together
it looks like it took about .9 seconds
for linear search to find the 100 names
in the list of one hundred thousand
now let's try timing the binary search
script time
python
binarysearch.pi
names and for this one we need to use
the sorted list of names
looks like that took around a quarter
second so less than half as long
bear in mind that part of this time is
spent loading the file of names into a
list the difference between linear
search and binary search will be even
more pronounced as you search through
bigger lists or search for more items
let's wrap up the course by looking at
the big o runtimes for linear search and
binary search these are going to be much
simpler to calculate than the sorting
algorithms were
for linear search you need to do one
comparison to the target value for each
item in the list again theoretically we
could find the target value before
searching the whole list but big o
notation is only concerned with the
worst case where we have to search the
entire list so for a list of eight items
that means eight operations
the big o runtime for linear search is o
n where n is the number of items we're
searching through
this is also known as linear time
because when the number of items and
number of operations are compared on a
graph the result is a straight line
linear search looks pretty good until
you compare it to binary search for
binary search the number of items you
have to search through and therefore the
number of operations is cut in half with
each comparison
remember the number of times you can
divide n by two until you reach one is
expressed as log n so the run time of
binary search in big o notation is o log
n
even for very large values of n that is
very large lists you have to search
through the number of operations needed
to search is very small binary search is
a very fast efficient algorithm
that's our tour of sorting and searching
algorithms be sure to check the
teacher's notes for opportunities to
learn more thanks for watching